GENTLEMEN WE'RE GONNA GET
STARTED WITH HE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA YOU CHAIR THE
FIRST MEETING OF THE YEAR I
THINK WHAT.
YEAH SECOND.
SECOND OKAY WELL WELCOME SECOND
MEETING EARLIER.
WE DO HAVE A.
TOO LONG OF AN AGENDA WE ARE.
WAITING FOR A COUPLE OF AUTHORS
TO COME THEY ARE IN ROUTE BUT WE
DO HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL GET
THAT STARTED.
I'M SECRETARY PICCOLO.
PRESIDENT.
HELLO.
RIO.
WHY HERE?
TO.
EGGMAN.
GLORIA.
FIRST PRESIDENT.
KALRA.
BEING.
OFFICE.
RUBIO.
SOLACE PRESENT
WOULD.
OKAY.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
ASIAN NOT
COMMITTEE.
YEAH LOOK AT THE QSAR COUNTER
THAT THE MOTION.
SECOND BY MISTER SOLACE.
MY MISSION BIGELOW SEGMENTS
CELLS.
ROCCA.
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE. EMOTION
AS.
AND IT.
MISSION.
EDUARDO GARCIA I.
GARCIA I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI. CHOICE I CHU. CHU AYE
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA. HARPER FLY HARPER AYE
KALRA. KALRA AYE LEVINE. LEVINE
AYE.
MATHIS.
RUBIO.
SOLACE BY ALICE I WOULD.
MISTER GALLAGHER.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE
CONSENT CALENDAR YOUR BILL. I.
GALLAGHER ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE. NINETEEN ZERO FOUR AT NIGHT
BECAUSE THERE WILL KEEP THE A
ROLL OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO
ADD ON.
I KNOW IT'S A TRADITION THAT THE
CHAIR GOAL AT THE END.
BUT OPPOSITE MY BILLS OF. MISTER
LEVINE WILL YOU CHAIR.
HOW MUCH GALLAGHER TO?
GALLAGHER.
I TRIED. I TRIED MATH.
OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN.
WHICH ONE WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
LIKE TO DO NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
FIRST OR HER NIGHT NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN OKAY.
IT WAS A GOOD YEAR AND PROCEED
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN.
BUT NINETEEN EIGHTEEN IS THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF OUTDOOR
RECREATION ACT
CALIFORNIA'S OUTDOOR RECREATION
ECONOMY IS THE LARGEST IN THE
UNITED STATES GENERATING OVER
NINETY TWO BILLION.
IN ECONOMIC STIMULUS AND CREATED
MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DIRECT JOBS.
DESPITE THE SIZE AND IMPACT OF
OUR STATE'S OUTDOOR RECREATION
ECONOMY THERE'S NO SINGLE STATE
LEVEL OFFICER GOVERNMENT.
BODY THAT IS FOCUSED ON BRINGING
THE EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE OF
THE DIVERSE BODY. AS FOCUSED.
PACIFIC ME.
TO ATTRACT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES A AS A RESULT OF
THE CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR ECONOMY.
AT NINETEEN EIGHTEEN WILL
ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF
SUSTAINABLE OUTDOOR RECREATION
IN THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
PACIFIC IN THE OFFICE WILL HELP
PLAN AND IMPLEMENT. A
COORDINATED STRATEGY IS TO
DEVELOP JOBS AND ECONOMIC GROWTH
IN THE OUTDOOR RECREATION
INDUSTRY.
DEVELOP STRATEGIES CONCERNING
OUTDOOR RECREATION AMENITIES AND
EXPERIENCES AND TO SERVE AS A
CENTRAL POINT OF THE CONTACT
AMONGST
THE MULTITUDE OF FACTORS
INVOLVED IN THIS SECTOR.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR.
I'D YOU HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YES GOT.
GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE.
NOW NAME IS TAYLOR BRIAN FEENEY
I'M THE STATE AND LOCAL POLICY
MANAGER FOR THE OUTDOOR INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN. AND AFTER
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IS THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
SUPPLIERS RETAILERS
MANUFACTURERS OF. THAT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR OUTDOOR RECREATION
INDUSTRY SO. ACROSS THE NATION
WE HAVE MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED
MEMBERS.
OF WHICH TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
ARE CALIFORNIA BASED.
WE'VE RECENTLY SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF SUPPORT FROM THIRTY OF
THESE COMPANIES THAT HAVE A
GROWING COALITION.
OF SUPPORTERS WHO UNDERSTAND THE
BENEFITS.
EXCUSE ME.
THIS COULD BRING TO THEIR
BUSINESSES AND ORGANIZATIONS.
AND TO RESIDENTS AND VISITORS TO
RECREATION HERE AND TO THE STATE
AS A WHOLE.
AND OFFICE OF SUSTAINABLE AFTER
RECREATIONAL CENTRALIZE
CALIFORNIA'S OUT TO RECREATION
ECONOMY ALLOWING INCREASED
COORDINATION BETWEEN STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND INDUSTRY SIX
STAKEHOLDERS ON ISSUES IMPACTING
INCREASED ACCESS.
TO CALIFORNIA'S RECREATION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE GROWTH AN ATTRACTION OF
OUTDOOR BUSINESSES
AND COLLABORATION BETWEEN STATE
AND LOCAL TOURISM AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OFFICES.
NO I IS BEEN A SUPPORTER OF
EFFORTS THAT HAVE ESTABLISHED
SIMILAR OFFICES ABOUT TO
RECREATIONS OR OVER ACTS AS WE
CALL THEM. AND SEVEN OTHER
STATES.
WELL UTAH AND COLORADO WHERE THE
FIRST SUCH STATES TO.
ESTABLISH THESE OFFICES
CALIFORNIA'S NORTHERN NEIGHBORS
IN OREGON WASHINGTON.
HAVE SIMILARLY ESTABLISHED
OFFICES ARE GOVERNOR'S LEVEL
POSITIONS.
IT WE SAW PROLIFERATION OF THESE
OFFICES CREATED THE LAST YEAR
AND A HALF WITH MONTANA WYOMING
AND NORTH CAROLINA ALL JOINING
THE RANKS.
THE COMMON THREAD HERE IS THAT
THE STATE'S AND SEVERAL OTHERS
ACTIVELY CONSIDERING THEIR OWN
OFFICES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS
ECONOMIC AND JOB OPPORTUNITIES.
THAT OUT TO RECREATION OFFERS TO
OUR STATE.
THEY ALSO RECOGNIZE THE UNIQUE
INTERSECTION THAT OUT RECREATION
DOES AND CAN PLAY BETWEEN HEALTH
HEALTHCARE. AND EDUCATION
SYSTEMS NATIONWIDE.
STATES THAT HAVE.
REX UNDERWEAR HELPING THEIR
BUSINESSES UTILIZE STATE
PROGRAMS AND INCENTIVES THAT ARE
INTO HELPING SMALL TO MEDIUM
SIZE BUSINESSES THRIVE.
THERE CONNECTING WITH
CONSERVATION AGENCIES AND
PARTNERS TO SHARE INFORMATION
AND DATA ABOUT WHAT RECREATION
USERS WANT AND NEED.
THEY'RE PROMOTING OUTDOORS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR STATEWIDE
TOURISM OFFICE.
THE REVIEWING AMENDING AND EVEN
SOMETIMES CREATING NEW POLICIES
TO HELP MAKE ACCESS TO THE
OUTDOORS MORE EQUITABLE TO THEIR
STATES RESIDENTS.
AND AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
MENTIONED CALIFORNIA HAS THE
LARGEST OUTDOOR RECREATION
ECONOMY AND THE U. S. ITS
EMPLOYMENT FIGURES ALONE.
SUPPORTING SIX HUNDRED NINETY
ONE THOUSAND JOBS ANNUALLY.
IT'S LARGER. THAN TELEVISION
FILM AND WINE IN THE STATE.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO INVEST.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT COMPONENT
ABOUT HER OF OF CALIFORNIA'S OUT
TO RECREATION ECONOMY AND I ASK
YOU FOR YES VOTE TODAY.
RIGHT.
ADDITIONAL WITNESS CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM NOT IS AHMED THE
EXPERIENCES MANAGER FOR THE
SIERRA MARKET FOR THE ARMY I CO
AUTHOR. ON BEHALF OF OUR YEAH I
IT'S MY PLEASURE HERE TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
I'M ALSO HERE TO REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA OUTDOOR RECREATION
PARTNERS CORP.
DARIA CHO OPPOSE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION COOP MEMBERS IN NEARLY
TWO THOUSAND EMPLOYEES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. SINCE TWENTY TWELVE
THE COOP HAS HOSTED OVER TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND OUTDOOR
ENTHUSIASTS IN CALIFORNIA TO OUR
FIELD AN IN STORE EVENTS AND
CLASSES FOCUSED ON RECREATING
OUTSIDE.
AS AN OUTDOOR RECREATION COMPANY
IN CALIFORNIA WE BENEFIT FROM
THE VAST AN IMPRESSIVE PUBLIC
LANDS NATURAL RESOURCES IN AFTER
SPACES THAT MAKE CALIFORNIANS
WANT TO BE OUT DOORS.
I'VE BEEN WITH ARI I SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN AND I'M LUCKY TO
BE IN A UNIQUE POSITION IN THE
OUTDOOR INDUSTRY. I'M PART OF A
COOPER THAT IS DEDICATED TO
EDUCATING ITS MEMBERS AND THE
PUBLIC ABOUT OUTDOOR RECREATION
PRACTICES WHILE PROVIDING
QUALITY EQUIPMENT.
AS PART OF THIS COOPER I OVERSEE
A PROGRAM THAT DIRECTLY PROVIDES
OUR MEMBERS IN THE PUBLIC
WITHOUT OR EXPERIENCES THEY MAY
NOT SEEK BY THEMSELVES.
COMPANIES LIKE OURS.
AND HUNDREDS OF OTHER
RECREATIONAL INDUSTRY PARTNERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA ARE ENABLING
CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE
TRANSFORMATIVE EXPERIENCES IN
THE OUTDOORS.
OUR INDUSTRY IS BEING SHAPED
EVERYDAY BY CONSUMERS WHO SHOW A
PREFERENCE FOR EXPERIENCES AND
LOOK TO CONNECT THROUGH
TECHNOLOGY PRODUCTS PATHWAYS IN
NEW WAYS TO RECREATION.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN CREATES THE
OFFICE OF SUSTAINABLE OUTDOOR
RECREATION THAT WILL BE A FOCAL
POINT FOR THE ULTRA RECREATION
INDUSTRY IN MEETING THOSE
CHALLENGES.
PUT IN FIRMS INCREDIBLE ECONOMIC
STATE POWERHOUSE THAT THE
OUTDOOR RECREATION ECONOMY IS TO
CALIFORNIA.
YEAH ALSO CREATES A VISIBLE
PLATFORM FOR STATE LEADERS TO
WORK WITH THE INDUSTRY AND
DEVELOPMENT EMPLOY STRATEGIES TO
BETTER POSITION CALIFORNIA.
TO COMPANIES AND BRANDS THAT
WANT TO EXPAND OR RELOCATE.
AT A TIME WHEN EVERY STATE IS
LOOKING FOR WAYS TO BE
ATTRACTIVE AND COMPETITIVE TO
EMPLOYERS GREAT TALENT AND
GROWING INDUSTRIES CREATING A
NEW OFFICE ABOUT THE RECREATION
IS CALIFORNIA IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I KNOW OUR YEAH AND MANY OF OUR
CORPORATE PARTNERS WILL GREATLY
BENEFIT FROM THIS NEW OFFICE
EQUALLY VALUABLE THE
COLLABORATION OFFICE WILL BUILD
BETWEEN THOSE THAT ARE CREATING.
MANUFACTURING AND SELLING OUT OR
RECREATION EXPERIENCES GOODS AND
ARE IN A CRITICAL POSITION OF
PROVIDING PROGRAMMING AN OUTDOOR
EXPERIENCES TO HELP ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
SPECIAL YOU THINK COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS IN
AN EQUITABLE WAY.
THE DUAL MISSION OF THIS OFFICE
ENVISIONED AN EP NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN IS WHAT MAKES US UNIQUE
A NEEDED FOR CALIFORNIA. THERE
IS GREAT POTENTIAL FOR TAPPING
INTO INNOVATION TECHNOLOGY
CONSERVATION AND RECREATION
EXPERTISE THAT EXISTS IN THE
COMPANIES BUSINESSES RECREATION
PROVIDERS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE DEDICATED
TO THIS WORK.
AND OFFICE ABOUT DIRECTING
CALIFORNIA WILL BE A GREAT
RESOURCE FOR INDUSTRY AWAY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MAINTAINING GROW
ITS OWN COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE IN
HELPING DEVELOP RECRUIT INGROWN
YOU AT THE RECREATION LEADERS
AND COMPANIES IN THE STATE. I
ASK YOUR A VOTE FOR AB NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU. AND I HAVE JUST.
I KNOW WE GOT A LOT TO GET
THROUGH SELF WITNESSES COULD TRY
TO KEEP TO THEIR THREE THREE
MINUTES TOTAL. TOTAL THAT WOULD
HELP.
I MOVE THAT BUT YES ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TWENTY MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
RECALL MONSTER DID NOT A WITH
THE TRUST FOR
THE GLANDS IN SUPPORT.
IT'S ABOUT IN LAS POTTER ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE CLEAR OPEN
SPACE AUTHORITY IN TAHOE LINES
AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA AND MO ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND SUPPORT.
MICHELLE ROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK FOUNDATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PAUL MAY SO THE CIVIC FOR A
TRUST ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN GALLAGHER
MEMBERS DUCK HOUSTON ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA REC PARK AND REC
SOCIETY EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT.
NORTH LAKE TAHOE RESORT
ASSOCIATIONS HERE BUSINESS
COUNCIL CINEMA COUNTY REGIONAL
PARKS IN TAHOE CITY PUBLIC
UTILITY DISTRICT DOWN SUPPORT.
I THINK YOU BUT ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I'D SEEN NOT ANY QUESTIONS.
FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
S. SECOND.
I MOVE BY.
SO REMEMBER CHIU AND SECONDED
BY.
SIMILAR BIGELOW.
NEITHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
A GOOD THAT WE WILL CALL THE
CULT BUT WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
INJECTIONS IN CLOSING I THINK OF
A TWO WITNESSES HAVE ARTICULATED
QUITE WELL WHY THIS OFFICE. TO
DO CALIFORNIA WELL AND TO AS I
LOOK AROUND THE ROOM I THINK
EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE IN
SOME FORM OR ANOTHER.
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
REALLY.
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF. THE OUTDOOR
ECONOMY IF ALREADY.
IT ISN'T OCCURRING IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND.
OUT YOU KNOW JUST THE MYSELF UP
LOOKING AT THE HOW MANY PEOPLE
VISIT THE JOSHUA TREE AREA AND
OUR DISTRICT.
AND OTHER OUTDOOR ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST IN.
FIFTY SIX SEVEN DISTRICT AND NO
THERE'S SOME HUNTING NICHOLS ON
IN SOME PARTS OF.
TYPICAL DISTRICT IN OF COURSE
WAS KNOW QUESTION AND MISTER
HARPER'S ENTERS THE SURFING AND.
SALAS. AND OTHERS TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF.
OUTDOOR ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES
THERE'S ONE SO I JUST I WANT TO
OPEN UP THE.
ETERNITY FOR ALCOA AUTHORS
IF ANYONE IS OF INTERESTS AT TO
JOIN.
I IN THIS EFFORT BEEN AGAIN
RESPECT LAST FOR RIVAL.
ANY CO AUTHORS WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED. ABOUT.
I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED CORRALLED
MISTER SOLACE TO LIVING.
WOULD.
WE DO THAT RIGHT HERE.
I ALL ADD MYSELF TO THAT AS
WELL.
AND.
OKAY SO MOVED AND SECONDED.
.
CALLED COLUMN LOVE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA I. GARCIA.
GALLAGHER.
I. GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI NOW AYE CHOI AYE CHU. CHU
AYE FRIEDMAN. GLORIA.
HARPER.
KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I MATHIS.
RUBIO. SOLACE
SOLACE I WOULD.
WOULD I.
EIGHT.
I'M.
SO LEVELS OUT ON EIGHT TO.
EIGHT ZERO BOTH.
NO ACTUALLY WILL KEEP TO ITS ON
CALL.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT WE'LL HAVE MISTER GRAY
I'M UP IN REPRESENT
.
THE MORNING I WAS CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ON.
CHOPPER SEAT.
LARGER.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE.
MEMBERS IS MODEST BUT IMPORTANT
BILL TO ADDRESS THE DRAMATIC
DECLINE IN THE NUMBER OF JUNIOR
OUTDOOR SPORTSMEN AND WOMEN A
CALIFORNIA HAD SEEN OVER THE
PAST TWENTY YEARS.
AS NOTED THE NOW SAYS.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY THEIR TWO
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND JUNIOR
HUNTERS IN CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THAT NUMBER HAS DROPPED
TO JUST FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED.
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE. IN
LARGE PART DEPENDENT ON THE
REVENUES GENERATED BY OUTDOOR
SPORTING ACTIVITIES TO FUND
VITAL CONSERVATION AND
MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES.
IF THE NUMBER OF HUNTERS IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO PLUMMET.
THESE REVENUES WE PUT
SIGNIFICANT JEOPARDY
THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO MAKE
HUNTING MORE AFFORDABLE FOR
YOUTH.
WHO WE NEED FRANKLY TO BECOME
THE NEXT GENERATION OF HUNTERS?
ONE OF THE LARGEST BARRIERS FOR
CALIFORNIANS INTERESTED IN THIS
TRADITION. IS THE UNNECESSARILY
HIGH PRICE
USED BIG GAME TAX.
WHERE'S CALIFORNIA JUNIOR
HUNTERS PAY FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS FOR HELP TAG YOUTH IN
MONTANA COLORADO PAY TEN DOLLARS
AND SEVENTY FIVE CENTS.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE ATTEMPTS
TO ADDRESS THIS DIVIDE BY GIVING
JUNIOR HUNTERS ACCESS TO LOWER
COST TAGS.
FOR ANTELOPE ELK BAIRD BIGHORN
RAM.
THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
NUMBER OF TOTAL TAX ON OFFER
WHICH IS DETERMINED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
BASED ON BIOLOGICAL FACTORS.
BY KEEPING THE BILL LIMITED TO
THE SPECIES WE REMOVE FINANCIAL
BARRIERS FOR JUNIOR HUNTER
PARTICIPATION WHILE KEEPING IN
MIND THE FINANCIAL HEALTH OF THE
BIG GAME MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT.
THE BILL HAS AN ESTIMATED PRICE
TAG OF JUST OVER THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND PER YEAR FROM ACCOUNT
WHICH RECEIVES ONE AND A HALF TO
TWO MILLION IN REVENUE ANNUALLY.
AND CURRENTLY HAS A RESERVE OF
OVER EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HUNTING CONSERVATION COALITION
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND SAN
DIEGO COUNTY WILDLIFE FEDERATION
AMONG OTHERS.
MISTER CHAIR WOULD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR VOTE WILL BE
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
YOU WITNESSES PLACE.
MORE MUCH CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M
ROY GRIFFITH SPEAKING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE.
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
COALITION
I'M RETIRED GAME WARDEN THIRTY
YEARS WITH THE DEPARTMENT AND
THE LAST TWELVE OF WHICH I
BECAME VERY AWARE OF THIS
SITUATION HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY. I'M HONORED TO WORK WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY ON THIS
BILL AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
TAKE SOME FORM OF ACTION.
IT ANNUALLY SPORTSMEN AND WOMEN
BRING IN OVER ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS JUST IN LICENSES ALONG
WITH THE AT AND TAGS ITS UPS THE
NUMBER TWENTY SIX MILLION.
HUNTERS FOR THE PURCHASE OF
AMMUNITION AND FIREARMS ANOTHER
SPORTING EQUIPMENT BRING IN OVER
FORTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS
AVAILABLE TO THE STATE THESE
DOLLARS ARE HUGE AND CRITICAL
FOR WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT AND
RESOURCE MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA.
MAKING THIS OPPORTUNITY BILLABLE
ALL CALIFORNIA'S NOTCHES
CONSUMERS WHO CHOOSE TO HUNT
THEM BUT FOLKS I JUST WANNA GO
OUT AND SEE AN. AN ALCOR NAM
HOPE FOR ITS OWN INTRINSIC
BEAUTY.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL IS
NOT THE ONLY FIX JUST LIKE
POINTED OUT THAT MANY THINGS GOT
US IN A SITUATION THAT LED TO
THIS DECLINE OF SPORTSMEN AND
WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA LAST THIRTY
YEARS. BUT THIS IS A HUGE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MARKEDLY WITH CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL I JUST NOTE THAT.
HER HUNTING LICENSE.
TAG AND.
STAMPS ARE AMONGST THE HIGHEST
OF ANY STATE IN THE COUNTRY. AND
THAT HUNTER SURVEYS SHOW THAT
COST IS A SIGNIFICANT BARRIER TO
PARTICIPATION SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AGAIN THE OTHER WITNESSES.
SPEAK SUPPORT.
THIS COMPORT.
MEMBERS JOE TO FINALLY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME WARDENS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THE KNOW ONE. ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW
SECOND OF SOLACE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS UNLESS
GOODNESS BIGELOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS FOR THE OFFER BE HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU JOIN TODAY.
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
OF LOCAL AND CHECK CHECK.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THAT THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA I.
SEE I GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE CHU.
CHIU I FRIEDMAN. GLORIA HARPER
AYE HARPER AYE KALRA. LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE MATHIS.
RUBIO SOLACE SOLACE I WOULD.
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS AT ON THANK YOU THINK
RICH CHAIR ALRIGHT. A MEMBER
GIPSON.
TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ON THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE.
WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE THE
WATER.
SERVICE FOR CALIFORNIANS MANY
CALIFORNIA'S RECEIVE THEIR
DRINKING WATER FROM SMALL PUBLIC
ON SYSTEMS THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO
MAINTAIN. THESE TROUBLED SYSTEMS
LACK THE RESOURCES TO FUND THE
ONGOING COST OF MAINTENANCE
NEEDED TO OPERATE EFFECTIVELY.
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS CAN OVERCOME
THESE CHALLENGES BY
CONSOLIDATING WITH THEIR
NEIGHBORING SYSTEMS
CONSOLIDATION. OF WATER SYSTEMS
CAN BE TO SHARE COSTS AND
PROVIDE A BETTER WATER SERVICE
ECONOMY OF SCALE.
ALTHOUGH SOME CITIES MAY WANT TO
VOLUNTARILY CONSOLIDATE THEIR
TROUBLED WATER SYSTEM.
THEY HAVE TO OVERCOME
THESE PARTICULAR BARRIERS ONE
VARIAS THE COST OF HOLDING A
FULL BLOWN ELECTION TO APPROVE
THE SALE OF A SMALL WATER.
SYSTEM.
UNDER EXISTING LAW EVEN IF THEY
CITY HAS WATER SYSTEM WITH ONLY
TEN CONNECTIONS.
A COMPLETE ELECTION ON THE WATER
SKIS ONE OPPONENT ON THE A
COMPLETE ELECTION.
OF WOULD BE NEEDED BEFORE THE
SALE CAN ACTUALLY TAKE PLACE
WHILE THE COST OF HOLDING AN
ELECTION.
IS NOT INSIGNIFICANT TO LARGE
CITIES HOWEVER IS VARIOUS A
SIGNIFICANT AND EXPENSIVE TO
TAXPAYERS OF SMALL COMMUNITIES.
THEREFORE THIS BILL SEEKS TO
MODIFY THE ELECTION REQUIREMENTS
AND ALLOW CITIES TO SAY OUT
THERE SMALL PUBLIC A WATER
SYSTEMS IF IT'S IS IS IN THE
BEST INTERESTS OF THE A
PARTICULAR CITIES OR
JURISDICTIONS. I'M NOT TO
OPERATE.
THESE CHANGES PROVIDES MORE
CALIFORNIANS WERE CLEANER AND
SAFER DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
OF TODAY OF THIS BILL SUPPORTED.
BY.
THE INDIVIDUALS WILL BE
SPEAKING HERE BEFORE YOU KNOW
FEW MOMENTS.
WE HAVE THE MAYOR OF MONTEBELLO
MISSED.
DELGADO AND ALSO WE HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
WATER SUPPLIERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE VOTE AT
THE APPROPRIATE TARNISHES MAY
PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING.
I AM THE MAYOR OF MONTEBELLO IN
LA COUNTY MY NAME IS VANESSA BUT
YOU HAVE THOUGH AND I'M HERE TO
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
SPELL. OUT WE ARE ONE OF THE
AFFECTED CITIES AND WE HAVE A
VERY SMALL WATER SYSTEM ONE OF
FIVE THAT HAS SIXTEEN HUNDRED
FIFTY CUSTOMERS WE'VE HAD TO
INCREASE RATES. A HUNDRED
PERCENT OF THE LAST THREE YEARS
FOR THIS WORKING CLASS AREA. AND
WE STILL RUN A DEFICIT.
SO WE ARE ASKING TO BE ABLE TO
CONSOLIDATE WITH ONE OF THE
OTHER PROVIDERS. AYE WE ARE ALSO
FACING FORTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS TO
THE SYSTEM WHICH WOULD BE SO
COSTLY FOR THE SPORT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED. CUSTOMERS TO ABSORB SO
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AN
URGENT MESSAGE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MMBERS I'M JACK TALKS BAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
SAYS HE ASIAN.
YOUR CALL I TESTIFIED BEFORE
YOU.
ABOUT.
TWO MONTHS AGO PONDA ED THE ON
EARLIER VERSION OF THIS BILL.
YOU'LL RECALL THAT AFTER IT
THAT PASSED OUT OF WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE WAS HELD BY OF THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. SO
THAT THERE WOULD BE.
ADDITIONAL THAT COULD BE
ADDITIONAL REVIEW BY THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL A GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE IN ADDITION TO THIS
COMMITTEE.
.
THE.
BUT A AS A RESULT OF THAT
HEARING.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE HAS
A NUMBER OF CHANGES.
THAT CAME AS A RESULT OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE MEMBERS. OF
THIS COMMITTEE IN AMONG THOSE
CHANGES ARE.
THAT THE.
POTENTIALLY SUBSUMED THAT'S THE
SYSTEM THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
WATER PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
MUST BE WHOLLY WITHIN THE
BOUNDARIES OF THE.
MUNICIPALITY.
IF.
AS
YOU JUST HEARD IF OF RATE
INCREASES NECESSARY TO BRING THE
SUBSUMED ACQUIRED SYSTEM.
OUT OF THE DISREPAIR AND BRING
IT UP TO STANDARD.
THOSE RATES THOSE INCREASES
WITHIN BE PHASED IN OVER TIME IT
WOULDN'T BE ONE BIG. RATE SHOCK
AT EL ALL AT ONCE.
THAT'S A NEW.
PROVISION IN THE BILL.
THERE'S NOW A FORTY FIVE DAY
ALLOWANCE FOR A PROTEST PERIOD
UPON THE.
.
APPROVAL OF THE A RESOLUTION
FROM FROM THE.
THE MUNICIPALITY.
AND.
THE.
THEY HEARING FOR THAT
RESOLUTION.
MUST BE PUBLISHED OR NOTICED.
BEFORE THE.
A RESIDENTS OF THE COMMUNITY.
AND.
THE.
THE RESOLUTION MUST STATE THE
CITY'S INTENDED USE OF THE.
OF THE PROCEEDS AND THEN
FINALLY THERE'S A TIME OUT
PROCESS.
SUCH THAT IF FIFTY PERCENT OF
THE OTHER VOTERS APPROACH.
OF THE INTERESTED PERSONS AS
ITS STATE IN THE BILL PROTESTS.
OF IN THE CITY WOULD HAVE TO
WAIT A YEAR SO THEIR NUMBER OF
CHANGES.
TO THIS BILL BUT THE BY AND
LARGE IT'S IT'S WHAT YOU HEARD
BACK IN JANUARY AND.
WE WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE BUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT.
THE WITNESSES. WHICH IS BIG IN
FAVOR OF THIS MEASURE.
ST AT NO ONE ANY.
THERE'S A MOTION BY MISTER THANK
YOU
CHIU SECOND AND SHE GALLAGHER
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
IS MEASURES SEEN NO ONE.
I QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
TOTALS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
.
GIPSON THINK FOR THIS MEASURE
OBVIOUSLY.
THE WAY I SEE IT IS AND CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG IT'S JUST THE
OPTION OF THE SMALLER. DISTRICTS
IF THEY WISH TO CONSOLIDATE
WHICH USUALLY LEADS TO A
LOWERING OF THEIR WATER RATES
BECAUSE OF THE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE.
I DO APPRECIATE IN THE BILL AND
READING IT I THE LEGISLATION
THAT TALKS ABOUT.
THE ABILITY TO STILL TRIGGER AN
ELECTION.
SHOULD THERE BE AN ISSUE WITH
THE RATE PAYERS.
THEY CAN THEY STILL HAVE THAT
OPTION MOVING FORWARD AS WELL
THERE'S CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT ALL SUPPORT
THANK YOU ISABELLA.
I THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M A CO
AUTHOR OF THE LEGISLATION AND I
THINK THINK THE AUTHOR I'M. FOR
FOR WORKING WITH ME THIS I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL.
TO HAVE BEEN AND I I THINK
ADDING IN THE THE PROVISIONS.
THAT ALLOW THE VOTERS TO TRIGGER
A VOTE IF IF ENOUGH PEOPLE
PROTEST THE DECISION YOU MAKE
PUTS US MORE IN LINE WITH
PROPOSITION TWO EIGHTEEN AND
HELPS PROTECT.
AND THE INTEREST OF TAXPAYERS
ON.
BUT ALSO I MEAN THAT I THINK
THAT THE LARGER ISSUE IS IT IS
AS MADAME MAYOR YOU POINTED OUT.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO
HAVE I COME AT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MYSELF.
AS I KNOW AND AS THE AUTHOR.
AND HAD TO DEAL WITH THIS AND
SIMILAR SITUATION.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHERE WE
HAD A VERY SMALL. SYSTEM THEY
SEE HUNDRED USERS IN A VERY
RURAL COMMUNITY. AND.
WITH REALLY NO OTHER OPTIONS
OTHER THAN TO RAISE RATES AT
SOME PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
.
VERY SIGNIFICANTLY TO DO THAT
CLEAN UP TIED TO DO AND.
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
AND REALLY IF THEY'RE ABLE TO
MERGE WITH ANOTHER SYSTEM.
ECONOMIES OF SCALE THERE FOR
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
JUST MADE A LOT OF SENSE AND SO
HAVING THIS TOOL OUT THERE I
THINK IS.
UNIT AND IS VERY MUCH NEEDED AND
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF SYSTEMS
THAT ARE REALLY JUST KINDA
STRANDED.
ON THEIR OWN AND. YOU KNOW WITH
WITH THE.
WITH THAT SYSTEM IN PLACE RIGHT
NOW REALLY HAVE NOWHERE TO GO IT
OTHER THAN TO RAISE RATES VARY
SIGNIFICANTLY.
AND SO I THINK.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO GET
THIS THIS MEASURE THROUGH AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S HARD
WORK ON THIS.
AND. I WILL BE VOTING IN IN
FAVOR THANK YOU.
QUESTION BUT ADOPTED. YEAH PART
QUESTION.
UP I WOULD SUPPORT DODD DESPAIR
LA. BUT THUS MORE QUESTION IS
THAT DON'T WIN NOT MORE THAN
FIFTY PERCENT OF LA OF REST AND
SO.
A PROTESTER.
AND UP WILL TEST MEANS THAT IN
THE FORM OF A PHYSICAL PRESENCE
IN THE MEETINGS SEWER IN THE
FORM OF.
.
SIGNATURE GATHERING.
AND.
.
A IF THAT HAPPENED IS.
THE MONEY SPUR GOVERNMENT WILL
HAVE TO WAIT A YEAR. IF THE
SECOND YEAR SIMPLY HAPPENED SO
OR BE ANOTHER YEAR DELAY.
Y. HA HOW LONG DOES IT HAVE TO
REPEAT THAT THAT PROCESS.
WHAT WHAT YEAR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH?
IT'S IT'S ONE YEAR BUT IF
THAT'S IF THAT'S THAT MUCH
OPPOSITION I THINK THAT KILLS.
KILLS THE THAT THE SALE.
NOT OPPOSITION MONTH SO. IF IT'S
THAT MUCH OPPOSITION BASING YOUR
EXAMPLE I THINK THE MESSES ROW
CLEAR IT'S NOT A FIRST OF ALL IT
STOPS IMMEDIATELY THEN AWAITS A
ONE YEAR. THEN AS YOU DESCRIBE
IF IT HAPPENS AGAIN A SECOND
YEAR AND THEN A THIRD YEAR I
THINK THE MESSAGE IS VERY CLEAR.
TO THE GOVERNMENTAL BODIES THAT
THERE'S STRONG OPPOSITION TO IT.
BUT IT STOPPED FOUR YEAR.
AND THAT'S HOW WE GONNA COUNT TO
FIFTY PERCENT OR MORE BROUGH
GRAYSON SUPPORT IN ESTA. IN THE
SIGNATURE PHONO THROUGH ITS
PRESENCE OR OR WRITTEN.
OF THE PROTESTS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
DOES IT SEEM NOTE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ON.
THIS SIDE OF.
JACK CLOSED.
AND THERE'S NO JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THERE'S NO.
NOTE OPPOSITE HIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOTH
THANK YOU THANK YOU. OUT ROCCA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
EDUARDO GARCIA I
SEE I.
BUT GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
CARILLO.
CHOI GUY TROY I. CHIU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN. GLORIA.
HARPER NO HARPER NO.
KALRA.
CLARA I LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
RUBIO. REVEAL AYE SOLACE. SOLACE
I WOULD.
OR IT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHR THANK YOU TO ADD ON.
ALL TAKE UP MY SECOND ITEM AND
THEY THINK WE ONLY HAVE ONE
AUTHOR.
REMAINING THAT WOULD BE.
MISTER A GLORIA
.
OKAY THE AB TWO SIXTY THAT
ADVANCE WATER PAYMENTS THIS IS A
BILL.
THAT MAKES CHANGES TO BOTH THE
ADVANCE FUNDING CONDITIONS OF
THE INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT PLAN AND THE STATE
WATER POLLUTION CONTROL
REVOLVING. FUND SMALL COMMUNITY
GRANT.
FUND PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU THAT DON'T MOTION
SECOND TO AND THE.
DISAPPOINTMENT BREVITY HERE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR HYPO.
OKAY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PROCEED CERTAINLY MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DAVID EBENEZER I'M
WITH RURAL COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
CORPORATION BE PROVIDED THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SMALL
RURAL COMMUNITIES.
TO.
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
CURRENTLY THE STATE LAW ALLOWS.
WATER AND WASTEWATER PROJECTS
THAT SERVE DECIDED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
TO RECEIVE A.
FUN AT THAT PRECEDE FUNDING
UNDER THAT.
INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT MANAGEMENT PLAN
FUNDING.
TO THE QUESTION ADVANCES UP TO
FIFTY PERCENT OF THE PROJECT.
IF THERE PROJECT COSTS ARE ONE
MILLION ARE LESS.
IF
THE PROJECT BECAUSE EVEN A
DOLLAR MORE THAN A MILLION
DOLLARS THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR.
OF THE ADVANCES A AND FREQUENTLY
THERE ARE LONG DELAYS IN.
THE REIMBURSEMENT OF UP.
EXPENSES TO THE SMALL
COMMUNITIES SO PUT OF CASH FLOW
BURDEN ON.
THESE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT THEY INCUR PENALTIES
AND ADDITIONAL PROJECT COSTS
FROM. CONTRACTORS.
ALSO A S. B. TOOL EIGHT ONLY
ADDRESSED.
THEIR URBAN PROJECTS.
NOW THERE'S
SIMILAR COMMUNITIES UNDER.
RECEIVING FUNDING UNDER THE
PROP PROPOSITION ONE FUNDING.
AND.
THEY ARE FACING SIMILAR
CHALLENGES.
SO.
WE.
RECENTLY RECEIVED TO.
LINE OF CREDIT REQUESTS FROM
FOR A TO SMALL COMMUNITIES
BOLIVAR DE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
AND PIXLEY PUBLIC UTILITY
DISTRICT.
AND THEY THEY.
BOTH ARE OF.
IN VIOLATION OF STATE STANDARDS
OF FOR.
CHEMICALS IN WATER AND UP OF
BOTH SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN APPROVED
FOR GRANTS UNDER THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD BUT.
BECAUSE OF THAT CHALLENGES.
INHERENT IN THAT SYSTEM THEY
THEY CAME TO US DO SO THAT THEY
CAN KEEP THEIR PAYMENTS GOING
WITH THAT CONTRACTORS AND.
BUT THIS POLL IMPOSES AN
ADDITIONAL LOAN COSTS AND
INTEREST IN PEACE ON THEM.
AND SO WE REQUEST THAT THAT ONE
MILLION CAP ON PROJECT.
SIZE AND BE REMOTE AND A
INSTEAD PUT A CAP ON THE ADVANCE
PAYMENT OF A.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE FIFTY
PERCENT UP ALL PROJECT COSTS
WHICH IT WORSE SMALLER.
AND.
.
WORKED WITH THE THE. DE AFFECTED
AGENCIES TO IMPROVE IT.
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESSES SO THAT
THE STATE ADVANCES.
CAN.
HELP THEM CASH FLOW THE PROJECTS
AND THEN THEY COME BACK.
AND SUBMIT THEIR INVOICES AND
YOU KNOW SO THAT CASH FLOW
BURDEN.
IS BELIEVED
AND I IN THIS WAY A WE BELIEVE
THAT.
THE PROJECTS INTENDED BY THE
STATE.
TO THESE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ALL OF THEM
WOULD BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE AND
BENEFIT FROM THEM.
AND SO WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
FOR THE.
THANK YOU SIRTHAT ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT THAT YOU
HAVE LOTS OF WITH CALIFORNIA'S
WHAT UTILITIES ASSOCIATION WE
APOLOGIZE OUR LETTER WAS LATE
BUT WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S GLENN FARRELL SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY WERE ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
MORNING PAUL MASON WITH PACIFIC
FOREST TRUSTS WE'RE ACTUALLY
INVOLVED IN.
AND A GREAT DREAM THAT REGIONAL
WATER MANAGEMENT PLAN UP IN THE
UPPER SACRAMENTO. AND THE DELAY
WITH REIMBURSEMENT ISRAEL IT
MONTHS AND MONTHS TO BE
REIMBURSED SO BEING ABLE TO NOT
INCUR THAT BURDEN BE WONDERFUL.
JACK WALKS CALIFORNIA WATER CITY
ASIAN IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN AGAINST ON BEHALF OF THE
OF SELF HELP ENTERPRISES IN
SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
I'D SEEN UNDER WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I KNOW ONE THING THAT
WAS BROUGHT UP MISTER CHAIRMAN
DISTANT FROM OUR ANALYSIS WAS
THAT THIS ALSO REMOVES DESCENT
EXISTING SUNSET.
I HAVE THAT RIGHT NOW SAID A
JANUARY FIRST. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FIVE.
.
YOU KNOW HAVING THE SUNSET THEIR
LEAST ALLOWS SOME REVIEW OF THE
PROGRAM TO SEE HOW IT'S WORKING.
AND IS THAT SOMETHING THAT.
YOU.
CONSIDER IS A JUST BE.
MAYBE SOME COMMENT ON THAT AS
MUCH IT WOULD BE MY QUESTION.
SO IT SO WE KNOW THAT.
THE PROGRAM IS WORKING IT'S GUYS
GOT SOME CHALLENGES FOR SOME OF
THESE ECONOMIC NEED
IT'S ABOUT COMMUNITIES.
CASH STRAPPED THEM.
AND OR NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE.
TYPICALLY CARRIED OUT SOME OF
THESE PROJECTS THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS AND SO.
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THESE FUNDS.
I CERTAINLY WOULD CONSIDER A
ANOTHER TYPE OF FOR A REVIEW
PROCESS
THAT WOULD DETERMINE.
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'VE REYES WHICH
IS WHETHER OR NOT THIS IS
WORKING I'M NOT BUT I THINK.
THE PROGRAM IS WORKING IN
GENERAL BUT CERTAINLY HAS SOME
BARRIERS AT.
WE'RE TRYING TO ELIMINATE WITH
THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
NOW MR SAUCE.
THANK YOU THINK MISTER CHAIRMAN.
CHAIRMAN.
SO I UP A YOU KNOW I REPRESENT A
BUNCH OF A RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
OBVIOUSLY ACCESS TO CAPITAL IS
IS.
ONE OF PARAMOUNT CONCERNS.
BUT I WAS LOOKING AT.
YOU KNOW SO WHO REMOVE THE CAP
THAT'S
YOU NO WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
HOW DO WE PREVENT LIKE BAD
ACTORS IN THE FUTURE. CITED NO
IF YOU HAD SAW.
TO WE PROMULGATE REGULATIONS
AROUND AWARDING THE FUNDS TO
THOSE ENTITIES THAT CAN PROVIDE
THE TECHNICAL AND THAT HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO. ADMINISTER
THESE FUNDS OR DO YOU SEE THAT
BEING SPELLED OUT IN THE
LEGISLATION.
AS THIS BILL MOVES FURTHER
ALONG.
THAT PUBLIC.
SOME MAN UP TO TAKE A LOOK AT IN
FURTHER DETAIL I DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER TO THAT BUT.
I THINK SOMETHING TO.
FOCUS ON IS THAT YOU KNOW
ELIMINATE THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR
CAP ON PROJECTS.
.
OR FIFTY PERCENT OF THE GRANT
AWARD WOULD
CHIPPER'S LESS IS REALLY KIND
HOW WE.
SAID IT SO THAT IT DOESN'T
EXCEED.
BE CAP.
THAT THAT YOU REFERRED TO.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE DETAILS
THAT.
TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT.
DICK YOU'RE WITH THE LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL IS SIMILAR TO EXISTING
LAW.
WHICH OF ALREADY PROVIDES
PROTECTION FROM THEFT AND OTHER.
UNFORTUNATE EVENTS COTTON SO.
MIGHT BE FREE WE ALL BE DOING
ITS LIMIT IN A CHANGING THAT THE
CAP THE CAP EVERYTHING ELSE
DAIS.
THERE'S A LOT OF BLOOD LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THAT PIECE YOU'RE LOOKING AT
KENNETH TIGHTER OVERSIGHT IS
REALLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING RIGHT
IS A MAKING SURE THAT.
THERE ISN'T.
ABUSE SEWER UP DOLLARS ARE BEING
SPENT.
YEAH FOR ANY THAT'S BOTH WHAT WE
WERE IN THAT I THINK WE CAN WORK
ON MAY BE SOMETHING THAT WOULD.
YOU HAVE A HAPPY HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU ALL PUT SOME LANGUAGE
IN THERE THAT KIND OF BUT SINCE
A CARD IN THERE GOT.
I THINK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS THAT YES IT MISTER
BIGLER. I WAS JUST
PONDERING HERE WONDERING.
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE MOTION.
.
WOULD YOU WITH THE. AUTHOR OF
THE BILL BE WILLING TO AMENDED
NOW JUST STRIKING OUT THAT
PORTION OF THE SUNSET LEAVING
THE SUNSET IN THEIR.
AT THIS TIME I THINK WHAT HE WAS
LOOKING FOR IS NOT TO REMOVE THE
SUNSET BUT MAYBE TO COME UP WITH
SOME SORT OF OVERSIGHT YEAH I
THINK I THINK ADDRESSING THE THE
OVERSIGHT CONCERNS IT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT.
WILLING TO LOOK AT.
.
BUT SOME LANGUAGE IN THERE TO
ADDRESS BOTH THE QUESTIONS THAT
WERE ASKED BY MISTER GALLAGHER
MISTER SALAS I THINK I AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LEVELS AND
THAT BECAUSE I I THINK THERE'S
A.
REALLY VALID CONCERNS THAT WE
JUST PUT THIS IN PLACE AND IN.
AND SO HERE WE ARE COUPLE YEARS
WE HAVE SEEN THE FULL WRATH OF.
ACTUAL RESULTS MERELY JUST
BECAUSE OF THIS WE'RE SEEING
SOME SOME ACTION SO MAYBE IT
DOES WARRANT SOMETHING.
I'LL LEAVE IT IN YOUR HANDS AND
AND WHAT AND THE HAND TO THE
OTHER MEMBERS TO WORK OUT THAT
VOTE WON'T CONSIDERS AND ASK THE
QUESTION WILL CONSIDER.
I'D OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT.
MA'AM CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA HIGH
GALLAGHER BY GALLAGHER AYE.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CORREO.
CHOI AN AYE CHOI AYE CHU ARE
CHOI CHU I FRIEDMAN. GLORIA
FLOREA AYE HARPER FIVE HARPER
AYE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I MATHIS.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SOLACE.
SOLACE I WOULD.
WRITER ELEVEN.
ZERO THAT BILL DOES PASS AND
LEAVE IT ON CALL
.
PRIVACY GLORIA YOU HAVE AB
TWENTY SIXTY FOUR I DO SIR.
GOOD MORNING.
STRUCTURES CHAIRMAN OF MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
SIXTY FOUR LEGISLATION JOINTLY
AUTHORED BY MYSELF AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHIRLEY WEBER.
AB TWENTY SIXTY FOUR WILL
ENSURE THE INTEGRATED REGIONAL
MANAGEMENT PROCESSES ARE
WORKABLE FOR SMALL DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. UNDER EXISTING
LAW DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
ABLE TO RECEIVE AN ADVANCE PARA
OF UP TO FIFTY PERCENT OF THE
GRANT AWARD TO THE INTEGRATED
REGIONAL WATER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM. ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
THIS ADVANCED PAYMENT PROCESS
HAS BEEN WORKING WELL BUT IT
DOES NOT FULLY ADDRESSED THE
CASH FLOW PROBLEMS THE SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS. EVICTING WITH VIC
EXPERIENCE.
UNDER TRADITIONAL REIMBURSEMENT
MODEL A TWENTY SIXTY FOUR
ENSURES THAT THE SMALL
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE ABLE
TO RECEIVE AN ADVANCE PAYMENT
FOR THE SECOND HALF OF THE GRANT
AWARD. SIMILAR IN THE MANNER FOR
THE FIRST HALF OF THE AWARD.
I APPRECIATE GREATLY THE
INSIGHTS OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND I COMMIT TO ADDRESSING THE
ISSUES RAISED ANNOUNCES.
PACIFIC WE WORKING WITH AN AYE
INCORPORATING ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THAT APPLY TO THE
SECOND HALF OF THE ADVANCE GRANT
PAYMENT THIS IS CURRENTLY
INCLUDED IN THE FIRST HALF AGO
ADVANCE GRANT PICKED PAYMENT.
ABOUT LIKE THE TEAMWORK MISTER
GARCIA STAFF DEVELOP LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD HELP SYNCHRONIZE THIS
BILL WITH THE CHAIRS MEASURE
THAT YOU JUST HEARD AB TWENTY
SIXTY.
ALSO TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION I COMMIT TO
CLARIFY THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS IN THIS BILL IN THE
LOWER THE ADVANCE VINYL ADVANCE
RETENTION FROM TEN PERCENT TO
FIVE PERCENT. CONSISTENT WITH
EXISTING D. W. OUR PRACTICE
IN CLOSING THIS COMMITTEE
APPROVED SP TWENTY TWENTY OH A.
WAS I TO.
TWO OH EIGHT A UNANIMOUSLY
ACKNOWLEDGING THE NEED FOR TO
COME TO A SMALL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
FURTHER THOSE GOALS THAT WE
SHARE FROM PROVING WATER EFFORTS
THAT SERVE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS. JOINING THIS
MORNING AT TWO WITNESSES GLENN
FARROW WITH THE CITY OF COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY AND MARK STADLER
FROM SAN DIEGO INNOVATIVE
REGIONAL WATER MANAGEMENT
ADVISORY GROUP I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER GURIAN
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AYE GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
GLENN FOR A WITH THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY WATER AUTHORITY.
THE INTERPRETER REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM IS ONLY AS
STRONG AS ITS MEMBERSHIP.
WE BELIEVE THAT A GREAT
REGIONAL WATER MANAGEMENT
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE ARE.
AT BEST.
FUNCTIONING WHERE AND MOST
PRODUCTIVE MOST SUCCESSFUL MOST
CREDIBLE WHEN THERE'S ROBUST
PARTICIPATION FROM THROUGHOUT
THE COMMUNITY.
WATER AGENCIES MUNICIPALITIES
WATER COMPANIES TRIBES AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
ANOTHER COMMITTEE INTEREST
GROUPS.
TO THE EXTENT THAT THERE ARE
VARIOUS BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION FOR SOME OF THE
SMALLER ENTITIES. NOW WE WANT TO
RESOLVE THOSE SO THAT THOSE I'M
IN A GOOD REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT GROUPS REMAIN ROBUST.
PRODUCTIVE INCREDIBLE ON THEN IN
THAT REGARD WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
THE.
.
PARTICIPATION OF DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY GROUPS AND AND
PROJECTS THAT SUPPORT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT THE INTEGRATED REGIONAL
WATER MANAGEMENT PROGRAM DOES.
IN FACT PROPOSITION ONE THE NEW
GRANT PROGRAM FOR OUR W. M..
REQUIRES THAT AT LEAST TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE GRANT FUNDS GO TO
PROJECTS THAT BENEFIT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
CURRENTLY THE THE REQUIREMENT
THAT THE SECOND HALF OF A GRANT.
FOR DISADVANTAGED DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY HAS TO BE.
.
BUT PUT PUT FORWARD ON A.
TRADITIONAL REIMBURSEMENT BASIS
CAUSES PROBLEMS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE CASH FLOW ISSUES AND REALLY
CAN'T AFFORD TO FRONT THE STATE
SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
AT A TIME. AYE AND WAIT TO GET
REIMBURSED
SO.
AB TWENTY SIXTY FOUR WOULD
REMOVE THAT ROADBLOCK FROM THE
PATH OF DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
REQUIRE PARTICIPATION. AND I
RESPECTFULLY IT'S A REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU DISH NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AND ALSO IN SUPPORT.
JACK WALKS CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
PAUL MASON FOR TRUST ALSO
SUPPORT.
AND ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEN NONE.
SO MOVED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU
SECONDED BY SOME MEMBER LEVINE.
.
I DID HEAR YOU ARE YOU ACCEPTING
SOME OF THE SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS
AND AND NO ONE OF. ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS BROUGHT UP BY THE
COMMITTEE WAS.
THAT THE SECOND.
ADVANCE HAVE THE SAME.
.
ACCOUNTABILITY PROVISIONS AS THE
FIRST.
PORTION IS THAT ARE YOU EXCEPT
IN A LOT OF THEM OKAY.
ADAM.
AND ARE AT SO IS IT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
HAD SEWED IT OF POLYBIA DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AS AS AMENDED IS
THAT CORRECT.
OKAY TIED SO.
MADAM CLERK PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BY THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER AYE GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO. CREEL AYE
CHOI NIGH CHOI AYE CHU.
TO I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE FIVE LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
RUBIO.
SOLACE.
SOLIS I WOULD.
CALL.
RIGHT A BILL PASSES TWELVE
DESIRABLE LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL
FOR OTHER STAT ON.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP THE.
.
ROLL CALL FOR.
SEVERAL BILLS FOR MEMBERS TO ADD
ON WILL START AT THE TOP.
AND AMEND CLERK.
CARILLO.
I'M SORRY AB NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CARILLO.
CARILLO I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE HARPER.
NOT VOTING.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MATHIS.
RUBIO.
FOR MR MATHIS AB NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN.
THE CHAIRS BILL.
HI MATHIS AYE.
YES.
THIRTEEN TWO ZERO.
GREAT BUT CHEAP ALCOHOL.
AB TWENTY SIXTY.
CALLING THE MISSING MEMBERS
CARILLO.
CREEL I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
MATHIS
I MATHIS I WOULD.
NINE ZERO.
AB TWENTY SIXTY FOR THIS IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE RUBIO.
WOULD.
ZERO.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE CARILLO.
CARILLO NOT VOTING.
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I.
.
YES.
LEVINE NO. VOTE CHANGE.
MATHIS I MATHIS AYE RUBIO.
WOULD.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
CARILLO.
CARILLO I FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE MATHIS STAY.
MATHIS.
NOT VOTING.
WOULD.
ELEVEN.
ONE.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE.
CARILLO.
CARILLO I
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE. MATHIS.
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE
BY.
MATHIS I RUBIO.
WOULD
.
SO WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE.
ROLE OPEN FOR SEVERAL OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
BUT I THINK AT THIS TIME FOR
MANY OF YOU THINK. BUSINESS HERE
MAYBE.
COMPLETE WE DO HAVE THE SPECIAL
ORDER MEETING AT TEN THIRTY AND
THAT MY UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE TO
GET.
SOMEWHAT CLOSE TO THAT TIME TO
GET THAT.
CONVERSATION STARTED SO THANK
YOU
I.
YES I.
AB TWENTY SIX BEFORE RUBIO AYE.
RUBIO AYE.
AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE RUBIO I.
FEEL I.
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY NINE
RUBIO AYE OF.
A. B. TWENTY FOR SIXTY FIVE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE.
I THINK YOU.
SO THINK.
OKAY AT THIS TIME THE WATER
PARKS WHILE I PULL ADJOURNMENTS
MEETING.
AND A CLOSE THE GENDER
YOUR YOUR KITS ABOUT WHERE THEY
IN MIDDLE.
OF.
OKAY GOOD MORNING AGAIN EVERYONE
AND WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
PARKS WATER PARKS AND WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE THIS IS A SPECIAL
ORDER OF BUSINESS.
OVERSIGHT HEARING CALIFORNIA
WATER COMMISSION. WATER STORAGE
INVESTMENT PROGRAM WE HAVE A.
COUPLE OF PANELISTS IT ALREADY
READY TO GO I DON'T THINK WE
NEED TO CALL ROLE FOR THIS ONE.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US
AND THAT'S GET US STARTED WE
HAVE AMONG LOOKING DENTAL CHAIR
OF THE.
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
CAROL BAKER VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION.
CITY TUCKED. DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
MAURICE ALSO SEE IT. VICE
PRESIDENT OF WATER. FOR THE
ECOSYSTEMS PROGRAM OF I'M A
DEFENSE FUND WE'RE GONNA LET
EVERYONE DO THEIR PRESENTATION.
AND THEN NOW WE WILL BEGIN THE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS AND OPEN
TO HAVE. A CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE
WITH YOU ALL THIS WHILE. AND
THEN TAKE SOME OF.
PUBLIC COMMENTS AFTER THAT SO
WE'LL START IN THE ORDER MISTER
KING THEY'RE WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I MET MY LOOKING TOTAL AND.
MORNING TOLD ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AND EVERYONE WHO IS JOINING US
THIS MORNING.
A THE CALTRANS WATER COMMISSION
CLEARLY UNDERSTANDS THE
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING IN THE
ADDITIONAL WATER STORAGE TO
SECURE CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WE'RE
COMMITTED TO THAT GOAL. AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO TAKING KEY STEPS
THIS SUMMER AS A PART OF THE
WATER STORAGE INVESTMENT
PROGRAM.
WELL AS YOU KNOW THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATIONS CALIFORNIA WATER
ACTION PLAN CALLS FOR
INVESTMENTS IN ABOVE AND BELOW
GROUND WATER STORAGE.
TO HELP PREPARE FOR THE AFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE IN FUTURE
DROUGHTS.
THE WATER STORAGE INVESTMENT
PROGRAM FUELED BY THE TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
FROM THE VOTER APPROVED PROP
ONE.
PROPOSITION ONE OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN IS AN IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE TO
KICK START.
VITAL PROJECTS BY PROVIDING
FUNDS FOR SPECIFIED PUBLIC
BENEFITS RICHER ASSOCIATED WITH
THE PROPOSED PROJECTS.
THE COMMISSION DEVELOPED THE
PROGRAM WITH EXTENSIVE INPUT
FROM STAKEHOLDERS OVER A TWO
YEAR PERIOD.
AND BY THE CLOSE OF THE
APPLICATION PERIOD IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE'D RECEIVED TWELVE
APPLICATIONS SEEKING A TOTAL OF
FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
IN FUNDING. FOR BOTH SURFACE AND
GROUNDWATER PROJECTS AROUND THE
STATE.
COMMISSION STAFF AND TECHNICAL
REVIEW TEAMS CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE ELEVEN OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS AND THE COMMISSION
MEMBERS ARE SET TO BEGIN MAKING
INITIAL FUNDING DIRK
DETERMINATIONS THIS SUMMER.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT NO
FUNDING DECISIONS HAVE BEEN MADE
BY THE COMMISSION AT THIS TIME.
AND ALL PROJECTS REMAIN ACTIVE
IN POTENTIALLY VIABLE IN THIS
PROCESS.
WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT THIS
PROCESS WILL RESULT IN DOLLARS
GOING OUT THE DOOR TO QUALIFY IN
PROJECTS LATER THIS YEAR.
ONLY TO COVER A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE PROCESS AND WHY WE ARE
FOCUSED ON THE PUBLIC BENEFITS
OF THE PROJECTS.
.
AND THAT IS A PROPOSITION ONE
WHICH IS PASSED OVERWHELMINGLY
BY THE VOTERS IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN.
WAS VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT HOW THE
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
FOR WATER STORAGE CAN BE USED.
THE MEASURE STATES THAT THE
COMMISSION MAY ONLY FUND THE
PUBLIC BENEFITS ASSOCIATED WITH
WATER STORAGE PROJECTS THAT
IMPROVE THE OPERATION OF THE
STATE WATER SYSTEM.
ARE COST EFFECTIVE AND PROVIDE A
NET IMPROVEMENT IN ECOSYSTEM IN
WATER QUALITY CONDITIONS.
WATER STORAGE INVESTMENT PROGRAM
FUNDS ARE FOR THE FOLLOWING
PUBLIC BENEFITS.
SPECIFIED IN LANGUAGE IN THE
LANGUAGE OF PROPOSITION ONE
CHAPTER EIGHT.
THOSE ARE ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS
WATER QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS.
FLOOD CONTROL EMERGENCY RESPONSE
RECREATIONAL PURPOSES IN THIS
ALSO INCLUDES A REQUIREMENT FOR
PROJECTS TO SHOW A MEASURABLE
ECOSYSTEM IMPROVEMENT TO THE
DELTA.
OR TO ITS TRIBUTARIES.
THERE'S A QUOTE THAT I RAN
ACROSS IN THE DAY WHICH I REALLY
LIKED AND APPLIES VERY MUCH THIS
PROGRAM. IN THE QUOTE IS IN GOD
WE TRUST BUT FOR EVERYONE ELSE
WE NEED DATA.
.
AND SO UP FUNDING THESE PUBLIC
BONTA BENEFITS
IS INTENDED TO HELP LOCAL
PROJECT PROPONENTS COMPLETE THE
FUNDING PICTURE OR FOR THEIR
PROJECTS.
IN DOES NOTED WE ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE EVALUATION PROCESS OF THE
PROGRAM.
STAFF IS REVIEWING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION SUBMITTED BY
APPLICANTS APPEALS TO THE
ADDITIONAL INITIAL TECHNICAL
ASSESSMENT OF THE PUBLIC BENEFIT
RATIO.
WATER COMMISSION STAFF AND
SUBJECT AREA EXPERTS MET WITH
ALL PROJECT PROPONENTS IN PUBLIC
MEETINGS IN FEBRUARY TO ADDRESS
QUESTIONS AND TO CLARIFY
INFORMATION THAT WAS NEEDED IN
THE APPEAL PROCESS.
AND ALL OF THESE INTERVIEWS ARE
AVAILABLE ONLINE AT THE WATER
COMMISSION WEBSITE.
IN MAY COMMISSION MEMBERS WILL
BEGIN OUR PUBLIC DECISION MAKING
PROCESS FOCUSED FIRST ON
DETERMINING A FINAL PUBLIC
BENEFIT RATIO FOR EACH PROJECT.
AND THEN THE REMAINING
COMPONENTS SCORES FOR EACH
PROJECT.
ARE THE VICE.
CHAIR BAKER WILL ELABORATE MORE
ON THE NEXT STEPS IN THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
GENTLEMAN COVERED WITH.
NOT JUST MENTION A FEW MORE
THINGS BEFORE IT HANDED OVER TO
CAROL.
OR VICE CHAIR BAKER. ARE THE
CHRISTIANS WORKED SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF PROP ONE FOR TIMELY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROCESS.
WE DEVELOPED THE STATUTORY
REQUIRED REGULATIONS TO A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT
INCLUDED APPLICANTS STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE PUBLIC.
THESE REGULATIONS WERE ADOPTED
IT WAS A TWO YEAR PROCESS AND
BY THE COMMISSION IN TWELVE IN
DECEMBER FOURTEENTH TWENTY
SIXTEEN WHICH CONSISTENT WITH
THE STATUTORY DEADLINE.
THE REGULATIONS
WERE APPROVED BY O. A L. IS
INITIALLY SUBMITTED BY THE
COMMISSION.
AND THE APPLICATION SOLICITATION
BEGAN ONE WEEK AFTER THE
REGULATIONS PRINT WERE IN EFFECT
AND THE APPLICATION COULD REMAIN
OPEN FOR FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS
WITH PAUL STAFF AVAILABLE FOR
APPLICANT CONSULTATION ON THEIR
APPLICATIONS.
THIS IS ALMOST SIXTY PEOPLE FROM
DOM STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES ALL SUBJECT AREA
EXPERTS WHO COULD ASSIST
APPLICANTS WITH THEIR PROJECTS.
VICE CHAIR BAKER.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE HERE I'M CAROL BAKER VICE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
COMMISSION.
AS THE CHAIR INDICATED WERE
ABOUT TO MOVE INTO OF THE
COMMISSION DECISION MAKING
PROCESS.
THE FIRST.
THE THREE THREE DAY OF MEETINGS
THE FIRST BEING IN MAY WHERE THE
COMMISSION WILL. MAKE A
DETERMINATION UP ON THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT RATIO.
IN JUNE OF WILL BE MAKING THE
COMMISSION WILL BE MAKING A
DETERMINATION ON PROJECTS
SCORES.
AND IN JULY.
BOTH THE COMMISSION WILL BE
DETERMINING THE MAXIMUM
CONDITIONAL ELIGIBILITY FOR
FUNDING.
AND FUND IT AND EARLY FUNDING
AWARDS.
THE COMMISSION IS COMMITTED TO
APPROPRIATE.
PRODUCTIVE INTERFACES WITH
APPLICANTS DURING THE PROCESS
DURING THIS PROCESS.
IT'S A VERY COMPLEX PROCESS.
AND WE ARE COMMITTED TO BEING
RESPONSIVE AND TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE TO ENSURE SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOME OF.
THE REGULATIONS ALLOWED
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO BE
SUBMITTED. DURING THE BEEN A
BASIC ELIGIBILITY INCOME
COMPLETENESS SPACE.
A WHICH OCCURRED LAST FALL.
AND THE APPLICANT APPEAL PHASE
WHICH OCCURRED IN FEBRUARY OF
THIS YEAR.
THE COMMISSION ALSO RECOGNIZES
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
INTERACTIONS.
A THERE WERE A DID AT.
WE ADDED THE THIRTY THREE HOURS
OF APPLICANT MEETINGS.
IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY OF THIS
YEAR. WERE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR STAFF TO CONSIDER OPTIONS
FOR ADDITIONAL INTERACTIONS.
A IN THE REMAINDER OF THE
PROCESS.
FUTURE INTERACTIONS NEED TO
A NEED TO BE A BALANCE.
IF YOU.
THE FUTURE INTERACTIONS NEED TO
BALLOTS PURPOSE INEFFECTIVENESS
IN TRANSPARENCY. FAIRNESS
EFFECTIVENESS AND TIMELINE.
THE COMMISSION REMAINS DEDICATED
TO MOVING THE MONEY OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
TRANSPARENCY AND.
PUBLIC DECISION MAKING.
ADDED. A ADDITIONAL TIME TO THE
PROCESS.
AT WE HAD OVER FIFTY STAKEHOLDER
MEETINGS DURING THE REGULATION
DEVELOPMENT.
ONCE THE REGULATIONS WERE
APPROVED BY THE COMMISSION THEY
MOVED ON TO THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW.
WHERE THEY WHEREBY THEY HAVE A
PUBLIC PROCESS FOR THEIR?
REVIEW OF OUR REGULATIONS AND
WERE SUBSEQUENTLY APPROVED.
AND AS I JUST DESCRIBED WE HAVE
A.
STEP WISE THREE DAY.
THREE THREE DAY MEETINGS.
FOR OUR DECISION DECISION
MAKING PROCESS.
AFFECTING THIS OF THE PROCESS
RELIES ON THE COMMISSION'S
DECISIONS THE SUMMER.
HOWEVER.
IT ALSO RELIES ON APPLICANTS
EFFORTS TO MEET THE STOCK IT
STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BAR.
THE JANUARY EXCUSE ME THE JULY
COMMISSION PLUMERI DECISIONS ARE
CONDITIONAL.
AFTER WE DO OUR PART.
THE APPLICANTS HAVE SEVERAL
OTHER KEY STEPS
A IN ORDER TO COMPLETE THE
PROCESS THE.
APPLICANTS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DOING OF THE FOLLOWING.
I'M PLEADING FEASIBILITY
STUDIES.
COMPLETE ALL ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTATION.
OBTAIN ALL OTHER FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL APPROVALS.
SECURE FUNDING.
NOT COVERED BY THE.
WITH PROGRAM IT'S REQUIRED IN
PROP ONE.
FOR THOSE PROJECTS WITH LONG PRE
A.
PRE CONSTRUCTION TIME LINES.
THOSE PROJECTS MUST MEET.
A NOT ONLY MEAT THEY FOR
MENTIONED REQUIREMENTS BY
JANUARY FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY STE TO THERE ARE SEVERAL
EXCEPTIONS.
THEY'LL HAVE TO HAVE SEVENTY
FIVE PERCENT OF THE FUNDING
COMMITMENT. FOR NON PROGRAM COST
SHARES. AND A PUBLIC REVIEW
DRAFT OF THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENT.
TO BE.
IN THE PUBLIC DOMAIN.
THE COMMISSION IS COMMITTED TO
TRANSPARENCY AND THE COMMISSION
OUT RETAINS THE DECISION MAKING.
IN THE WATER STORAGE INVESTMENT
PROGRAM.
AND ES INVESTORS AND PARTNERS OF
THE WATER STORAGE INVESTMENT
PROJECTS.
THE COMMISSION HAS ENTRUSTED BY
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO
INVEST THE TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION FOR MEASURABLE AND
ACCOUNTABLE PUBLIC BENEFITS.
AND TO ACHIEVE WATER RELIABILITY
AND RESILIENCY AS ENVISIONED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S WATER ACTION
PLAN.
ADDITIONALLY THE FUNDS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE ALLOCATED IN THE
COMPETITIVE.
FAIR AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS
AND THIS IS A UNIQUE AND COMPLEX
PROGRAM.
WERE ALL PAIN A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF ATTENTION TO THIS AS
IS OUR APPLICANTS IN MUCH LIKE
OUR APPLICANTS.
THE COMMISSION IS EAGER TO
OBLIGATE THE FUNDS AND WE REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES IN THIS PROGRAM.
WE HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE THAT
THIS PROCESS RESULT IN FUNDING
BEING AWARDED TO.
ELIGIBLE PROJECTS THAT OFFER
THE BEST RETURN ON THE PUBLIC'S
INVESTMENT.
AND WE VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION AND
CAROL AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WILL GOING TO NEXT WEEK I KNOW I
HAVE COLLEAGUES WHO ARE READY TO
ASK QUESTIONS BUT WHAT WILL
CONCLUDE WITH A.
FOURTH SPEAKER AND THEN WILL
WILL JUMP RIGHT IN.
GREAT THINK FUTURE GARCIA IN
MEMBERS IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HEARD TODAY CINDY TALK WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES. AQUA REPRESENTS ABOUT
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE.
THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
TOGETHER THEY PROVIDE ABOUT
NINETY PERCENT OF THE WATER
THAT'S DISTRIBUTED FOR THE
PUBLIC FOR AG IN FOR BUSINESS.
I'M IN MY COMMENTS TODAY IN UNIT
HARDCOVER FOUR POINTS ONE SOME
BRIEF HISTORY ON PROP ONE WHICH
IS RELEVANT TO THE CONVERSATION
TODAY.
TWO THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE
STORAGE FUNDING THREE AND
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
IT'S ON COULD PROCESS STEPS THAT
WE WOULD SUGGEST.
AND FOURTH A LINK TO FEDERAL
FUNDING WHICH IS GOOD TO HAVE IN
MIND.
SO ON THOUGH HISTORY ON PROP ONE
IN MANY OF YOU KNOW THIS FIRST
HAND. BY PROP ONE WASN'T WRITTEN
IN. ALL IN TWENTY FOURTEEN IT
GOES BACK TO THE PACKAGE FROM
TWO THOUSAND NINE. THAT BILL ON
IT WAS BY A SENATOR COG DEAL AND
THAT WAS ELEVEN POINT ONE FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BOND. THAT
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER SIGNED.
AND AFTER TWO THOUSAND NINE WE
WERE IN THE RECESSION IN THERE
WERE DECISIONS MADE BY I THINK A
LOT OF FOLKS THAT.
VOTE ON THE BOND SHOULD BE
DELAYED AND SO IT WAS DELAYED
UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND THERE
WAS A LOT OF WORK ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE. IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO TRIM THE BOND DOWN FROM AT
ELEVEN POINT ONE FOUR BILLION
DOLLAR BOND TO THE SEVEN POINT
FIVE OR SO BILLION DOLLAR BOND.
THAT WENT TO THE VOTERS.
SOTHAT YOUR AND I THINK IT'S
WORTH NOTING THE ASSEMBLY VOTED
SEVENTY SEVEN TWO TWO.
AND ON THE SENATE VOTED THIRTY
SEVEN TO ZERO GOVERNOR BROWN
IMMEDIATELY SIGN THE BILL FOR US
THAT WITH A VERY EXCITING DAY WE
HAVE A PICTURE ABOUT UP IN THE
OFFICE.
IN IN IN THE OF COURSE THE KEY
EVENT IS THAT IT WENT TO THE
VOTERS AS PROP ONE IN THE PAST
BY SIXTY SEVEN PERCENT. I GO
THROUGH THAT JUST TO SAY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE ACTOR.
THE GOVERNOR ACTED THE VOTERS
ACTED IN THE EXPECTATION IS THAT
THE MONEY WHEN YOU PASS A BOND
THE EXPECTATION IS THAT THE
MONEY WILL BE ALLOCATED AND SO
WE'RE GLAD TO HEAR THAT. VERY
POSITIVE STATEMENTS OF THE THE
COMMISSIONERS THIS MORNING.
SO THAT'S THE HISTORY.
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE.
PROF WHEN STORAGE MONEY. UP THE
CHAPTER EIGHT LANGUAGE FOCUSES A
LOT ON PUBLIC BENEFITS IN IN
PARTICULAR.
ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS ARE IT
ECOSYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS.
AND WHY IS THAT.
AND EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT STORAGE
IS REALLY IMPORTANT FROM A WATER
SUPPLY MANAGEMENT STANDPOINT AND
FLOOD PROTECTION. THAT'S STILL
VERY TRUE TODAY BUT WHAT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT IS THAT WE HAVE
STORAGE TO HELP PROVIDE WATER
FOR THE ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS
SUCH AS SENSUAL SEASONAL FISH
FLOWS.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING WE WANTED TO
MENTION IN CHAIR QUINN PARA
ALREADY MENTIONED THE PUBLIC
BENEFITS THAT ARE IN THE LOT SO
I'M NOT GOING TO.
KEEP THAT.
SO NOW I COME TO THE PROCESS AT
THE COMMISSION.
AND I THINK EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT
WHEN THE PRE APPEAL
DETERMINATIONS CAME OUT FOR THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT RATIOS.
THERE WAS A LOT OF CONCERN AND
AQUA WE WERE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT.
THE FACT THAT THERE SEEMED TO BE
A DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE
REVIEWERS AT THE STATE AND THE
APPLICANTS.
AND SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
THE COMMISSION HELD ADDITIONAL
MEETINGS THEY WERE.
INTERACTIONS WITH THE
APPLICANTS BUT THEY WERE
TRANSPARENT IT WAS ARE EXCELLENT
PROCESS STEP WHETHER WE WITH
FURTHER COMMUNICATION TO INFORM
THE APPEAL PROCESS
WE THINK THAT WAS CRITICAL.
WE BELIEVE THAT SIMILAR FUTURE
INTERACTIONS ARE IMPORTANT I
HAVE TO BE TRANSPARENT WE THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THEY SHOULD
HAPPEN BUT FOR THE KEY
MILESTONES THAT ARE COMING UP
SO THAT THEY CAN INFORM THE
PROCESS SO THAT IF STATE
REVIEWERS HAVE QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHAT WE SUBMITTED THEY CAN ASK A
QUESTION.
THIS IS A A HUGE AMOUNT OF MONEY
IT'S OF IMPORTANT ADVANCEMENT IN
OUR STORAGE THERE NEEDS TO BE
ABLE TO BE A DISCUSSION BACK AND
FORTH. AND AGAIN WE SUGGEST THAT
THE ADDITIONAL PROCESS STEPS BE
BEFORE THE KEY MILESTONES.
SO THAT'S THE THE THIRD POINT.
IN AN THE FOURTH POINT IS ON A
COMMON ABOUT FEDERAL FUNDING.
THE COMMITTEE MAY ALREADY BE
AWARE BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THE COMMITTEE AND THE
PUBLIC ARE AWARE. THAT.
CONGRESS ACTUALLY GOT IT
TOGETHER NOT TOO LONG AGO AND
PASSED A. NEW LAW ON WATER IT'S
CALLED THE WIN ACT.
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT
FOR THE NATION'S ACT.
AND THAT INCLUDES MONEY FOR
STORAGE.
AND ON THE KEY IS THAT FOR
CALIFORNIA PROJECTS IT SPELLS
OUT THAT THEY HAVE TO.
SHOW THAT THE OUT BY AND I THINK
THE COMMISSION ACTUALLY HAS TO
DETERMINE THAT THEY MEET THE
PROP ONE TESS.
SO FUND THIS YEAR ARE
UNDERSTANDING THE BUDGET PROCESS
IS
THE SECRETARY OF INTERIOR WILL
ACT WILL BE DOING EVALUATIONS.
AND THEY WILL PROVIDE THEIR
INPUT TO CONGRESS ON THIS IN
AUGUST
SO THE TIMING TO GET THESE
DECISIONS. ARE ALLOCATION
DECISIONS ON DONE THE SUMMER IS
VERY IMPORTANT WE THINK THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT FEDERAL MONEY.
AND WITH THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE PROVIDE COMMENTS AND WE'LL
BE GLAD TO ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU
WILL WANT TO NEXT WEEK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF.
CHAIRMAN GARCIA VICE CHAIR
GALLAGHER OF MEMBERS OF
COMMUTING GAS. REALLY APPRECIATE
THE CHANCE TO TALK WITH YOU
TODAY ON THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
TOPIC.
MY NAME IS MAURICE HALL I LEAD
TO ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND'S
WESTERN WATER PROGRAM.
AND OUR WORK IS FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE THAT OUR WATER
SYSTEM IS RESILIENT TO MEET OUR
CHANGING NEEDS OF OUR SOCIETY
AND NATURE.
ESPECIALLY IN THE FACE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND MORE EXTREME
WEATHER CONDITIONS.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND I'M WATER
RESOURCES ENGINEER HYDROLOGIST
IN A LAWSUIT LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL OF CIVIL
ENGINEERING CALIFORNIA.
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING ON VARIOUS
ASPECTS OF CALIFORNIA WATER FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS AND.
AND WORKED IN OTHER ISSUES AND
OTHER STATES BEFORE THAT.
I REMEMBER WELL THE NEGOTIATION
DROUGHT POP ONE HAS MISTOOK IS.
AND.
DESCRIBED IT WAS A LONG DELIVER
TO PROCESS.
THAT LED. TO EVENTUALLY THE
ALLOCATION OF TWO POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS TO PAY FOR
PUBLIC BENEFITS.
ASSOCIATE WITH WATER STORAGE
PROJECTS AND IN CHAPTER EIGHT
THE MEASURE.
IN AT THAT TIME A WIDE RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS.
RECOGNIZE THAT.
WE NEED SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ENHANCEMENT.
DUE TO CALIFORNIA'S INTENSE
DEVELOPMENT OF OUR WATER
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR FUTURE AND OUR WAY OF
OUR FARMS AND OUR WAY OF LIFE.
AND THE NEED FOR INVESTMENT HAS
EVEN INCREASED IN RECENT YEARS
AS WE'VE EXPERIENCED SEVERE
DROUGHTS AND FLOODS INCLUDING.
BETWEEN THE TIME WE FIRST
STARTED TALKING ABOUT A BOND AND
THE TIME IT WAS EVENTUALLY I GOT
TO THE VOTERS.
TWO OF OUR MOST SEVERE DROUGHTS
ON RECORD OCCUR.
BECAUSE OF THIS EXPERIENCE IN
OUR HISTORY DEALING WITH
DROUGHTS IT WAS CLEARED UP
POLICYMAKERS AND AS I SAID A
WIDE RANGE OF STAKEHOLDERS
WORKING ON PROPOSITION ONE THAT.
MORE WATER STORAGE IS NEEDED.
FIRST MAJOR POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IS.
.
THAT.
THIS IS A NEW VENTURE THAT WE
ARE ON.
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
INNOVATIVE NATURE.
OF WHAT SOME OF YOU AND YOUR
PREDECESSORS DID IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH IN NOW.
THIS WATER STORAGE INVESTMENT
PROGRAM IS A DEPARTURE FROM THE
WAY WE HAVE APPROACHED WATER
STORAGE FOR MOST. OF OUR
HISTORY.
IN MOST OUR HISTORY ARE WATER
STORAGES BEEN DESIGNED TO MEET
THREE BASIC NEEDS THE FEW OTHERS
AROUND THE EDGES BUT PRIMARILY
FLOOD CONTROL WATER SUPPLY.
AND HYDROPOWER GENERATION.
AND THEN ONLY AFTER PROJECTS
WERE BUILT LARGELY FOR THOSE
PROCESSES THE FOR THOSE WHO.
.
BENEFITS.
WE TRIED TO CONSTRAIN THE
OPERATIONS
IT'S JUST HOW WE OPERATED IT
CETERA TO IMPROVE THINGS LIKE
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
MITIGATE FOREIGN BAR.
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS IMPACT
EFFICIENT WHILE I.
STILL A MAJOR FUNCTION OF THE
RESERVOIRS.
AND THE STORAGE HAS BEEN FOR
FLOOD CONTROL WATER STORAGE IN A
POWER GENERATION.
IN CONTRAST THIS PROGRAM TURNS
THAT A LITTLE BIT ON ITS HEAD
AND SAYS THAT WE WILL
PROACTIVELY.
THINK ABOUT HOW TO USE STORAGE
TO PROVIDE WATER BENEFITS.
FOR THE PUBLIC INCLUDING THE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECOSYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS
DESCRIBED IN THE ACT.
THE KEY PART OF THIS OF COURSE
IS THE PRO ACTIVE. ASPECT OF IT
DELIBERATELY PUTTING THE STORAGE
TO USE.
TO ME.
PACIFIC PUBLIC NEEDS INCLUDING
AS DESCRIBED IN THE LAW AND
OTHERS HAVE HIGHLIGHTED
ECOSYSTEM IMPROVEMENTS.
WATER QUALITY PRINTS IN THE
DELTA FLOOD CONTROL.
EMERGED RESPONSE AND RECREATION.
THIS NEW AND AND I ACTUALLY
THINK THE VISIONARY STEP.
TO LOOK AT STORAGE PRESENT SOME
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE.
WE HAVE A LONG LEGACY OF
PROCESSES AND STANDARD
PROCEDURES FOR.
DEVELOPER MARMI CORBIN HERE'S
BUREAU OF RECLAMATION AND OTHERS
AROUND THE WORLD TO BUILD
STORAGE DRUGS FOR WATER SUPPLY
AND POWER GENERATION BUT.
FOR ECOSYSTEM BENEFITS AND OTHER
PUBLIC BENEFITS AS PRESCRIBED IN
THE LAW.
THE ESTABLISHED PRACTICE IS NOT
SO CLEAR.
NO WE'RE NOT COMPLETE STARTING
COMPLETELY FROM SCRATCH BUT WE
DON'T HAVE.
.
THAT IS WELL ESTABLISHED WAYS OF
CHARACTERIZING HOW THE PROJECT
STORAGE PROJECTS CAN BE OPERATED
TO PROVIDE THESE BENEFITS.
QUANTIFYING THOSE BENEFITS
PRIORITIZING THEM AND
MONETIZING.
TO DO THIS THE WATER COMMISSION
AND THEIR STAFF OF HAD TO BREAK
NEW GROUND.
LOTS OF NEW GROUND IN FACT.
AND BY CRITIQUING THE PROJECTS.
AND THE INFORMATION PROVIDED BY
THE PROPONENTS THEY'RE DOING
THEIR JOB.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THAT IT'S
TAKEN AWHILE. AND IT'S NOT
SURPRISING THAT IT HASN'T GONE
ALL THAT SMOOTHLY AND THAT THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME HICCUPS.
THAT'S NOT SURPRISING IT'S BEEN
CHALLENGING FOR THE WATER
COMMISSION THEIR STAFF.
AND ADMITTEDLY FOR THE PROJECT
PROPONENTS.
AND FRANKLY WE ENVIRONMENTALLY
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY OUR OUR
BIT NERVOUS.
I THINK THE IDEA OF HAVING
STORAGE.
CAN BE OPERATED PROACTIVELY FOR
PUBLIC BENEFITS.
OCCLUDING ANVAR ECOSYSTEM
IMPROVEMENTS.
IS A POTENTIALLY POWERFUL TOOL.
BUT I THINK MOST OF US ARE
SOMEWHAT NERVOUS THAT. IF IT
ISN'T DONE RIGHT WE COULD END UP
WITH AN EVEN WORST WITH EVEN
WORSE CONDITIONS FOR FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO DEPEND ON OUR WHAT
RIVERS AND STREAMS AND WETLANDS.
AND OUR INNOVATIVE TWO POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
FOR PUBLIC BENEFITS.
WILL HAVE GONE FOR NOW.
AND SET A POOR PRECEDENT.
FOR THIS
POSSIBLY VISIONARY A
TRANSFORMATIVE WAVE USING
STORAGE.
NOW FOR THOSE WHO ARE MORE
FOCUSED ON THE WATER SUPPLY
BENEFITS OF NEW STORAGE.
AND MAYBE HAVE LESS.
LESS INTEREST ARE LESS FOCUSED
ON THE PUBLIC BENEFITS.
I ALSO THINK THOSE INTEREST
SHOULD BE INTERESTED IN SEEING
THIS PROCESS DONE RIGHT.
IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL IN THIS
INNOVATIVE QUEST.
IF THE WATER MADE AVAILABLE FOR%
PUBLIC BENEFITS CAN REALLY
DELIVER.
AND HELP RESTORE THE AQUATIC
ECOSYSTEMS OF THE BAY DELTA
WATERSHED.
AND WE WILL REDUCE CONFLICT.
AND THE WATER USERS WIN AS WELL.
A MORE RESILIENT WATER SYSTEM
AND ADAPT WATER SYSTEM MEANS
THAT OUR WATER SUPPLY SYSTEM
WORKS BETTER FOR ALL OF US.
SECOND POINT ONE MAKE IS THAT AS
AS BEEN HIGHLIGHTED. BY OTHER
SPEAKERS IN INCLUDING A
COMMISSIONER CAN TARA.
.
VICTOR WITH THE.
ALTHOUGH THE TAPPED RATE HASN'T
NEW AND INVENTIVE INNOVATIVE
APPROACH WATER STORAGE.
IT'S ALSO CLEAR THAT THE PROJECT
WOULD BE SELECTED BY THE
COMMISSION THROUGH COMPETITIVE
PUBLIC PROCESS.
AND.
AS DESCRIBED EARLIER THE CHAPTER
I DO NOT GUARANTEE EARMARKED.
FOR ANY SPECIFIC PROJECT.
WELL I I THINK IT WAS A WISE
DECISION BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
SUBSEQUENTLY BY THE VOTERS IN
APPROVING IT THAT. THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE BEST PROJECTS TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND INDEED SEVERAL OF THE
PROJECTS THAT AM COMPETING FOR
FUNDING CAN MAKE.
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTION TO
ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S WATER STORAGE NEEDS
IN THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
IN ADDITION THERE IS ENOUGH
MONEY TO FUND ALL OF THESE
PROJECTS.
AND SO IT IS ONLY SENSIBLE.
THAT THOSE PROJECTS
WITH THE MOST PROMISE FOR PUBLIC
BENEFITS ARE SELECTED FOR
FUNDING.
THERE ARE NUMEROUS VERY
PROMISING PROJECT PROPOSED HOME
ESPECIALLY IMPRESSED WITH SOME
OF THE INVADING GROUND WATER
PROJECTS.
SOME OF WHICH PROVIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS IN PLACE.
AND ALSO INCREASE WATER SUPPLY
BUTA FOR HUMAN USES DURING
DROUGHT YEARS.
AND SOME OF THE GROUNDWATER
PROJECTS ARE DESIGNED TO WORK IN
CONCERT WITH EXISTING.
AND POTENTIALLY FUTURE SERVICE
TOWARDS RESOURCED TO INCREASE
WATER SUPPLY RELEASE RESILIENCY.
AND PROVIDE DIRECT PUBLIC
BENEFITS FOR PATIENT WHILE.
IN FACT I THINK ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL PROMISES OF THE WATER
SYSTEM STORAGE INVESTMENT
PROGRAM IS THE POSSIBILITY OF
OPERATING A COMBINATION OF NEW
PROJECTS.
IN CONCERT WITH ONE ANOTHER.
AND CONCERT WITH EXISTING
STORAGE PROJECTS GROUNDWATER AND
SURFACE WATER TO MULTIPLY THE
BENEFITS.
BEYOND WHAT WOULD BE ACHIEVABLE
WITHIN A SINGLE PROJECT.
I HOPE THE COMMISSION CAN
INCORPORATE CONSIDERATION OF
THESE SYNERGISTIC BENEFITS IN
THEIR EVALUATIONS TO ENSURE THE
SELECTION OF A PORTFOLIO OF
PROJECTS.
THAT MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS TO
THE PUBLIC.
A THIRD POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
IS MORE PROCEDURAL AND REFLECTS
OF WHAT. WHAT DONE MISTOOK
DESCRIBED AND THAT'S ABOUT
TRANSPARENCY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
INPUT?
VERY MUCH ENCOURAGE.
CAN YOU TRANSPARENCY OF THE
WATER COMMISSION AND IT APPEARS
TO BE AND I'M AN EMPHASIS OF THE
COMMISSION.
AND.
THE COMMISSION THOUGH AS I'VE
NOTED AND SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE AND AND EMPHASIZED.
HE'S UNDER A LOT OF PRESSURE
TO DO THIS QUICKLY.
PROGRESS IS IMPORTANT AND WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO SEETHE
COMMISSION COMPLY WITH THE
SCHEDULE LAID OUT THE LAW AND TO
ENSURE THAT.
THE DOLLARS DO GO TO FIND
PROMISING PROJECTS.
HOWEVER IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE WITH A STAKE.
AS A REASONABLE CHANCE TO FOLLOW
AND ASSESS THE PROCESS.
THE CURRENT SCHEDULE LAID OUT OF
MY MY BY THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
HAS ALLOWS ONLY TEN DAYS BETWEEN
THE COMMISSION STAFF
ANNOUNCEMENT OF THEIR REVISED
PUBLIC BENEFIT RATIOS WHICH IS.
ONE OF THE MORE IMPORTANT
CRITERIA FOR PROJECTS ELECTION.
A BETWEEN THAT ANNOUNCEMENT AND
THE COMMISSIONERS COMMISSION'S
HEARING ON MY FIRST. TO MAKE A
DECISION ON RECOMMENDATIONS.
THIS REALLY ISN'T ENOUGH TIME TO
REASONABLY ALLOW FOR
STAKEHOLDERS TO DIGEST THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AT PRESENT CLEAR
IMPORTANT POINTS FOR THE
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER.
FOR SOME OF US SOURCE REQUESTING
AN ADDITIONAL TWO WEEKS IN THAT
WINDOW AND I THINK IT'S A
REASONABLE QUEST.
REQUEST GIVEN THE LEVEL OF
INVESTMENT DECISION THAT IS
BEING MADE NINE COURAGE THE
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER THAT
REQUEST.
TO A CONCLUSION.
I WOULD URGE YOU AND YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE.
SUPPORT AND PERHAPS BE A BIT
PATIENT WITH THE WATER
COMMISSION IN THEIR PROCESS
AS THEY CARRY OUT THE
LEGISLATURE'S AND THE PUBLIC'S
MANDATE.
ANOTHER PART YOU PROPONENTS ARE
ANXIOUS TO GET A RESOLUTION AND
IN SOME CASES MOVE FORWARD.
CASES TO MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR
PROJECTS IN FACT WE ARE ALSO
ANXIOUS.
TO GET SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
OPERATING SO THAT WE CAN BEGIN
REALIZING THE PUBLIC BENEFITS
THAT THEY OFFER.
BUT THE QUICKEST OF THESE
PROJECTS.
SOME THE GROUNDWATER PROJECTS
WILL TAKE FIVE YEARS.
TO BE IMPLEMENTED UP TO FIVE
YEARS TO BE IMPLEMENTED SOME OF
THE SERVICE STORAGE PROJECTS TEN
TO FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND SO AND WE'RE SPENDING TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
SO IF IT TAKES ANOTHER MONTH OR
TWO EVEN IF THE SCHEDULE SLIPPED
A LITTLE THIS IS ACCEPTABLE.
WE NEED TO GET THIS RIGHT.
I PUT CALIFORNIA'S WATER SYSTEM
AND A TRAJECTORY TOWARD
RESILIENCE.
ALL THIS IS TO SAY.
FIGURING OUT HOW TO DO STORAGE
PROJECT FOR PUBLIC PUBLIC
BENEFITS IS NEW AND IT'S TOUGH.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET IT
RIGHT.
WE ALL HAVE FRUSTRATIONS WITH
THE PROJECT WITH THE PROCESS.
BUT LET'S BE PATIENT GET IT
RIGHT. AND WE WILL ALL WATER
USERS AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
BE BETTER OFF IF WE DO IT WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU BUT TO BOTH THE ALL
FOUR OF YOU WHO LIVE.
.
S. INITIATED THE DISCUSSION I
KNOW MR AND SOLACE WANTED TO
JUMP RIGHT IN.
ASKING SOME QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
APPRECIATE.
EACH OF YOUR TESTIMONY
ESPECIALLY THE HISTORICAL
CONTEXT.
EVEN WITH MY PREDECESSOR.
A BIG PART OF THOSE NEGOTIATIONS
REMEMBERING ALL THE NEGOTIATIONS
I THINK A LOT OF US.
HERE ON THIS COMMITTEE WERE.
FOUR OF THE TWENTY FOURTEEN
BOND.
BUT YOU KNOW I JUST HAD A
COUPLE QUESTIONS I WANT TO ASK
IN ONE OF THE THINK OF THE
COMMISSION AS WELL FOR ALLOWING
IT LEAVES ONE TWO THREE FOUR OF
US.
AT LEAST ON THIS DIETS WERE AT
THE COMMISSION MEETING AND
PROVIDED TESTIMONY. OF THEIR NAY
AND I DON'T WANT TO REHASH
EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID THERE I
THINK IT WAS.
PRETTY WELL UNDERSTOOD WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE WAS COMING FROM AND.
AND THE REQUEST THAT WE'RE
GETTING FROM OUR CONSTITUENCY
KNOW OBVIOUSLY I THINK SEVERAL
OF YOU GUYS HAVE MADE COMMENTS
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT THE.
THE INVESTMENTS IN THESE FUNDS.
ARE ISSUED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
AND YOU KNOW I JUST WANTED ASK
BECAUSE WE HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSION ABOUT.
THE APPLICANTS AND THE
APPLICANTS BEING ABLE TO BE
PROVIDED THE INFORMATION THAT
THEY NEEDED TO CLARIFY THEIR
APPLICATIONS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
NEARLY.
ALL OF THE APPLICANTS.
THAT APPLIED OF APPEALED.
AND THAT.
ITS BEEN VERY PUBLIC CAME AND
THEIR SCORES AND AND WHAT NOT
BUT YOU KNOW MOVING FORWARD. YOU
KNOW TODAY'S MARCH TWENTIETH AND
WE KNOW THAT THOSE PILLS
WILL BE ONLINE ON APRIL
TWENTIETH SO OF A MONTH FROM NOW
I BELIEVE IS IS PROCESS.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY ONLINE NOW
OKAY.
AND THEN SO ON.
.
SO RESPONSES TO THE PILLS WILL
BE POSTED ONLINE ON APRIL
TWENTIETH.
SO BUT WITH THAT.
WITH THAT SAID AND I REMEMBER AT
THE COMMISSION MEETING IT WAS
STATED THAT.
COMMISSION STAFF WAS GOOD BE
WORKING WITH THE APPLICANTS AND
SIT DOWN WITH THEM TO GO OVER
THESE A TO GO OVER THEIR
APPEALS.
BUT.
SINCE THAT COMMISSION MEETING
AND GIVEN THE APRIL TWENTIETH I
BELIEVE IS THE NEXT BIG
DEADLINE.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR. THOSE PEOPLE.
BETTER FAR IN THIS APPEAL
PROCESS.
TWO WORK WITH COMMISSION STAFF
OR TO REQUEST ON A NEED BASIS IF
THEY WANT TO SIT DOWN WITH STAFF
TO GO OVER THOSE PARTS OF THEIR
APPLICATIONS THAT MIGHT NOT BE
CLEAR TO COMMISSION STAFF IN
TERMS OF. OTHER PUBLIC BENEFIT
RATIO.
LIKE YOU'VE JUST TO LOOK AT YOUR
QUESTION TO ME JUST A LITTLE BIT
OF CONTEXT TO EVERYONE AND THAT
IS THAT. WHEN WE OPEN THE
APPLICATION PERIOD WHICH WAS
FOUR AND A HALF MONTHS
WE HAD OVER SIXTY STAFF
AVAILABLE THAT ENTIRE TIME FROM
FISH AND WILDLIFE DEPARTMENT
WATER RESOURCES AND STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. AND THE
STAFF THAT WAS AVAILABLE TO WORK
WITH APPLICANTS WERE ALL THE
SUBJECT AREA EXPERTS IT WILL BE
DOING THAT HAVE BEEN DOING THE
EVALUATIONS OF THESE.
APPLICATIONS
ARM.
FOUR HAVE MONTHS THEY WERE THERE
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AS PEOPLE
WERE PUTTING TOGETHER THIS.
COMPLEX APPLICATION PROJECTS
PROCESS WHICH WE ALL ABSOLUTELY
RECOGNIZED.
.
WHAT UP WHEN WE GOT THE APPEALS
FROM THE APPLICANTS
WE RECEIVED OVER NINE THOUSAND
FILES AND UPDATE THEIR
APPLICATIONS?
WE POSTED ALL OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS TWO DAYS AFTER
RECEIVING THEM ALL OF THOSE ARE
ONLINE ON THE WATER COMMISSION
SITE NOW FOR INDIVIDUALS TAKE A
LOOK AT.
I WOULD HOPE THAT ANYONE WITH
SPECIFIC INTEREST IN ANY
SPECIFIC PROJECTS CAN GO AND
JUST TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE
WHAT THEY'RE PRESENTING. ARM
AND.
PART OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IT
AS A COMMISSION.
OPEN PLEASE IS AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS WERE LISTENING VERY
CAREFULLY TO EVERYBODY WHO'S
PRESENTING TO ALL OF THE STAKE
HOLDERS AND INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE.
WHO ARE?
FOCUSED ON THESE PROJECTS AND
WE'RE LISTENING AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO THIS.
I KEEP.
THE PROCESS MOVING FORWARD AND
ALLOW EVERYBODY ACCESS AND.
WHERE STE WHERE WE HAVE NOT MADE
DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO DO THAT
BUT WE'RE WATCHING YOU KNOW WHAT
WERE ALL ANXIOUS TO GET THE NEW?
PUBLIC BENEFIT RATIOS
IN FRONT OF US AND MEAN THAT
THAT CAN MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
IN ME YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I SAID.
SHORTLY OR I WAS SOMEBODY SAID
SOMETHING TO ME ABOUT THIS
EFFORT HAVE THAT'S THE RIGHT WAY
TO PUT IT.
AND THAT WAS WHAT YOU GUYS DID
WAS YOU HANDED THE HOMEWORK BACK
AND SAID WE NEED. WE NEED TO
HELP YOU WITH THIS AND WE WANT
TO GET THE RIGHT ANSWERS BECAUSE
WE WANT TO GIVE YOU THE FUNDING
FOR THESE PROJECTS AND GET THE
BEST ANSWERS POSSIBLE SO. I HAVE
TO SAY THINK THAT OUR PROCESSES
ITERATIVE AND WE REALLY WANT TO
BE SUCCESSFUL OF THIS WILL MAKE
EVERY EFFORT TO DO THAT GOT IT
SO THAT YOU GIVEN THE HOMEWORK
BACK.
IF
STUDENT OR THE APPLICANT HAS
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND THEY
CAN STILL WORK WITH COMMISSION
STAFF ON A NEED BASIS WELL I
THINK I I DON'T KNOW MY GUESS IS
THAT. I DON'T KNOW HOW TO ANSWER
THAT EXCEPT THAT.
.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO HANDLE
THAT ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS AND
THE INFORMATION THAT COMES UP IN
THAT END UP BECAUSE I HOPE. THAT
IN THE APPEAL PROCESS AND I'VE
LISTENED TO MOST OF THE MEETINGS
WHICH WERE POSTED THEY'RE ALL
AVAILABLE ONLINE THE ONE HOUR
MEETINGS. AND IT'S VERY
INTERESTING BECAUSE IN SOME OF
THEM YOU CAN WRITE AWAYS HERE
RIGHT AWAY YOU HEAR THE PROJECT
OPPONENTS SUBJECT AREA EXPERTS
TALKING AND. ABSOLUTELY
CONNECTING WITH THE STAFF FROM
THESE THREE AGENCIES ARE GOOD
OKAY NOW WE GET IT SO HERE'S
WHAT WE'LL DO IN THAT AND.
IT'S LANGUAGE OF A LOT OF US TO
UNDERSTAND BUT THERE'S CLEARLY
CONNECTIONS THERE AND IT AND
ACTUALLY I HAVE TO SAY THAT
THOSE MEETINGS VARIED I THINK IN
THEIR SUCCESS WILL HAVE TO SEE
HOW THAT GOES.
AND IS THE COMMISSION STILL
LOOKING TO OBLIGATE ALL THESE
FUNDS BY THE SUMMER ALTHOUGH THE
ONLY THING AND I THINK IT'S A
GOOD QUESTION.
ABOUT THE ONLY THING THAT WE CAN
OBLIGATE THIS SUMMER IS THE
EARLY FUNDING FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT SOME OF THE COSTS
ASSOCIATE WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTATION FOR THE PROJECTS.
THAT'S IT WILL BE ABLE TO.
TO DECIDE IT.
JULY.
AND IN JULY WILL ALSO BE
DETERMINING THE MAXIMUM.
CONDITIONAL ELIGIBILITY OF OF
FUNDING SO. THAT MEANS.
BASED ON THE SCORES THE PROJECT
SCORES AND HOW THEY ARE RANKED
AND.
IN THE THREE DAY A.
MEANING THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A
LITTLE LIE WILL.
BASED ON THAT INFORMATION.
.
A.
DETERMINE ALL I'LL SAY THAT THE
CEILING OF THE FUNDING BECAUSE
AGAIN IT'S CONDITION ALL AND
IT'S BASED ON.
THE APPLICANT'S COMPLETING.
OF A.
FOR LACK OF BETTER TERM CERTAIN
DOCUMENTATION AND AT THAT IT'S
REQUIRED IN THE BOND.
GOT IT.
OKAY AN WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT
THAT NUMBER IS AT THIS POINT.
THEY'LL HAVE TO COMPLETE THE
EACH APPLICANT WHO.
WHO HAS QUALIFIED FOR?
THE VAN.
IF OUR SORRY SIGIL ON TERM.
THE MAXIMUM CONDITIONAL
ELIGIBILITY A.
DETERMINATION OF FUNDING.
OF.
THE FINAL WILL BE. DEPENDENT ON
THEM COMPLETING ALL THE OTHER
STEPS THAT ARE REQUIRED IN
BONDS.
SO IF I HAD THE.
I'M SORRY.
CUP
COUPLE MORE QUESTIONS IF IF I
HAD THAT CONSTITUENTS BACK HOME
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY VERY
INTERESTED IN WATER POLICY IN MY
AND MY PART OF THE DISTRICT.
AND IF THEY WERE TO ASK ME SO
WHEN DO WE ANTICIPATE THIS TWO
POINT SEVEN.
BILLION DOLLARS OF CHAPTER
EIGHT MONEY TO BE FULLY
ALLOCATED WHAT WOULD BE A GOOD
RESPONSE
WHEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RECEIVES THE ASSURANCES AND
DOCUMENTATION. THAT.
GIVES US THE CONFIDENCE TO.
TWO AND LET THE MONEY THERE TO.
DIRECT MONEY TO THE PROJECT.
SO WE'LL BE DOING GO GO AHEAD
YEAH NOT SO THAT WOULD MEAN THEN
NOT. NECESSARILY THE SUMMER BUT
HOPEFULLY BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR I MEAN OR WHAT WHAT'S THE
GOAL THAT THE COMMISSION AND
EVERYONE IS WORKING TOWARDS TO
ACTUALLY. OBLIGATE THE TWO POINT
SEVEN SO THAT WE COULD ACTUALLY
SEE IT START GOING TOWARDS
PROJECTS AND AND THINGS THAT
PEOPLE CAN CAN POINT TO AND SAY
THAT'S BEING DONE.
I HOPE THAT COULD IT GO HIT
CARE.
I THINK THAT.
THAT THAT MAY VERY.
A PENDING UPON THE PROJECT.
YOU KNOW EACH PROJECT HAS THEIR
OWN TIMELINE RIGHT. SO.
OF I THINK OF. WHAT WHAT ONE
THING IT THOUGH IS AS I
INDICATED BEFORE THAT? THAT FOR
THESE PROJECTS THAT HAVE LONG.
PRE CONSTRUCTION.
TIMELINES.
THEY NEED TO COMPLETE.
CERTAIN ELEMENTS.
OTHERWISE THEY WILL BE DEEMED.
A CERTAIN DOCUMENTS OTHERWISE
THEY WILL BE DEEMED INELIGIBLE
BY JANUARY FIRST TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO.
AND THAT'S STATED IN THE BOND
NO.
YET EVERYONE WANTS TO SEE
PROGRESS BEING MADE ON ON WHAT
IS BEING ALLOCATED.
YET IT'S EASIER FOR ME TO GO
BACK TO TALK TO.
FOLKS AND SAY OKAY.
OF THE TWO POINT SEVEN THESE ARE
THE PROJECTS I GOT PICKED THIS
IS WHAT'S BEING DONE. OBVIOUSLY
IF NO PROGRESS IS BEING MADE
THEN YOU REEVALUATE THAT.
BUT IT'S ALSO USEFUL FOR I KNOW
FOR MYSELF AND PROBABLY SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES TO GO BACK AND
SAY.
OKAY THIS IS WHAT'S BEING DONE
THIS IS THE TIMELINE THIS IS
WHAT THEY'RE WORKING TOWARDS YOU
KNOW GIVEN EVERYBODY.
A PLATE SO PROCESS AND
TURNS THAN OTHER PEOPLE WORKERS
THEIR HOMEWORK
USING YOUR ANALOGY. SHOWING
THEIR WORK.
A SO SO TO SPEAK THEN YOU KNOW
THAT'S SOMETHING WE CAN POINT TO
AND SAY THIS IS THE GOAL OF THIS
IS WHAT'S BEING DONE AS OPPOSED
TO. YOU KNOW I GET A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE FRUSTRATED AT NOT A
SURLY WITH WHAT. WITH ANSWERING
THE COMMISSION HERE BUT ALSO
WITH OTHER AGENCIES IN THIS SAY
OKAY IT'S ALL CAUGHT UP IN THE
BUREAUCRACY AND. NOTHING'S BEING
DONE WE PASS THIS YOU KNOW FOUR
YEARS AGO IN.
YOU KNOW HOW HOW CAN WE SEE THE
SIX COME TO FRUITION.
AND SO.
WORKING TOWARDS THAT GOAL IN AND
GETTING THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
AND IT WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
MYSELF AND.
PROBABLY SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
AS WELL. I AM OMIT MENTION OF A
MISTER HALL MENTIONED IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THAT THIS BEING A
NEW PROGRAM IT'S NOT FOR
EVERYBODY.
AND SO WE'VE CUT SUBJECT AREA
EXPERTS FROM FISH AND WILDLIFE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD NDW ARE WHO ARE DOING
THEIR BEST BECAUSE AS YOU SAID.
MAURICE.
NEED OF THIS IS CARBON A NEW
PATH FORWARD AND AND SO IT IS
TAKING I THINK MORE WORK THAN
WHAT WE ALL EXPECTED BUT IT'S
ALSO REALLY CRITICAL I THINK IN
TERMS OF. OF.
GOING.
I THINK FUTURE PROCESSES
HOPEFULLY WE'LL LEARN WE WILL
LEARN A LOT IN THIS PROCESS AND
MAKE FUTURE PROCESS
SMOOTHER.
YOU KNOW AND.
AND I THINK OF IT ALSO IS AYE
ICE SERVICE ELECTED MEMBER OF A
BORDER OF WATER PROGRESS LIVE.
AND IF WE WERE TO BUILD OUR OWN
WATER STORAGE PROJECT WE WOULD
STILL HAVE TO MEET STATE
REQUIREMENTS IN TERMS OF
DOWNSTREAM ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS.
AND SO. OUTSIDE OF OF THESE
FUNDS ANYBODY WHO'S DOING A
WATER STORAGE PROJECT HAS TO
COMPLY WITH THESE SORTS OF
CONDITIONS.
BUT IN THIS CASE IT'S THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
INVESTING IN THAT PART OF THE
PROJECT THAT'S THE INTERESTING
THING ABOUT THIS.
THIS WHOLE PACKAGE TO IS THAT IF
IF ANY OF YOU WERE UP THE IN IF
YOU SERVED ON A IF YOU WERE PART
OF A A WATER UTILITY. WE'RE
GONNA BUILD WATER STORAGE YOUR
CUSTOMERS WOULD HAVE TO PAY FOR
THE WHOLE THING.
INCLUDING THAT DOWNSTREAM.
BENEFIT THAT YOU WOULD BE STORY
IN THIS CASE IT'S THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S GONNA STEPPED
IN AS A PARTNER AND OFFSET THAT
PART OF THE COST THEN AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WANT TO DO BELIEVE ME
THAT DAY AND WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE
OUR ABILITY. TO
PORT THESE PROJECTS THAT NON I
APPRECIATE.
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY THE WATER
COMMISSION HEARING MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN HELPING.
.
CORRECT THE SHIP I GUESS SO TO
SPEAK IN TERMS OF.
MAKE SURE THAT THE APPLICANTS
WERE HEARD THAT PROCESS IS
ACTUALLY MOVING FORWARD AND SO.
I DO APPRECIATE THAT IT AND YOU
TAKE IN OUR TESTIMONY
INTO ACCOUNT AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT AS WELL.
YOU KNOW AND YOU KNOW.
YOU JUST MENTIONED AND MISTER
HART TALKED ABOUT IT TO THAT
EVEN ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY ONE DIDN'T HAVE SPECIFIC
EARMARKS IN TERMS OF.
PACIFIC PROJECTS I KNOW IN THE
CHAPTER EIGHT LANGUAGE WE DID.
OUTLINE AND WE DID REFERENCE I
THE CAL FED DATA BAY DELTA
PROGRAM RECORD OF DECISION.
I DATED AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH.
AND SO IN A CHAPTER EIGHT ADULTS
AND PROVISION A SECTION TWO
SEVEN NINETY SEVEN POINT ONE
PAGE TWENTY TWO. SO I DON'T WANT
THAT TO BE LOST AS WELL.
AND I THINK I'VE SAID THE
COMMISSION UNDER.
AS SUCH THANK YOU THINK YOU SAW
US I I THINK THAT THE QUESTION
YOU ASK.
ABOUT TIME LINES ISN'T UP A
HYPOTHETICAL ONE IT IT'S A REAL
QUESTION THAT. THAT WAS JUST
ASKED OF ME BY THE MEDIA RIGHT
FOR YEARS.
IN THE MAKING CLEARLY.
IT IS A NEW. ARENA THAT THAT WE
ARE WORKING IN BUT.
I THINK.
HIGHER LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY IN.
.
ALLOWS FOR INSIGHT TO BOTH THE
PROCESS IN THE PROGRESS.
AND WHY WITHOUT A DOUBT THE
INCLUSIVENESS OF STAKEHOLDERS I
THINK.
MINIMIZES THE LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION AND ANXIETY RITE OF.
ALONG THIS IS BAD TAKEN I KNOW
OF MISA TALK THAT YOU HAD
SOMETHING YOU WANTED TO ADD TO
THAT YES I WANNA GO BACK VQ TO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOLACE FIRST
QUESTION YOU WERE NOTING THAT
THE RESPONSES TO THE APPEALS
WOULD BE ONLINE ON APRIL
TWENTIETH IS THE SCHEDULE FOR
THAT. YOU WERE ASKING WOULD
THERE BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
INTERACTION ARE ABOUT.
AND.
I THINK THAT'S AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION THE BECAUSE OF THE
ORIGINAL DISCONNECT BE. ALONE WE
WERE SO GLAD THERE IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR APPEALS AND NOW
AS WAS MENTIONED A LOT OF
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION HAS BEEN
SUBMITTED AND THE REVIEWERS ARE
REVIEWING THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION.
SO WE THINK ONE OF THE FUTURE
INTERACTIONS THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN IS REGARDING THAT. NEW
INFORMATION THAT'S COME IN AND
WE ARE SUGGESTING THAT THERE BE
A MEETING IN EARLY APRIL ON FOR
THAT PURPOSE AND I THINK I
THINK.
I KNOW THAT THE COMMISSION AND
THE STAFF ARE LOOKING AT WHAT IS
THE RIGHT PROCESS WE APPRECIATE
THEM LOOKING AT THAT BUT THAT'S
ONE OF THOSE INTERACTIONS THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN BEFORE. THE OF
THE FINAL ON DECISIONS ON THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT RATIOS ARE POSTED
AND I AND I APPRECIATE THAT FACT
THAT COMMENT I BELIEVE I JUST
HEARD FROM THE COMMISSION TO
THAT THEY WERE GOING TO ALLOW
THAT ON THE NEED BAY SO
HOPEFULLY WE CAN'T CONNECT MAYBE
BEFORE THE APRIL. TWENTIETH SO
IF THERE'S ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
PROVIDED ARE CLARIFIED THAT IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT IS A.
CORRECT YOU KNOW WHAT I MAY BE
BACK TO CORRECTLY IF IT'S OKAY
I'D LIKE TO INVITE OUR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER JOE YOUNG UP TO TALK
ABOUT THIS AS WELL BECAUSE HE
LISA EATEN DAY TO DAY MANAGEMENT
OF STAFF ON.
RIGHT.
MORNING MY NAME'S JOEY ON THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION.
SO THERE'S SCRIPT TO QUESTIONS
THAT SEEM TO BE GOING AROUND
THAT I WANTED TO FIRST AND GO
BACK AND MAYBE ADDRESS THE.
MEMBERS ALICE'S QUESTION ABOUT.
WHAT'S THE TIMELINE IN WHAT WHAT
CAN WHEN CAN WE TELL PEOPLE WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
SO THAT THE WAY THE STATUTE IS
WRITTEN.
.
THE COMMISSION CANNOT ALLOCATE
FUNDS
EXCEPT FOR THE EARLY FUNDING AND
TELL ALL THE REQUIREMENTS ARE
MET IN SEVEN AND SEVEN FIVE ONE.
AND SO THAT PRESENTED A PROBLEM
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM.
BECAUSE IT PUTS YOU ON IN IN A
LITTLE BIT OF A DO LOOP THEY
CAN'T GET THERE ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS AND SEVEN NINE
SEVEN FIVE ONE IS A HUNDRED
PERCENT COMMITMENT FOR THE NON
PROGRAM FUNDING.
AND SO INTEL FOLKS UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE STATE WOULD MIGHT BE
ABLE TO COMMIT IT'S HARD TO GO
DO THAT.
AND SO IN THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PROGRAM WHAT WE DID IS WE
CREATED THIS AWFUL TERM.
MAXIM CONDITIONALS ABILITY
DETERMINATION WHICH IS REALLY IT
PUT PRELIMINARY COMMITMENT TO
PLAN A DECISION BY THE
COMMISSION IN JULY.
TO SAY GETTING ALL YOUR
REQUIREMENTS TOGETHER IS THIS
SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO DO BUT
HERE IS WHAT WE WOULD BE WILLING
TO COMMIT SHOULD YOU GO DO THAT
SO THAT ALLOWS THE APPLICANTS
THEN TO ENTER INTO.
.
INTO A BETTER SELF PACED.
TIME PERIOD WHEN THEY CAN GET
ALL THOSE.
REQUIREMENTS DONE AND THEN COME
BACK TO THE COMMISSION FOR THE
FINAL WORD SO IN JULY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AT THE
COMMISSION WILL BE MAKING THOSE
PRELIMINARY DETERMINATIONS AND
SO AT THAT POINT YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND WHAT PROJECTS
WOULD BE A HAVE WHICH FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
BUT THEY NEED TO GO BACK AND DO
THE THINGS THAT THAT THE STATUTE
REQUIRED THEM TO DO FIRST.
AND COMMISSION STAFF WILL BE
WORKING WITH THEM TO TO CLARIFY
THAT.
RIGHT SO AS WE GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS THEY WILL BE THEY WILL
HAVE TO COME BACK AYE AFTER JULY
FIRST OR GIVE THE COMMISSION
THE.
.
PROGRESS REPORTS OF SO THAT THE
COMMISSION UNDERSTANDS THAT WHAT
PROGRESS THEY'RE MAKING IN THE
COMMISSION HAS THE DISCRETION TO
SAY IF SOMETHING DOESN'T WORK
OUT.
PERMIT THE WATER RIGHT WHATEVER.
THAT THE COMMISSION CAN SAY OKAY
WE'RE GONNA CHANGE YOUR MIND ANY
TO GO FARTHER DOWN THE LIST SIR
JOHN TAKE AS MANY BASS OF
INDIRECT RESPONSE TO WHAT MISS
TACK HELPED OUTLINE.
WILL APPLICANTS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY IN CRAPS EARLY APRIL
TO WORK WITH COMMISSION ON THIS
SO THEN TO GO BACK INTO THE
QUESTION THAT THAT THE. CITY
TOOK WAS WAS TALKING ABOUT IS
WHAT ARE THE INTERACTIONS THAT
WE SHOULD BE HAVING WITH
APPLICANTS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WE'VE WE'VE CERTAINLY HEARD.
A LOT ABOUT WANTING TO HAVE
THOSE INTERACTIONS I'M SUPPOSED
BE TALKING TO THE COMMISSION
TOMORROW AT THE MEETING ABOUT
WHAT WE THINK IS APPROPRIATE.
IT'S VERY I THINK THE PRE APRIL
TWENTIETH A SUGGESTION THAT
APPLICANTS HAVE MADE.
CREATE SOME PROBLEM FOR US IN
TERMS OF OF WHAT I CALL PLIGHT
FAIRNESS.
.
I THINK WHAT EVERYONE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IN TERMS OF THE
FAIRNESS THE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT AND THEREFORE IT BE A
FAIR OPPORTUNITY TO EVERYONE
THAT WISHES TO PURSUE IT. PICNIC
WE CAN OFFER IT EIGHT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS TO COME IN
ON A VOLUNTARY BASIS THAT'S TRUE
I THINK.
THE DIFFICULTY WITH THE PRE
TWENTIETH MEETING.
IS.
THE INTERACTION THAT EVERYBODY
LIKED SO MUCH WAS AFTER WE HAD A
PUBLIC DOCUMENT RELEASED IN
FEBRUARY WHEN WE COULD TALK
ABOUT.
WHAT THE STAFF HAD DONE YEAH?
WHAT IT DIFFICULT PROBLEMATIC
FOR US BECAUSE NEARLY ALL OF THE
APPLICANTS
NOW GONE TO APPEAL AND EVERYBODY
WAS UPSET BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
CLEAR ON THE PROCESS AND SO?
YOU KNOW AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
FIGHTING AGAINST UP HERE.
SO THE DID WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
THE APPLICANT SIDE IS THAT. THEY
WOULD LIKE.
STAFF TO ASK THEM CLARIFYING
QUESTIONS
FOR THE TWENTY OF.
SO IF STAFF ASKED ONE APPLICANT
A CLARIFYING QUESTION AND HAS NO
CLARIFYING QUESTIONS FOR ANY OF
THE OTHER APPLICANTS.
AND THEN THE ALL THE OTHER
APPLICANTS
DO WORSE ORG.
THAN THE ONE THEY ASKED THE
QUESTION TWO IS THAT IT IS THAT.
IS THAT FAIR TO ALL APPLICANTS
SOME ALMOST STUCK IN THAT PLACE
OF SAYING HOW DO I ASK QUESTIONS
OF EVERYBODY IF I DON'T HAVE
QUESTIONS OF EVERYBODY AND IS IT
FAIR FIREHOUSES QUESTIONS.
WHEN THEY LOOK AT THE OUTCOME
FROM THE STAFF REVIEW
AND SO WE CAN RAISE SOME
UNFAIRNESS QUESTIONS.
ARE SOME.
UNFAIRNESS ISSUES
WITH THAT RUBRIC AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO DEAL WITH
IN TERMS OF WHEN IS IT TIME TO
TO ALLOW FOLKS TO COME IN AND
WHEN DO WE HAVE. THE DISCUSSIONS
AND I THINK IT'S EASIER FROM THE
COMMISSION SIDE. TO BE ABLE TO
BE ASK QUESTIONS BY APPLICANTS
BY STAKEHOLDERS AND US TO
EXPLAIN. WHAT STAFF IS DOING?
MY ABILITY TO DO THAT BEFORE I
RELEASE A PUBLIC DOCUMENT IS
VERY LIMITED. IT IT'S ALMOST
LIKE MOVING UP MY RELEASE DATE.
AND SO THERE ARE SOME ISSUES
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH. AND I WOULD LIKE TO TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH A A.
A MEETING.
AND INTERACTION. SHORTLY AFTER
THE TWENTIETH NOT BEFORE TO
PREPARE FOLKS FROM WHAT THEY MAY
BE COMING INTO THE COMMISSION TO
TALK ABOUT WHERE THE DECISIONS
CAN BE REALLY MADE.
THAT WOULD BE MY PREFERENCE YEAH
AND AND YOU KNOW AND FROM YOU
KNOW MY STEP POINT I'M JUST IF
EVERYONE'S GIVEN AN OPPORTUNITY
TO. TO.
TO SIT DOWN WITH STAFF.
THAT'S AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO
EVERYONE TO ME THAT SEEMS.
SEEMS FAIR BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THE DAY I WANT EVERY APPLICANT
TO FILL THAT THEY HAD EVERY TOOL
AVAILABLE TO THEM. TO MAKE THE
STRONGEST APPLICATION THAT THEY
CAN MAKE.
MOVING FORWARD SO.
NO MATTER HOW THE COMMISSION
DECIDES TO DO THE AWARDS.
AT THE END OF.
THE END OF THE SUMMER AND THE
AND THE YEARS CONTINUES TO
PROGRESS.
EVERYONE AT LEAST BILLS THAT.
THEY HAD THE DUE PROCESS.
THEY HAD ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY COULD A PROVIDED TO IT
HAVE THE STRONGEST APPLICATION
MOVING FORWARD.
AND SO.
I'D LIKE.
I WOULD THINK YOU'D BE.
.
IT WOULD BEHOOVE THE COMMISSION
I THINK JUST TO HAVE PROVIDE
THAT OPPORTUNITY TO THE APPLE
CANCEL THE CAN FILL THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
STRONGEST.
APPLICATION UNDER THE CRITERIA
THAT'S OUTLINED IN THE
OPPORTUNITIES TASSELS QUESTIONS
AS WE CONTINUE TO PROGRESS.
AND SO THAT'S WHY I WAS THINKING
AND YOU KNOW AS OUTLINED THINK
MISTOOK.
FOR THE APRIL TWENTIETH AND
THAT'S A PART OF THAT PROCESS
MOVING FORWARD.
IN A OF APPRECIATE THE THE
SUGGESTIONS AND I THINK WE ARE
WE ONLY TO LOOK AT PURPOSE OF
THE MEETING AND HOW THAT WOULD
THAT BE RUN TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S FAIR AND IT IS HELPFUL.
TOOK TAL PARTIES THEN THAT'S
REALLY WHERE WHERE WE'RE TRYING
TO LOOK AT THIS AND COME BACK
WITH SOMETHING THAT WE THINK
MAKES MAKES SENSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SOLACE WE HAVE
A A NUMBER OF FOLKS ONE ASK
QUESTIONS GALLAGHER FOLLOWED BY
MISTER BIGELOW MISS LEVINE.
IMAGE RUBIO.
I WAS.
FIRST WHY DO YOU WANT TO THANK
ED THE COMMISSIONERS.
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND AND AS
I SAID WHEN WE IT WHEN I SPOKE
TO YOU THAT.
YOUR PUBLIC HEARING I I
APPRECIATE ALL THE THE HARD WORK
THAT I KNOW HAS BEEN PUT INTO
THIS PROCESS.
AND AND YOU KNOW HOW SERIOUSLY
YOU'VE TAKEN EVEN YOU KNOW.
COMING OUT OF PUBLIC MEETINGS UP
AND DOWN THE STATE AND TO HEAR
FROM THE PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW SOME OF THEIR VERY REAL
CONCERNS ABOUT WATER
SUSTAINABILITY WATER
RELIABILITY.
AND WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO DO
THIS RIGHT.
AND I'VE HEARD THAT SEVERAL
TIMES.
FROM PEOPLE HERE SO I I
APPRECIATE THAT.
A YOU KNOW THAT THAT CONCERN AND
ATTENTION TO DETAIL IS HAS BEEN
THERE.
MIGHT MY CONCERNS REALLY REALLY
RELY AROUND AND.
ENSURING THAT THE STATUTE THAT
WAS PASSED.
AND THE BOND THAT WAS VOTED ON
AND PASSED BY THE VOTERS.
THAT IS IS TRUTH IS IS TRULY AND
ACCURATELY CARRIED OUT.
.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
BIG THINGS I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
HERE AND.
I THINK WHAT I'LL START BY IS
BECAUSE I STILL DON'T FEEL I'VE
HEARD A COMMITMENT. AND I WANT
TO HEAR COMMITMENT THAT BETWEEN.
THE DATE OF THIS HEARING.
AND APRIL TWENTIETH WHEN THE
REVIEWERS COME BACK WITH THEIR
RESPONSES
THERE WILL BE A MEETING.
WITH THE STAFF AND THE
APPLICANT.
AT A ONE IS NOT A SUGGESTION.
IT'S.
WILL THERE BE A MEETING WITH
APPLICANTS SO THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND.
AND THEN THEY HAD THAT MEETING
PRIOR TO THE APRIL TWENTIETH
COMING BACK.
IS IT GOING TO BE ONE OR NOT.
YOU KNOW IT BECAUSE THIS AYE
FROM THIS COMMITTEE I WANT TO
HEAR THAT THERE WILL BE.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO HEAR.
I DON'T KNOW WITH THE SCORES ARE
GOING TO BE COME A NO I'M NOT
ASKING FOR THE SCORE TO A NO
THERE WILL BE A MEETING.
WITH THE APPLICANTS PRIOR TO.
THE OFFICIAL RESPONSE COMING
BACK.
BUT ARE WE HAVE A COMMISSION
MEETING TOMORROW WHEN THE ENTIRE
COMMISSION WILL BE TOGETHER
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW.
NOW I CAN'T SPEAK FOR ALL MY
FELLOW COMMISSION MEMBERS AND I
THINK WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT IT AS A COMMISSION.
AND TAKE THAT QUESTION VERY
SERIOUSLY DON'T HAS BEEN. AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE'VE BEEN HAVING WITH
THEIR EXECUTIVE OFFICER AND
STAFF AROUND THIS AND SO.
WITHOUT.
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF MY FELLOW
COMMISSIONERS ARE THE VOICES OF
MY FELLOW COMMISSIONERS I DON'T.
FEEL LIKE I CAN.
ANSWER THAT.
COMPLETE BUT I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BELIEVE ME WE HEAR IT.
RIGHT AND I THINK THAT'S BEEN
EMPHASIZE MANY TIMES SO I JUST.
WELL THE SYNTHESIZER GUINNESS
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN I THINK IT
CAN BE DONE IN A WAY THAT'S
TRANSPARENT AND ALL THOSE THINGS
EVERYBODY'S CONCERNED ABOUT BUT
THERE NEEDS TO HAVE THAT MEANS
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS WHERE
THEY'RE AT AND WHAT OTHER
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
PROVIDE.
PRIOR TO THESE OFFICIAL
RESPONSES COMING BACK ON APRIL
TWENTIETH.
NOW I'M NOT GO TO MY SECOND PART
IS MY ONE OF MY BIG CONCERNS
HERE IS THAT I THINK WERE A LOT
OF THIS FRUSTRATION IS COMING
FROM.
IS THAT ATTORNEYS AND STAFF.
TO ME.
.
MAY BE SORT OF HIJACKING THIS
PROCESS A LITTLE BIT.
I AM AND.
YOU KNOW THAT.
NO THEY NEED TO BE TRUE TO WHAT
THE STATUTE SAYS AND WHAT THE
REGULATIONS SAY.
AND I UNDERSTAND THEIR SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS
ALSO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING
ON THESE AT THE APPLICANTS AND
THE TEAMS THAT ARE PART OF THESE
APPLICATIONS. ARE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS THEIR PEOPLE THAT KNOW
THE STUFF AND I PROVIDING VERY
DETAILED. INFORMATION AND DATA.
AND.
INTO AND WHAT I'M HEARING IS IS
THAT IN SOME CASES THEY'RE KINDA
BE MET WITH THE BLOCKADE.
AT THE STAFF LEVEL SAY NO THIS
IS YOU KNOW THIS IS AN ACCURATE.
EVEN EVEN ONE EXAMPLE BEING THE
EARLY ON STAFF SAYING YOU KNOW
YOU SHOULD REALLY CONSIDER A
SMALLER PROJECT.
WELL THAT'S NOT THERE THAT'S NOT
THEIR DETERMINATION.
TO MAKE ABOUT WHETHER WHAT THE
APPLICATION SHOULD LOOK LIKE AND
YOU KNOW THE AND PROJECTS SHOULD
BE.
THERE IS TO TRULY AND ACCURATELY
APPLY THESE THE STATUTE IN THIS
LANGUAGE.
TO THE APPLICATION.
YOU KNOW DOES IT MEET THESE
THINGS IS THAT ONE OF THESE FIVE
THAT.
FOR CRITERIAS A CALVET PROJECT
THERE'S A REASON WE CALLED UP
THE CAL FED PROJECTS.
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN STUDIED FOR
YEARS AND EVERYBODY IS
IDENTIFIED THEM AS BEING NEED
RIGHT. WHO ALSO CALLED UP GROUND
WATER PROJECTS WE ALSO CON
CALLED OUT REGIONAL PROJECTS
THAT HAVE? THE PUBLIC BENEFITS
RIGHT.
THE PROJECT PASSED HAVE
MEASURABLE IMPROVEMENTS TO THE
DELTA.
PERIOD. THAT'S GONNA ACTUALLY
THAT'S A HARD THING FOR GROUND
WATER PROJECTS TO MEET.
BUT I HAVEN'T HEARD A WHOLE LOT
OF PUSH BACK ON THAT BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
ACCURATELY. AND TRULY CARRIED
OUT IT HAS TO HAVE A NET
IMPROVEMENT.
TO THE ECOSYSTEM THAT DOESN'T
MEAN WHAT SOMEBODY WOULD LIKE IT
TO BE.
NO AND OVER ABOUT THAT NET BUT
ACTUALLY WHAT IS THE EXISTING
CONDITIONS OUT THERE TODAY.
YOU KNOW AND DOES IT PROVIDE A
NET IMPROVEMENT TO THOSE THAT'S
BEING VERY CLEARLY SPELLED OUT
ITS IN THE STATUTES IN THE
REGULATIONS.
BUT I'M STILL HEARING OF STAFF
SAYING.
THINGS LIKE WELL NO WE DON'T
THINK THAT THAT REALLY YOU KNOW
MEETS OVER AND ABOVE THE
STANDARD THAT WE WANT TO PRY AND
THERE'S EVEN MAY BE MOVING SAID
I'M HEARING THAT OFFICIAL
WILDLIFE.
IS THAT THERE'S THERE'S ALMOST A
A MOVING STANDARD AS TO WHAT
CONSTITUTES.
NO NOT IMPROVEMENTS IN AND ALL
THAT GOES TO.
I THINK YOUR JOB WHICH IS THAT
AT THE END OF THE DAY. YOU HAVE
TO.
ENSURE THAT THE STAFF AND THE
ATTORNEYS AND WHOEVER'S LOOKING
AT THIS.
ARE ACCURATELY INTERPRETING THIS
STATUTE AND APPLYING IT.
FAIRLY AND TRULY TO THE
PROJECTS.
AND SO THAT'S ME ON MY.
NO HAVE YOU HAD SOME OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT YOU GUYS HAVE.
WELL OUTLINE BECAUSE THERE'S A
TRANSPARENCY ON THE OTHER SIDE
TO.
THERE'S A TRANSPARENCY FROM THE
APPLICANT THAT ALSO WANT TO SEE
TRANSPARENCY ON THE STAFF SIDE.
AND MAYBE SOME OF THE. IN THEIR
PREJUDICES PREJUDICES ARE BIASES
THAT THEY'RE BRINGING.
TO THE TABLE AS WELL AND THAT
THAT IT IS IT'S NOT LIKE PUBLIC.
AS EMPLOYEES AND AND PEOPLE WHO
ARE REVIEWING THIS DON'T HAVE
THEIR OWN.
BIASES IN MAY BE TALKING TO
DIFFERENT GROUPS AS WELL. THAT
AREN'T APPLICANTS BUT THEY'RE
DEATHLY HAVE AN AGENDA.
AND NO TO ME THAT'S A CONCERN SO
I MEAN IS IS THAT MAYBE MAY IF
YOU CAN ADDRESS.
IS SOME OF THOSE ISSUES THAT
HAVE OF I'M NOT RAISE A COUPLE
DIFFERENT ISSUES THERE BUT MAYBE
YOU CAN ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE.
YOU KNOW A COUPLE THINGS ONE OF
THEM IS DURING ITS READING
MEETINGS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL THE
OTHER AGENCIES THERE THAT ARE
DOING THE EVALUATION SO THAT
THEY CAN. PARTICIPATE IN THE
DISCUSSION IN ANSWERING
QUESTIONS WITH APPLICANTS AND
UNDERSTANDING HOW THOSE THINGS
ARE GOING.
.
I KNOW THE I AM NOT.
I'VE LOOKED AT ALL THE REVIEWS.
AND A LOT OF WHAT I HAVE SEEN
OR MET MUCH OF WHAT I HAVE SEEN
HAS BEEN.
A DISCONNECT IN TERMS OF
DEFINITIONS AND OUTCOMES AND IT
WILL GIVE YOU YOU KNOW AN
EXAMPLE. THAT.
.
DO YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE.
SOMEBODY SAID DO YOU KNOW PER
APPROACH PROPONENTS IS THAT
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE BENEFITS FOR
FISH BY PROVIDING COLD WATER FOR
SO MANY DAYS. WHAT TURNS OUT
THAT?
AND I'M GONNA USE A FICTITIOUS
NUMBER HERE BUT LET'S SAY THEY
HAVE THEY HAVE COLD WATER THEIR
PROJECT WILL PROVIDE COLD WATER
FOR THIRTY DAYS. BUT WHAT FISH
AND WILDLIFE NEEDS ACTUALLY FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO BE EFFECTIVE
WITH THE MANAGEMENT OF FISHES.
SIXTY DAYS
AND SO THEN THERE'S A
NEGOTIATION THEIR OF SO HOW DO
WE DO THIS AND SO THAT THOSE ARE
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT HAVE
COME UP. AND ALSO.
WHEN THE APPLICATION OUT WHEN
REGULATIONS WERE PUT TOGETHER
THEY WERE PRETTY CLEAR.
I'M IS PRETTY CLEAR GUIDANCE IN
THE REGULATIONS IN TERMS OF
MODELS IT NEEDED TO BE USED
UP CLIMATE. CLIMATE IMPACTS AND
THOSE WERE USED IT FAIRLY
DIFFERENTLY DEPENDING ON YOU
KNOW THE APPLICATIONS AND SO
PART OF WHAT'S HAPPENED. IS THE.
I THINK THAT THE.
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT WERE
ALREADY HELD WITH THE PROJECT
APPLICANTS WERE SIGNIFICANT.
AND THEY WENT THROUGH A LOT OF
THOSE SORTS OF MISS
YOU KNOW MISSED UNDERSTANDINGS.
ARE OPEN AND.
TO.
AGAIN WE.
I M. CONFIT WITH THE STAFF THAT
HAS BEEN THE STAFF HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS I'M NOT AWARE OF
ANY UP PRESSURE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING I KNOW THAT THE.
INTO THE DIRECTOR OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IN HIS COVER LETTER FOR
THEIR EVALUATIONS IS VERY CLEAR
THAT.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT. WHAT THE
OUTCOMES ARE GOING TO BE THEY
CAN ONLY REACT TO THE
INFORMATION THEY'RE BEING GIVEN?
AND WITH THE.
THEY'RE APPLYING THE STANDARDS
THAT ARE UNDERSTOOD IN THE IN
THOSE INDUSTRIES AND SO.
.
YOU KNOW I I I DON'T KNOW HOW TO
ANSWER THE QUESTION ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THAT SUBSEQUENT
MEETINGS ON BEFORE APRIL
TWENTIETH.
RIGHT WELL I GUESS WHAT I WOULD
JUST AND WITH IS OKAY I THINK WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT MEAN
HAPPENS BEFORE THE TWENTIETH SO
THAT WE MAY.
SO ANY MISUNDERSTANDINGS ARE
CLEARED UP THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
OFFICIAL MEETING.
.
AND THEN.
BUT WHAT I WOULD DISTRESS TO THE
COMMISSION IS IT LOOK THIS HAS
BEEN PLACED IN YOUR HANDS AND
REALLY IN YOUR HANDS ALONE.
TO MAKE THESE ULTIMATE
DETERMINATIONS.
AND.
AS YOU CAN LOOK AT THE STATUE
YOU CAN LOOK AT THESE RAGS AND
WHAT I WHAT I THINK IS SOMETIMES
HAPPENING IS JUST A DIFFERENCE
IN OPINION.
A ABOUT WHAT THAT WHAT THAT
MEANS IN ANY SAY THEY'RE THEY'RE
APPLYING STANDARDS WILL.
THE PROBLEM IS SOMETIMES THE
STANDARDS CHANGE DEPENDING ON
WHO YOU TALK TO.
AND.
AND SOMETIMES THEY MIGHT BE
APPLYING A STANDARD THAT.
SOMEONE ELSE IS ALSO VERY WELL
VERSED IN THIS DISAGREES WITH
YOU KNOW AND SAYS NOW LOOK AT
THE DATA. WE CAN SHOW YOU THAT
THIS SUCH AND SUCH AS COLD WATER
ACTUALLY DOES HELP FISH.
YOU KNOW AND IS IT JUST THAT HEY
EFFICIENT WILDLIFE SAYS NO
THAT'S JUST THE BOTTOM LINE.
YOU KNOW AND EVEN IF THERE IS
DATA THAT SHOWS IT'S NOT SO. WE
I MEAN THAT CAN'T BE THE ANSWER
IS THAT JUST THEIR THE END ALL
BE ALL.
ULTIMATELY I THINK WHAT I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE YOU IS YOU MAKE THE
DECISION. YOUR COMMISSION MAKES
THAT DECISION AND SAYS NO. WE'VE
SEEN THE DATA WE SEEM WITH THE
SAP COMMITS SIN IS SUBMITTING
AND WE AGREE THAT IT MEETS THE
CRITERIA OUTLINED IN HERE
CRITERIA THAT WE ALL HELP SET
UP.
AND THAT YOU NOW HAVE TO
IMPLEMENT RIGHT.
I JUST DON'T WANT BE THE OPINION
OF SOME WELL.
PUT SOME STAFF PERSON AND THAT
IS THE END ALL BE ALL AND IT'S
NOT ULTIMATELY THE COMMISSION'S
DECISION.
NO AT ON SOME THESE ITEMS
BECAUSE I'M JUST HEARING THAT
THERE'S SOME.
THERE IS SOME OF.
THERE IS SOME DISPUTE WELL AS
SOME OF THESE THINGS.
REASONABLE DISPUTE AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT ALSO WOULD WANT
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT IS THAT THE
SUBSEQUENT MEETINGS WITH THE
COMMISSION.
AND THE PROJECT OPPONENTS AND.
.
IN MAY JUNE AND JULY WILL
INCLUDE REPRESENTATIVES FROM ALL
OF THESE AGENCIES IN THE COMBAT
THAT'S THE POINT AT WHICH THE
COMMISSION IS GONNA BE ABLE TO
ASK. AGENCY REPRESENTATIVES AND
SCIENTISTS LIKE WAIT A MINUTE
HOW DID YOU DO THAT AND SO DID
THE COMMISSION'S JOB TO REALLY
DELVE INTO THOSE THE QUESTIONS
THAT YOU'RE BRINGING UP IN THE
PUBLIC FORUM.
ON EACH OF THESE ELEMENTS
BECAUSE ITS NOT A SITUATION
WHERE THE COMMISSION IS JUST
GOING TO ACCEPT.
SCORES AS THEY ARE HANDED TO US
BY STAFF.
SO THAT IS GOING TO BE
CONTINUING DISCUSSION UP THROUGH
AN UNTIL JULY.
AS WE COME UP WITH THE WITH THE
FINAL DETERMINATIONS AT THAT
POINT.
THANK YOU WAS GALLAGHER.
I THINK I AYE ARE BE
RECOMMENDING TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THAT THAT WE DRAFT THE LETTER TO
THE COMMISSION.
PERHAPS EVEN FOR TOMORROW'S
MEETING AT RESPECTFULLY
REQUESTING.
OF THE.
POTENTIAL GATHERING.
A PRIOR TO THE APRIL TWENTIETH A
AND HOPEFULLY THAT WOULD THAT BE
TAKEN TO SEARS CONSIDERATION BY
THE ENTIRE COMMISSION.
AND I THINK THAT AMONGST THE
STAKEHOLDERS CAN DETERMINE HOW
BEST TO A STRUCTURE. THAT
CONVERSATION WITHOUT THE LEADING
TO ANY AB.
UNFAIRNESS OR YOU KNOW HINDERING
THE COMPETITIVENESS OF YOU KNOW.
I YEAR SCORING.
BUT THAT CERTAINLY THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL SO WELCOMED THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
SIGN ON.
TO THAT LETTER THAT WILL BE
SENDING TO THE COMMISSION.
NEXT A MISTER. A BIGELOW
FOLLOWED BY MISS LEVINE AND THAT
MRS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN YES
I'D BE WILLING TO SIGN ON TO
THAT LETTER I THINK THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT.
FACTOR.
.
AGAIN THANK YOU TO ALL OF THE.
PRESENTERS HERE TODAY.
TAKING TIME TO COME HERE AND
SHARE WITH US YOUR.
YOUR UNDERSTANDINGS IN YOUR
THINKING.
I THINK.
AT WORST LISTENING HERE WERE
LEARNING.
I LOT MORE ABOUT THE
ENLIGHTENMENT OF WHAT'S BEEN
HAPPENING WHAT HASN'T BEEN
HAPPENING.
I THINK THE REAL CRUX OF THE
ISSUE LEAST I'M TAKING AWAY
RIGHT NOW.
IS THERE'S BEEN A.
WELL OPEN DIALOGUE.
AND INFORMATION SOMEWHAT GOING
BACK AND FORTH THERE'S BEEN SOME
DISCONNECT.
I FIND IT DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT.
PEOPLE SITTING ON THE COMMISSION
SIDE.
AND THE PEOPLE WHO WERE
APPLICANTS.
WE'RE SO FAR APART.
I FIND IT HARD.
TO UNDERSTAND WHEN.
JUST USING ONE PROJECT OUT THERE
THAT SAYS.
FOR EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED.
IT WILL RETURN A PUBLIC BENEFIT
OF TWO DOLLARS AND EIGHTY SIX
THAT.
BUT ESCORTED ZERO.
WHAT INFORMATION?
WAS LACKING.
SO I'M STARTING TO FEEL LIKE.
MAYBE ALL THE INFORMATION.
WASN'T FULLY UNDERSTOOD BY
EVERYBODY.
BECAUSE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WAS
SPENT.
MILLIONS.
GETTING APPLICATIONS.
ROCK PORT ONLY SCORED ZERO.
EXPERTS ON BOTH SIDE CAN'T BE
THAT FAR APART.
SO I I ACTUALLY COME BACK TO
WHAT MR SOLVES IS SAYING WHAT MR
GALLAGHER SAYING.
I THINK THERE'D THAT DOES NEED
TO BE A WINDOW AND I UNDERSTAND.
WHY MR YA?
THAT.
HE WANTED SILOS
SO IT WAS A FAIRNESS ISSUE.
BUT HIS SYSTEM OR THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THAT.
I SOMEHOW BROKE DOWN. SO THAT
WE'RE NOT GETTING PROJECTS
AS.
WELL PRESENTED AND SUCCESSFUL AS
POSSIBLE.
THE HAVE ACROSS THE BOARD ZEROS.
SAYS IT WAS BAD INFORMATION OUT
AND THAT INFORMATION IS.
WE START WITH THAT INFORMATION.
YOU'RE GONNA END WITH THAT
INFORMATION.
I WILL BE CONSISTENT.
SO WE'VE GOT A FIX THAT I THINK
THAT'S INCOME BUT UPON THE
COMMISSION.
TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SAY.
WON'T ALLEY.
WE HAD A PROBLEM.
AND WE CAN FIX IT.
I THINK YOU AS A BODY CAN STEP
UP YOUR STAFF.
AND SAY LOOK.
YOU NEED TO WORK WITH THESE
FOLKS.
SHE GALLAGHER WANTS A COMMITMENT
I THINK LETTER NOW FROM THE
CHAIRMAN IT'S GOING TO BE ASKING
FOR. FOR THAT.
THEN AND I'M SUPPORTIVE THAT.
IS IT POSSIBLE.
FOR US TO HEAR SOME.
SOME TAILORED DID POINT THAT
SAYS.
YEAH WE'RE WILLING TO LOOK AT
THAT.
LOOK AT GIVING AN OPEN.
OPPORTUNITY FOR APPLICANTS.
STAFF
TO GET MORE CLARIFYING
INFORMATION.
SO THAT'S PROJECTS CAN BE
LOOKED.
NOT IN A PARTISAN WAY WITH
FAVORITISM BUT WITH AN AYE OF.
TRUE BREATH OF UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT EACH WAS SAYING AND MOUNT.
A POSSIBLE TO HAVE THAT.
SO AS MISTER HALL WAS SAYING.
YOU COULD HAVE A SUCCESSFUL AND
WELL PRESENTED PROJECT.
CAN WE DO THAT.
THAT'S A QUESTION SOME YOU KNOW
I'LL  SAY THAT.
DURING THE APPLICATION PERIOD
AND AS ONE AND JUST PUT THIS IS
A ONE OF THE TENT STAKES AND
THAT IS DURING THE APPLICATION
PERIOD JUST FOR HAVE MONTHS ALL
OF THESE SUBJECT AREA EXPERTS
WERE AVAILABLE FOR STAFF I MEAN
WERE AVAILABLE FOR APPLICANTS.
AND THAT.
I THINK THAT COULD HAVE BEEN.
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF MEN A MUCH
BETTER WAY THAN IT WAS AND THAT
WAS PART BECAUSE I THINK
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZE THE
COMPLEXITY WE WERE DEALING WITH
THEM IN IN THE TWO YEARS OF
HEARINGS THAT WE HAD AND
DEVELOPING THE REGULATIONS.
THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
DISCUSSION OVER KEY POINTS
THROUGHOUT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THOSE REGULATIONS.
SO WAS CLEAR THAT THERE IS
GOING TO BE THE NEED FOR. CLEAR
COMMUNICATION THAT'S PART OF WHY
THE APPLICATION PERIOD WAS SO
LONG AND SO.
BE DEAFENING WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT THIS TOMORROW IS WAS WHAT
I CAN SAY AND THAT AND IT IS
THAT IT HAS NOT BEEN. WHICH YOU
BRING UP IS NOT A TOPIC THAT'S
NOT BEEN. ROOM
ON OUR LAPS THIS WHOLE TIME IT'S
LIKE HOW DO WE DO THIS HOW DO WE
GET THE APPLICANTS.
TO DO THE BEST POSSIBLE PROJECT
IN APPROACH PROPOSALS SO AND
THAT IN PART OF THE AND.
YOU KNOW AND PART OF IT IS THAT
WE ARE ALSO TOLD THIS IS A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS.
SO.
DINA AND THAT'S THAT'S ALSO PART
OF THE CHALLENGE FOR US RIGHT
BUT I GUESS MY REAL ULTIMATE IS.
YOU'RE THE CONTROLLER OF THE KEY
RIGHT.
IF THESE FOLKS DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE KEY MATT.
THEY WERE NEVER DESTINED TO HAVE
SUCCESS.
THEY WERE DESTINED TO HAVE
FAILURE.
KEY IS THAT PAUL COMPONENT OF
SUCCESS.
AND YOU HOLD THE KEY.
KEY MUST BE FIXED.
BEFORE THESE APPLICANTS CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH ANYTHING THAT'S
GONNA.
GIVE THEM A RATING.
THAT WILL BE SEEN AS ACCEPTABLE.
SO IT'S IT'S IT'S AT YOUR LEVEL.
BUT YOU NOW MUST RISE TO THE
OCCASION.
AND DIRECT YOUR STAFF
DIRECT OTHERS THAT NEED TO BE
DIRECTED.
TO ACCEPT THIS AND SAY FOLKS.
EVERYBODY CAME AWAY WITH
NOTHING.
WE MESSED UP.
WE NEED TO FIX THIS AND FIX IT
FAST.
WE PLEASE DO THAT.
VICE CHAIR CARE OF MAKE WANTED
TO MENTION SOME.
JUST AS A CLARIFICATION I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT.
WHAT
THE THE PUBLIC BENEFIT RATIOS
THAT?
WERE RELEASED AND.
FEBRUARY. THOSE WERE INITIAL OF.
OF REGION OF P. BR'S.
AND.
SO THAT GAVE THE THE APPLICANT'S
AN INDICATION OF WHERE THERE MAY
HAVE BEEN ISSUES AND.
ALSO THERE WERE OF.
A STAFF OUR STAFF AND THE
REVIEWING AGENCIES SAT DOWN WITH
THE APPLICANTS IN FEBRUARY TWO
GOAL FOR THOSE AND. AND AGAIN
THOSE ARE INITIAL OF.
OF OF PBR HAS.
AND.
AS THE CHAIRMAN INDICATED WE IN
WE GOT NINE THOUSAND FILES.
IN RESPONSE AND SO IT'S OF.
OF.
SO SO I'M I GUESS WHAT I'M
TRYING TO SAY IS THAT WE HAVE
TAKE YOU KNOW I THINK WE HAVE
TAKEN STEPS TO TRY TO.
OF HABIT A DIALOGUE WITH WITH
THE APPLICANTS THIS IS A VERY
VERY COMPLEX OF. PROGRAM. AND AT
LEAST IN MY OWNS A.
STATE EXPERIENCE OF.
THIS IS A VERY UNIQUE GRANT
PROGRAM AND AND.
.
THAT'S NOT TO TAKE AWAY FROM.
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING MISTER
BIGELOW BUT? BUT IT IS IT IT'S.
IT'S KIND OF AN ODD DUCK IN
IN THE.
STATE GOVERNMENT
YES
BUT AT AT THE SAME TIME.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT A
RECOGNIZE THAT WERE LEADING.
CHARITIES GO BY.
WE CAN'T SQUANDERED THAT ANYMORE
WE HAVE A SYSTEM THAT IS SAID.
AT UP AT PINNACLE POINT OF
POTENTIALLY FAILING AS.
AND IF WE DON'T FIT
START TAKING ACTION NOW.
AND AS WE HEARD FROM MISTER
HOLLAND FROM YOU AND OTHERS.
IT'LL TAKE MANY YEARS TO GET
MANY OF THESE PROJECTS
COMPLETED.
AND WE CONTINUE TO MARCH DOWN A
PATHWAY OF.
IF HAVING.
NO SUCCESS.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US TO
TALK.
TO LOOK AT THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT'S HERE.
AND THIS OPPORTUNITY IS THAT YOU
AS YOU ARE JUST ARTICULATED.
LEVERAGE WHAT PROJECTS WHATEVER
WAS.
THAT ALL DIDN'T MEET MUSTER.
NOW YOU GOT NINE THOUSAND
CORRECTIONS.
NINE THOUSAND CORRECTIONS.
THAT CLEARLY ARTICULATES
THAT THERE WAS.
SOMETHING AMISS IN THE KEY.
VESTED TWICE.
ARE YOU WILLING AT THE
COMMISSION
S. COMMISSIONERS.
TAKE THIS CHARGE
FIX THIS. SITUATION WELL WE'LL
CERTAINLY TAKE IT UP SERIOUSLY
WERE HAVING A MEETING TOMORROW.
I APPRECIATE THAT LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT.
TO TAKE THAT OUT I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL.
FIND A WAY TO REMEDY THIS
SO THAT THEIR CAN BE THIS OPEN
DIALOGUE.
BETWEEN THE PARTIES THAT ARE
AFFECTED WHO ARE THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT WE ALL SERVE.
AND WANT TO GET ENOUGH ACTIVE OR
EFFECTIVE PROJECTS MOVED FORWARD
SO I'LL TAKE THAT.
AS A POSITIVE.
AND AGAIN MISTER CHAIRMAN
WHATEVER YOU CAN DO.
AS CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE TO
HELP.
SURE THAT THIS HAPPENS.
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH YOU AND
DELIVERING THAT THANK YOU.
THAT WE HAVE UP MISS LEVINE
FOLLOWED BY MRS RUBIO AND THEN
THE DOCTOR.
WILL YOU MAKE A COMMITMENT I'M
JUST KIDDING.
WE.
I I WANT TO THANK MISTER CAN
TEAR OWN THIS BAKER.
FOR THE TESTIMONY IN AND FOR
YOUR SERVICE WITH THAT YOUR
OTHER COMMISSIONERS.
THIS IS NOT YOUR DAY JOB. AND
DIE AND FOR FOR MANY OF YOU THIS
ISN'T EVEN YOUR YOUR YOU KNOW
FIRST VOLUNTEER ASSIGNMENT FOR A
COMMUNITY.
THAT THAT YOU SERVE.
TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU ALSO FOR FOR MISS
TALK AND.
MISTER HALL FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
.
THE THE YOU KNOW THAT THAT KIND
OF.
.
LAMENTING IN DEMANDING.
YOU KNOW PLEASE THAT I'M
HEARING.
ARE REALLY TO ME.
.
GEARED TOWARDS THE APPLICANTS
ON BEHALF OF APPLICANTS.
AND APPLICANTS
AS I SEE OF RIGHT NOW.
THEY MAY NOT SEE IT THIS WAY.
AND SO ANYONE EDUCATE ME BUT
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE.
A SEAT AT THE TABLE IN
NEGOTIATING WITH YOU. AND THEY
HAVE THE APPLICATIONS INTO YOU.
AND I JUST WANNA SAY WHEN WE
PASSED EIGHTY FOURTEEN SEVENTY
ONE.
THE THERE WAS INTENSE BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE REGULATIONS.
WERE WERE CIRCUMSPECT THAT THAT
THERE WAS IT A PROCEEDINGS TO
COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT
WORKED WELL FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA THAT THERE WASN'T A
RUSH.
TO GET MONEY OUT THE DOOR WHILE
WE WERE IN.
I DROUGHT AND PEOPLE REALLY
WANTED TO GET MONEY OUT THE DOOR
WE SAID WE'RE PUTTING
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF PUBLIC
MONEY. ARE INTO SOMETHING WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE IT SPENT WELL.
AND ALSO IT IS FOR PUBLIC
BENEFIT.
I THINK THAT.
WHAT WAS LOST IN A LOT OF THAT?
WAS.
.
I THAT MANY PEOPLE JUST WANTED
THE MONEY TO HELP THEM FIND
THEIR.
PROJECTS.
AND.
IN THE PROCEEDINGS WERE WHERE
THAT PUBLIC BENEFIT RIGHT
REGULATIONS WORD GENERATED.
THAT.
YOU PERHAPS.
.
THE APPLICATIONS THAT YOU SAW
DIDN'T FULLY. ARE.
DIE JASTER COMPREHEND THE FACT
THAT THERE REALLY WAS AN
EXPECTATION OF PUBLIC BENEFIT
THAT THIS MONEY ISN'T RELLY
JUST FOR THEM TO FINANCE THEIR
THEIR PROJECTS PERIOD. AND IT
TAKES A LOT OF EDUCATION FOR
THAT.
BUT ONE OF THE POINTS THAT MR
HALL HAD MADE AND IN HIS WAS
MORE IN IN I THINK THE.
THE THE APPEALS PROCESS ABOUT
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION BUT.
DO YOU.
DO YOU THINK THAT.
PERHAPS IF OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
WERE ENGAGED IN AND YOU KNOW THE
CONSERVATION NGOS BY THINK THAT
THERE WERE OTHER. STAKEHOLDERS
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN ENGAGE
EARLIER ON IN THE DEVELOPMENT.
OF THE REGULATIONS THAT.
MAYBE THAT.
PUBLIC EDUCATION OF BOTH
APPLICANTS BUT ALSO PUBLIC
EXPECTATIONS.
OF WHAT THE COMMISSION WAS
LOOKING FOR OUT COULD HAVE BEEN
MORE CLEARLY COMMUNICATED.
IN I I THINK WE TRIED TO ACHIEVE
THAT I THINK.
.
YOU KNOW AS AS WAS STATED
EARLIER COMMISSIONERS AS
COMMISSIONERS WE TRAVELED ALL
OVER THE STATE IN HOLDING PUBLIC
MEETINGS AND GETTING INPUT. FROM
EVERYONE AND WE ACTUALLY HAD TO
CONSISTENT AND.
REGULARLY PRESENT. UP
PARTICIPATION BY NGOS.
PENA A ETFS INTO SIERRA CLUB.
AQUA HAD REPRESENTATIVES
PRESIDENT PRESENT AT ALL OF THE
MEETINGS.
AND THERE WAS A THERE WAS A LOT
OF.
.
IT WAS A LOT OF DISCUSSION THERE
ARE ALSO A LOT CLEARLY THEY
WERE.
THERE WERE A LOT OF SORT OF
CAMPS ABOUT WHAT THIS MONEY WAS
TO BE USED FOR AND THAT. ARM
THAT REMAINED AS MUCH AS WE
TRIED TO SAY HERE'S HERE'S THE
SIDEBOARDS OF WHAT WE'RE WORKING
WITH.
YOU KNOW.
WE CONTINUE TO HEAR STORIES
ABOUT HOW THIS MONEY FROM
INDIVIDUALS AND GROUPS HOW THIS
MONEY IS SUPPOSE TO BE SPENT.
ALBUM AND WE REALLY TRIED TO
COMMUNICATE THAT LOOK WE'RE
WE'RE HANDED THIS TASK.
OF CREATING A COMPETITIVE
PROCESS THAT HAS TO DO WITH
PUBLIC BENEFITS AND I THINK THAT
IT.
YOU KNOW AS MISTER HALL
MENTIONED IN THAT THIS WAS THIS
IS A UNIQUE BEAST AND THAT SHIFT
IN THINKING.
ARM IS REALLY TOUGH AND I THINK
EVEN FOR FOLKS WHO WORK WITH
WATER UTILITIES A FAIR AMOUNT IT
WAS IT WAS A TOUGH THING TO THE
TIP.
MANAGE AND SO.
.
I I KNOW THAT WHEN WE WERE IN
THE LAST DAYS OF WORKING ON THE
REGULATIONS IN EVERYBODY CAME UP
MY MEMORY IS THAT EVERYBODY YOU
CAME UP TO COMMENT.
PROCESS OF THE TWO YEAR PROCESS
OF CREATING REGULATIONS WE HAD
POSITIVE COMMENTS FROM THE WATER
INDUSTRY WE HAD POSITIVE
COMMENTS FROM. THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AND FROM TRIBES AND FROM.
OF THE WATER UTILITIES AND ONE
THING THAT I REMEMBER HEARING IS
EVERYBODY SAID YOU KNOW THESE
ARE PRETTY GOOD IT'S NOT
EVERYTHING THAT I WANTED.
BUT THESE ARE PRETTY GOOD AND
SO I THINK THAT.
.
I MEAN I THINK THAT STAFF.
AND THE COMMISSION WE TRIED OUR
OUR BEST TO TO CREATE THAT LEVEL
OF UNDERSTANDING. BUT IT.
.
WE HAD CONTINUED HAVE WORK TO DO
MARK YEAH I IT'S YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO.
ASTROLOGY ONE IN THE COMING
ABOUT THAT.
IT JUST COUPLE COMMENTS SAID
THERE ISN'T A LOT OF.
IMPORTANT POINTS AND THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE.
HERE AND I DON'T WANT TO
DIMINISH THE IMPORTANCE OF
GETTING US RIGHT I DON'T WANT
TO.
DIMINISH THE URGENCY OF IT BUT I
THINK.
WE ARE CERTAINLY DEALING WITH.
A SITUATION AS I DESCRIBED
WHERE WE'RE BREAKING NEW GROUND
WE ARE FIGURING THINGS OUT AS WE
GO AND.
IF IF WE WERE. LOOKING TO BUILD
WATER STORAGE PROJECTS THAT MET
SOME SPECIFIC POWER GENERATION
NEED.
THERE'S AB RECIPE AND SOME
ENGINEERING BOOK SOMEWHERE THAT
SOMEONE WOULD LOOK TO AND CLICK
THROUGH AND SAY HERE'S WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO AND SO.
I'D AND I KNOW A NUMBER OF MY
IN JAIL COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED ALONG THE WAY
PROVIDING INPUT.
WE FELT THAT THE STAFF HAS BEEN
QUITE RESPONSIVE TO OUR INPUT
AND THE AND THE COMMISSION'S
MEMBERS SPONSOR BUT THERE ARE
THINGS THAT. I WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE SEEN AND THERE THAT.
THAT OUT IN THE REGULATIONS FOR
INSTANCE THAT I DIDN'T SEE YOU
BUT. I'M SURE THEIR NEIGHBOR
EVERYONE WHO'S BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS AND PROBABLY
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THOSE.
I DO THINK.
YEAH IF I HAD HAD THE CHANCE
TO DO IT I WOULD PROBABLY DO IT
A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY BUT I
PROBABLY ALSO CAN'T.
BE CERTAIN THAT THE WAY I THINK
IT WOULD'VE WORKED ANY BETTER
AND I'M CERTAIN THAT WE WOULD'VE
HAD KINKS TO WORK OUT AND
PROCESS SO.
ARE ALL THAT TO SAY.
I THINK THERE IS.
GOOD REASONS THAT WE'RE
STRUGGLING WITH S..
OVERALL I. ENCOURAGE THE
COMMISSION TO.
THAT IT DO THEIR BEST TO BE
RESPONSIVE IN THE IN THE TIME
FRAME GIVEN AND AND.
AS I INDICATED EARLIER IT
DOESN'T SEEM REASONABLE TO ME
THAT. TO HAVE A LITTLE MORE TIME
ALTHOUGH I KNOW THAT'S PROBABLY
GOES AGAINST.
THE PREFERENCES OF SOME OF THE
OTHER. AYE INTEREST INVOLVED. OF
BUT I DO THINK IT'S A IT'S A
IT'S
A REASONABLE EXPECTATION THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN BLIPS AND.
VERY MUCH ENCOURAGE US ALL TO
TO. TRY TO PROVIDE INPUT TO MOVE
THE PROCESS FORWARD IN A. IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY
I APPRECIATE THAT MR HALL AND
AND I'M VERY COMFORTABLE. WITH
FAR YOU KNOW IRONING OUT ANY
WRINKLES IN THIS PROCESS WE WANT
TO GET THIS RIGHT. ON I I DON'T
THINK THAT THERE'S ANY REASON
TO.
.
YOU GIVE A PASSING GRADE ON
HOMEWORK THAT'S INCOMPLETE OR
DIDN'T TAT FOLLOW THEIR THEIR
THAT REGULATIONS. THAT WERE PUT
OUT AND I WOULD.
WARNED THE COMMISSION NOT TO DO
THAT IF IT YOU KNOW FELT THAT
THERE WAS ANY PRESSURE TO DO IT
I'M ONLY HERE. FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO WE WANT TO SAFEGUARD THIS
MONEY. AND THEN WE WANT TO GET
THE BEST WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT OUR LIMITED RESOURCES CAN
GET US AND MAXIMIZE THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT.
AND THAT'S YOUR CHARGE.
SO I'M GLAD THAT WHAT I'M
HEARING IS YOU TAKE IT VERY
SERIOUSLY.
.
YOU KNOW AND I THINK THAT. I'VE
READ COMMITTING TO WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IS A GOOD THING
MAKING SURE THAT NO THERE ARE NO
SECRETS HERE YOU'RE NOT HIDING
THE BALL TO THE APPLICANTS.
THEY THAT MAY HAVE THE
REGULATIONS
THAT IF THEY HAVE IF YOU KNOW
THEY NEED.
TO GO WIN FOR US SOME AFTER
CLASS TUTORING PERHAPS THE WATER
COMMISSION SHOULD BE ABLE TO
MAKE THEMSELVES AVAILABLE MAYBE
NOT EVEN NECESSARILY. TO ASK
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS IF YOU DON'T
HAVE THEM FOR THE APPLICANTS
BESET THE APPLICANTS CAN GO OVER
THERE APPLICATIONS DIRECTLY.
WITH THE COMMISSION SO THEY CAN
GET SOME CLEAR GUIDANCE
AND IF THAT IN FACT MEANS.
THAT THEY'RE GONNA BE TOLD YOU
KNOW WHAT THIS APPLICATION JUST
IS NOT APPROPRIATE IT DOES NOT
MEET. OUR NEEDS THERE'S GOTTA BE
SOME WAY FOR THEM TO HEAR THAT
AS WELL SO THAT THEY CAN THEN
MOVE ON AND ALSO THAT THE
COMMISSION CAN FOCUS ITS WORK IN
ITS LIMITED RESOURCES ON THE
BETTER APPLICATIONS.
THANK YOU PUT.
SOME MEMBER RUBIO. THANK YOU I'M
I'M THE NEWEST MEMBER.
HERE HOWEVER SINCE YOU GUYS
OPEN UP THE. TEACHING ANALOGIES
I AM A TEACHER AND.
THE WHOLE OTHER CAN OF WORMS
ARE JUST OPEN BY THE WAY.
.
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE LOOK LET
ME BACK UP WHEN I GIVE HOMEWORK.
THIS I GIVE CRITERIA AND I GIVE
THE RUBRIC AS TO WHAT THE
HOMEWORK.
SHOULD LOOK LIKE AND WHEN IT'S
TURNED IN THESE ARE THE
EXPECTATIONS AS OUR RUBRIC.
AVAILABLE TO THE APPLICANTS
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE IF YOU'RE
DOING THIS ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS AS OPPOSED TO. THEIR SOME
RUBRIC THAT I CAN GO LOOK UP AND
THEN I CAN SAY OKAY DOES MY
PROJECT IT HERE BECAUSE IT
SOUNDS LIKE. A LOT OF THIS IS
BEING.
LOOK THAT ON THE. APPLICATION
BASIS AND THEY'RE BEING.
GOV FAIRNESS PART IS LOST
BECAUSE THERE IS NO CLEAR RUBRIC
SO FIRST YOU HAVE A GROUP THAT
IDEA LIKE THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
PRIMARILY SPENT THE TIME ON IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
REGULATIONS WAS IDENTIFYING
THOSE RUBRICS VERY CLEARLY
INCLUDING MODELS THAT NEEDED TO
BE USED HAVING TO DO. WITH CLAY
THIS IS ONE OF THE FIRST TIMES
IT APPLICANTS HAD TO INCLUDE
CLIMATE CHANGE MODELING. IN
THEIR.
AS A PART OF THEIR.
APPLICATION FOR THESE SORTS OF
FUNDS I MEAN THERE WERE THERE
WAS NEW IT WAS JUST ABSOLUTELY
NEW THINGS THAT FOLKS HAD TO DO
WITH REGARDS TO THESE MONEY SO.
THAT IS WHAT THE REGULATIONS ARE
SET UP TO DO IS TO.
CLARIFY RUBRICS INCLUDING
DISCUSSIONS OF WHAT KIND OF
STUDIES YOU COULD USE TO
SUPPORT.
THE UNIT SUPPORT THE NUMBERS
THAT YOU ARE PUTTING IN. IN YOUR
APPLICATION AND SO THEN YOU
CREATED WE WE CREATE THE
APPLICATIONS RIGHT BUT THEY WERE
COMPLAINING ABOUT HOW RIGOROUS
THE APPLICATIONS ARE WHEN WE
CREATED THEM.
I MEAN SO IF YOU SEE WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THAT YOU KNOW WHEN I
GIVE HOMEWORK. YOU KNOW I CAN'T
SAY ALONE THOUGH THE HOMEWORK SO
HARD WHEN I CREATED THE HOME.
FIRED THE HOMEWORK IS SO HARD TO
CORRECT WHEN I'M THE ONE THAT
DEVELOPED THE HOMEWORK AND SO
IT'S CONTRIBUTED A IT SEEMS
CONTRADICTORY TO ME. THAT WE
CREATED THE THE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS BUT NOW WE'RE
COMPLAINING ABOUT HOW RIGOROUS
AND DIFFICULT THAT IS WHEN WE
CREATED. AND SO IF YOU'RE
COMPLAINING ABOUT A CAN YOU
IMAGINE THE APPLICANTS HOW THEY
FEEL BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT TO
REFER BACK TO THE KEY THAT
MISTER BIGELOW WAS TALKING ABOUT
YOU CREATED THE KEY AS WELL. AND
SO IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS IS SO
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU GUYS OR WE
WERE THE ONES THAT CREATED THE
WHOLE PROCESS.
AND SO IS THERE A WAY TO.
TO CLARIFY AND REALLY GIVE.
AGAIN MY PICK MY WHAT I'M
HEARING RIGHT NOW IS THAT.
ONE APPLICATION IS VIEWED ONE
WAY ANOTHER ONE IN A DIFFERENT
WAY.
THAT'S NOT MY.
UNDERSTANDING OR IT'S MORE ABOUT
WHAT I HEARD WAS DIED YOU KNOW
IF THERE'S AYE AS SUCH AND SUCH
EXPERT THEIR VIEWING AND I
THINK.
MISTER HALL MADE THAT COMMENT
DIED.
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE ENGINEERS
LOOKING AT THIS AND YOU CAN LOOK
AT THE DIFFERENT WAYS WELL
THERE'S A RUBRIC IT SHOULD BE
LOOKED AT DIFFERENTLY.
YEAH I AGREE AND I THINK THAT
PART OF WHAT THAT THE ONE HOUR
MEETINGS RICHER YOU CAN LISTEN
TO THEM ONLINE YOU CAN HEAR
THESE CONVERSATIONS AND WHAT
HAPPENS WHICH IS REALLY
INTERESTING IN THOSE MEETINGS.
IS THAT YOU HEAR ENGINEERS FROM
THE APPLICANT SIDE AND FROM THE
STATE SIDE SAYING . WELL
THAT'S WHAT YOU MEAN AND COMING
TO AN UNDERSTANDING WHICH I I
HAVE SOME CONFIDENCE A FAIR
AMOUNT OF CONFIDENCE THAT THE
SUBSEQUENT FILES THAT WERE
SUBMITTED. AND THE UPDATED
APPLICATIONS ARE GONNA BE.
ALL LOT CLOSER TO THE MARK IN
THIS FIRST ONE. AND.
THEN THE FIRST BOMB DEADLINE
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT WAS.
.
I GUESS IN THE IN THE ANALOGY OF
HOMEWORK THIS IS AN ABSOLUTELY
NEW COURSE RIGHT ABSOLUTELY NEW
NEW CHALLENGES AND SO THAT'S WHY
ALSO WE HAD THE APPLICATION
PERIOD OPEN FOR FOUR AND A HALF
MONTHS WITH STAFF EQUIPMENT BUT
THEN THE COMITATO ALSO WAS ABOUT
THE FAIRNESS.
COMPONENT OF THAT IS THAT IF
YOU SIT DOWN AND TALK TO YOU
KNOW ONE APPLICANT FOR EXAMPLE
THEY MIGHT BE PERCEIVED BY
ANOTHER APPLICANT AS UNFAIR WELL
IF YOU HAVE DIRECT GUIDELINES
AND CRITERIA THAT FAIRNESS%
QUESTION SHOULDN'T COME INTO
PLAY. BECAUSE YOU HAVE DIRECT.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN SAY THE REASON
I'M TALKING TELL THIS PERSON IS
BECAUSE OF THIS. YOU KNOW
EXPLAINS THE.
THE SOLES SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THAT PART ABOUT WHY IT WOULD BE
UNFAIR TO TALK TO SOMEBODY. IF
THE INFORMATION IS CLEAR AND
TRANSPARENT THEN THERE SHOULD BE
NO QUESTION AS TO THE FURNACE
BECAUSE IT'S ALL WRITTEN IN THE
APPLICATION ORINDA AND THE
STATUTE WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL
AND I THINK WHAT WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT AND.
MY MY CALLED EXECUTIVE OFFICER
UP AGAIN.
YOU WOULDN'T MIND JOE.
.
WHAT I?
PART OF WHAT HAPPENS PRESS IS
BECAUSE THE OTHER THING THAT
WE'VE BEEN HANDED IS THAT THIS
HAS TO BE A COMPETITIVE PROCESS.
IT'S HOW DO WE KEEP HOW DO WE
KEEP THAT COMPETITIVE. PART OF
THE PROCESS IN PLACE AT THE SAME
TIME THAT WERE ASSISTING
APPLICANTS AND THAT'S BEEN THE
JUNGLE I THINK THAT'S PART THE
JUNGLE FOR US.
AND.
AND THEN THE THE OTHER PRESSURE
OF COURSE IS MEETING THE TIME
AND AGAIN.
BELIEVE ME I I THINK WE ALL
WOULD OF LOVED TO HAVE SEEN
THESE PROJECTS COME THROUGH THE
DOOR WITH ME WITH THEM
REFUNDABLE PROPOSALS.
ON BUT WE ALL ALSO RECOGNIZES
THE FIRST TIME WE'VE DONE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND SO.
WELL AND AND JUST.
I EIGHT AGAIN THIS IS MY LIFE
YOU KNOW KIND OF MY MY.
FIRST TIME GETTING MY FEET WET
IF YOU WELL BUT BUT WHAT I ALSO
HEAR FROM THE OUTSIDE AND THIS
IS JUST STRICTLY FROM THE
OUTSIDE IS THAT YOU MAKING THE
CRITERIA SO DIFFICULT TO.
ACHIEVE BAD AND AND THIS IS JUST
AN ANALOGY BY FOR EXAMPLE I WHEN
I TURN IN AN APPLICATION IF IT'S
MISSING A COMMA YOU DOING IT
BECAUSE IT'S MISSING A COMMA. AS
OPPOSED TO HE LET ME HELP YOU
THERE'S ACCOMMODATES MISSING
HERE SO THAT WE CAN. I LOOK AT
THAT PROJECT OBJECTIVELY IT AS
AS OPPOSED TO LOOKING AT THE
COMMA.
IT SOLD SO AND THIS IS JUST
AGAIN OUTSIDE.
INFORMATION THAT I'M GETTING IS
THAT IT'S.
THEY'RE GIVING DING ON REALLY.
.
COMMENTS FOR EXAMPLE RATHER THAN
THE PROJECT AS AS YOU KNOW THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT OR THE PROJECT AS
A WHOLE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION YOUR COMMENTS AND I
THINK THAT IF YOU. LIST IF YOU
TO LISTEN TO A COUPLE OF THE
INTERVIEWS WITH THE APPLICANTS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT COMMAS IT'S
ABOUT.
THE WOODS YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN YOU
APPLY THAT INFORMATION TO THIS
FORMULA THAT WASN'T THE
INFORMATION YOU NEEDED TO USE
YOU NEED TO USE THIS INFORMATION
OVER HERE. SO WAS NOT.
.
IT'S A I WORK AT A UNIVERSITY
AND I WORKED WITH GRANTS AND SO
I DO KNOW THAT SOMETIMES YOU THE
WRONG FONT IN YOUR APPLICATION
GETS KICKED OUT THIS IS NOT THE
CASE WITH THESE APPLICATIONS IN
FACT. I THINK EVERYBODY IS
REALLY INTERESTED IN SEEING
THESE PROJECTS GO FORWARD
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY. EVERYBODY
WHO'S INVOLVED IN THIS FISH AND
WILDLIFE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD NDW ARE ALL
RECOGNIZE BENEFITS FOR THE
PROGRAMS AND.
PURPOSE FOR WHICH THEY EXIST IN
THE SUCCESS OF THESE PROGRAM OR
AND THEN IF THAT'S THE CASE HOW
MANY APPLICATIONS HAVE YOU
RECEIVED AND HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
REJECTED OR HOW MANY ARE. ARE
NOT UP TO OUR WE RECEIVED TWELVE
ONE APPLICATION DIDN'T EVEN MEET
THE BASIC CRITERIA.
AND SAID THAT ONE DIDN'T
CONTINUE BUT NOW WE HAVE ELEVEN
WHICH ARE GOING FORWARD. AYE
GOING FORWARD.
AS IS OR GOING FORWARD AND
THAT'S WHERE YOU HAVE THE NINETY
THOUSAND CORRECTIONS NINE
THOUSAND NINE THOU DOESN'T FILED
NINE NOW THEY KNOW HOW THEY. YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THOSE JUST SO THE
ELEVEN HAVE NINE THOUSAND FOR
YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING THOUGH I
HAVE STAND THAT HOW CAN YOU HAVE
NINE THOUSAND CORRECTIONS ON
TWELVE ARE AROUND ELEVEN
APPLICATIONS IF THEY CUT IT
JUST.
IT DOESN'T.
AND I WILL I THINK WE WE GET THE
POINT WHAT AND I'D LIKE TO SAY
THAT THE PROBLEMS WERE ALL
DIFFERENT IT WASN'T LIKE EVERY
APPLICATION AT THE SAME.
THAT THE SAME DISCONNECT IT WAS
IT WAS.
IT WAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT ON
ISSUES AND AND BELIEVE ME I
REALLY DO FEEL LIKE EVERYBODY IS
INVOLVED IN THIS PROCESS WANTS
IS TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE WANT
MONEY TO GO OUT THE DOOR AND WE
WANT TO GET OUT. AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE AND I MIGHT ADD WITH
CONFIDENCE
AND THAT'S I THINK THE THING
THAT WE'RE ALL WORKING TOWARDS
THE CONFIDENCE.
THAT THE CONFIDENCE FOR THE
APPLICATION RIGHT IN AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU'RE WORKING
HARD AGAIN I THINK WHERE MY. MY
HEAD THAT KEEPS GOING BACK TO
IS.
I'M.
IF WE CREATED THE PROCESS SHOULD
BE THAT COMPLICATED TO BE ABLE
TO TO CHECK THE HOMEWORK.
BECAUSE IF WE CREATED THAN WE
KNOW WHAT THE CRITERIA SHOULD BE
WHEN YOU GO TO A CLASS YOU GET
ON.
.
RIGHT AWAY YOU GET THE
INFORMATION FROM THE PROFESSOR
AS WHAT THE REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR
THAT CLASS IN EIGHT SOMEHOW IT
JUST DOESN'T FEEL LIKE THAT'S
WHAT THE CASE HERE. AND SO WE
CAN GO ROUND AND ROUND AND
ROUND.
BUT THE POINT IS THAT IT
DOESN'T SEEM THAT THE
APPLICATION PROCESS. IS IS.
ADEQUATE ENOUGH TO FOR US TO
KEEP
UP YOU KNOW GOING BACK TO TO THE
SAME THING IF IT WAS WE WOULDN'T
HAVE NINE THOUSAND. ARE
CORRECTIONS I GUESS AND I PLEASE
YEAH I UNDERSTAND THAT IT JUST
MIGHT JUST I ALSO SAY THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THOSE REGULATIONS
WAS COLLABORATIVE.
YOU KNOW REALLY WERE EVERYTHING
THAT WE'VE DONE HAS BEEN IN THE
PUBLIC. IN THE PUBLIC ARENA.
EVERYBODY PARTICIPATED AND IT
HAS BEEN IT HAS BEEN A VERY OPEN
PROCESS BUT I UNDERSTAND THAT
I'M ABOUT THE PROCESS IS OPEN
BUTWE HERE WE ARE. I MEAN AND
SO I REALLY DIDN'T AND SO BY TWO
THAT I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
GIVING ME THAT HE NEEDED
ELSEWHERE QUESTIONS I WILL BE
ASKING MORE QUESTIONS BUT THE
ABSOLUTELY SIGN ME UP ON THAT
THAT LETTER BECAUSE THIS IS. IT.
AS A AS A VOTER.
WHEN YOU VOTE FOR SOMETHING AND
IT'S TAKING FOUR YEARS FOR A TO
COME TO FRUITION AND IT'S A KIND
OF I'M. KIND OF.
.
LEAVES ME SHELLSHOCKED ABOUT
VOTE FOR SOMETHING ELSE IF IT'S
NOT IF WHAT I INTENDED.
I.
WHEN I VOTED WAS TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD AND WE'VE BEEN DOING
THIS FOR FOUR YEARS.
I'M NOT ENCOURAGED TO VOTE ON
ANYTHING ELSE BECAUSE THEN THEN
THAT'S WHERE WE GET THE
REPUTATION OF ALL THE BURKE
BUREAUCRACY AND. YOU KNOW YOU
YOU FILL IN THE BLANKS AND IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO SUPPORT
OTHER.
BONDS IF THIS IS WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN TO EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THEM.
TAKE SOME MEMBER WE HAVE DOCTOR
BUT I'M BLUFF FOLLOWED BY.
SOME MEMBERSHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'M GOING TO ASK TWO QUESTIONS
TODAY I'M GONNA START WITH MISS
TALK AND THEN MOVE ON TO
CHAIRMAN CAN TARA.
FIRST YOU KNOW BACK IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN I WAS AN EMERGENCY ROOM
DOCTOR AND WORKING ON THE FRONT
LINES IN AN AREA THAT. I'M QUITE
PROUD OF OUR AGRICULTURAL ROOTS.
AND ITS NOT LOST ON ME THAT MANY
OF THE PLAYERS WHO YOU MENTIONED
BEFORE THAT WE WERE NOT
INCLUDING. THOSE WHO ACTUALLY
WORKED IN THE FIELDS AND THOSE
WHO ACTUALLY HAVE A VOICE.
AND I BELIEVE IT'S MY OBLIGATION
TO
COULD BECAUSE YOU WORK QUITE
ADAMANT ABOUT.
BRAG ABOUT YOUR PICTURE OF THE
SIGNING WITH THE GOVERNOR AND I
HAVE FOUND IN THIS BUILDING THAT
PEOPLE ARE. QUICK TO TAKE
PICTURES AND RIBBON CUTTINGS BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY THE IMPLEMENTATION
AND APPLICATIONS OF THE LAWS
THAT ARE DULY IMPORTANT.
SO I WANT TO GET AN
UNDERSTANDING FROM YOU
EXPLICITLY IF I CAN.
WHAT WAS THE INTENT OF SPEAKING
ABOUT CONVEYANCE?
IS THERE A CHANGE IN WHAT WAS
VOTED ON IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
WITH.
ANY NECESSARY IMPROVEMENTS THAT
MAY COME.
FORWARD FROM HERE ARE WE
CONSIDERING CONVEYANCE IN OUR
CURRENT APPLICATIONS AND WHAT
ROLE DOES THAT PLAY INTO. WHO IS
SELECTED?
SECOND QUESTION IS GOING TO BE
FOR YOU CHAIRMAN CAN TEAR.
AND I. REALLY. ENJOYED MUCH OF
WHAT YOU SAID AND.
I'M YOU KNOW I'VE I HAVE NOT
HEARD THAT QUOTE BEFORE IN GOD
WE TRUST AND FOR EVERYONE ELSE
WE NEED DATA. I'VE HEARD IT
DESCRIBED THAT WATER IS A MATTER
OF FAITH.
I COME FROM THE VALLEY AND FOR
US I'D ACTUALLY LIKE MARK
TWAIN'S QUOTE THERE LIES DAMNED
LIES AND STATISTICS.
YOU HAVE SAID THAT THERE IS A
DISCONNECT BETWEEN DEFINITIONS
AND OUTCOMES YOU'VE SAID THAT.
WERE APPLYING THE STANDARDS AS
THEY ARE UNDERSTOOD.
BUT AS WE ARE CARVING A NEW PATH
FORWARD.
HOW? CAN WE HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THIS PROCESS AS IT'S CURRENTLY
BEING. PUT FORWARD IF THIS WAS A
NEW COURSE.
AND WE'RE HAVING NEW CHALLENGES
SHOULD WE CONTINUE THIS COURSE.
EVERYONE FAILED THE FIRST TEST.
IS THAT ON THE APPLICANTS
OR ON THE PERSON GIVING THE
TEST.
SO HOW CAN WE HAVE CONFIDENCE
MOVING FORWARD THAT WERE
PERFORMING TO THE UP MOST OF OUR
ABILITIES.
SO TO THE FIRST QUESTION AND I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION. ON THE
CAN ON CONVEYANCE AND I BELIEVE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CONVEYANCE
IN THE VALLEY NOT.
NOW I'M NOT TALKING ACROSS THE
DELTA SO OKAY.
I'M CONCERNED THAT WE MAY
SELECT SITES
THAT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO POTENTIALS FOR
CONVEYANCE WITHOUT JUDGING WHAT
WAS PUT IN FRONT OF THE VOTERS
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN. THAT WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE DECISIONS
ARE REFLECTIVE OF ONE VOTERS
INITIALLY VOTED ON IT AND NOT
WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
SO YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CONVEYANCE IN THE DELTA OKAY. ON
WHICH IS A DIFFERENT QUESTION I
THINK I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
WAS.
VERY CAREFUL BOTH ON
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND NINE BUT I.
WAS PART OF THE DISCUSSIONS IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND THEY WERE
VERY CLEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FUNDING WASN'T. GOING FOR FOR
EXAMPLE THE TUNNELS PROJECT
AND AND THAT WAS AN EXPLICIT
PART OF THE DISCUSSIONS AND I
BELIEVE THE LANGUAGE. THAT WAS
RESOLVED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
SO CAN WE SAY THAN THAT.
ANY POTENTIALS FOR WATER FIX OUR
NOT BEING CONSIDERED AND.
APPLICATIONS ARE WE EXPLICITLY
EXCLUDING.
THAT AS A DECISION FACTOR.
IS IT BASED ON WHAT WAS IN
FRONT OF US IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
OR IS THIS A MOVING TARGET.
I I DEFER TO THE COMMISSION ON
THAT IT WAS BASED ON WHAT WAS IN
THE LANGUAGE OF THE LEGISLATION
TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT'S THE ONLY
THING THAT WE CAN FOLLOW WE
DON'T HAVE NEW TARGETS OR IDEAS.
THAT ARE BEING PRETTY.
THEY SHOULD.
MAYWEATHER CRAFTERS OF ALL THIS.
.
GOOD OR BAD THAT THE PROJECTS
WERE LIMITED TO ONLY THE.
PROJECTS OF RECORD A DECISION.
FOR THE CHAPTER A CONSIDERATION
SO WHATEVER WAS IN THE RECORD.
DECISION IS WHAT PROJECTS.
WE'RE ABLE BE STUDIED AND
UTILIZED AND RECOGNIZED.
VOTED FOR YOUR ANSWER.
SO IT IT MAY HAVE BEEN EXPANDED
SINCE THEN BUT TECHNICALLY THEY
SHOULDN'T BE THERE.
A SEPARATE DISCUSSION.
THAT'S NOT BEING DISCUSSED HERE
TODAY. AND. THE REASON WHY I
BRING IT UP AS I KNOW THIS IS A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS AND WHILE I
MIGHT NOT AGREE WITH MY VICE
CHAIR ON EXACTLY WHERE THE
STORAGE PROJECTS ARE.
I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE SAID THAT
TWO THIRDS OF OUR WATER RESTORED
NORTH OF THE DELTA.
AND IF WE LACK CONVEYANCE NOW.
HOW ARE WE CONSIDERING FUTURE
PROJECTS NORTH OF THE DELTA
SHOULDN'T WE LOOK AT AS A STATE
WHAT'S NECESSARY? FOR OUR
CURRENT
STATE OF CONVEYANCE AS WORD
DECIDING MAJOR PROJECTS LIKE
THIS
SO THAT WAS REALLY MY INTENT OF
THAT FIRST QUESTION. BUT I'D
REALLY LIKE TO GET A SENSE OF I
CAN HOW DO WE HAVE CONFIDENCE.
HOW DO WE LOOK AT THIS PATH
FORWARD AS BEING ONE THAT NEEDS
TO BE REPLICATED?
THAT IS WORTHY OF US WHEN WE
HAVE AS MANY QUESTIONS AS WE'RE
SEEING RIGHT NOW ABOUT THE
PROCESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
.
WHERE MID PROCESS RIGHT NOW SO
WE HAVE NOT WE HAVE NOT REACHED
THE POINT OF?
OF DECISION MAKING HERE
AND I THINK WE ARE ALL HOPING
FOR WERE REALLY SIMILAR OUTCOMES
I MEAN I THINK THAT I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE TO OUTCOMES IT.
THAT HOME WE ARE ALL PLEASED
WITH IN TERMS OF THE PROCESS BUT
WHERE MID PROCESS RIGHT NOW IS
ONE THING THEY DON'T SAY. THE
OTHER THING THAT YOU MENTIONED
IS ARM.
IN THE MEETINGS THAT WE HELD
AROUND THE STATE WE ABSOLUTELY
INCLUDED THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES AND THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND WE TOOK MEETINGS TO FRESNO.
AND TO.
OTHER AREAS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY
UP TO SACRAMENTO TO CHICO.
AND WE HAD A LOT OF
REPRESENTATION IT AT THE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS FROM THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY.
IN FACT THAT WAS I KNOW THAT
THERE WAS A FAIR AMOUNT OF
TESTIMONY FROM LONG TIME
FAMILIES.
FROM CALIFORNIA WHO'VE BEEN.
BUT WE'RE AGRICULTURE IS THEIR
HERITAGE.
ON THE COMMISSION ITSELF JOE
DEL BOSQUE WOULD OF OUR MEMBERS
IS A IS MAJOR RANCHER FROM THAT
LOS BANOS AREA. WE ALSO HAVE A
COMMISSION MEMBER.
MUDDY AT ADAM WHO IS FROM BY
CELLULAR WORKS WITH SELF HELP
ENTERPRISES AND IS VERY FAMILIAR
WITH COMMUNITY ISSUES.
THEY'RE SO THAT HAS BEEN THAT'S
ACTUALLY BEEN ALWAYS ON THE
TABLE IN THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE SUCCESS.
OF THESE PROGRAMS THE IMPORTANCE
OF THEM AND HOW TO BE.
AUTUMN.
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE EVALUATE THEM
I.
.
THE THE PROCESS THAT WE CAME UP
WITH WAS A COLLABORATIVE ONE SO
WE TOO WERE SURPRISED.
YOU KNOW IT WAS NOT A GAME OF
US TRYING TO YOU KNOW OUT WITH
ANYBODY AND AND DISADVANTAGED AN
APPLICATION OR ADVENT GIVEN OUT
ADVANTAGE WAS ANY CERTAIN TYPE
OF APPLICATION.
I'M WILL BELIEVE ME WE ALL WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD SAN OKAY LET'S
GET ON WITH THIS
SO. ARM
I WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS A PART
OF OUR PROCESS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
INVALUABLE TO BE HERE WITH ALL
OF YOU AND HEARING FROM YOU.
BUT I I CAN SAY THAT THEY THE
STAFF OF THE COMMISSION. AND THE
PROFESSIONALS FROM WITHIN THESE
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS WE ARE ALL
LOOKING FORWARD.
TO.
ACTIONS THAT TAKE US ON THE
SMART PATHWAY FORWARD FOR WATER
IN CALIFORNIA.
LET ME JUST THEN ADD MY TWO
CENTS IF I CAN.
.
NO WE HEARD ABOUT THE NECESSITY
FOR THE SYNERGISTIC BENEFITS OF
THE PROJECTS AND.
YOU KNOW IT. IT'S.
COM.
IT'S SAD IN A WAY THAT I WAS NOT
HERE TO HELP AT A VOICE TO THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE BEING IMPACTED BY
THE DECISIONS THAT ARE HERE
RIGHT NOW.
WORKING IN AN ER I SAW PEOPLE'S
LIVES THAT WERE SHORTENED
BECAUSE OF THIS DROUGHT.
AND I AM DOWN.
A BIT DISTURBED TO SAY THAT.
WE'RE NOT CONSIDERING THEIR
VOICES
AND REALLY LISTENING TO WEAR
PROJECTS NEED TO HAVE STORAGE IN
TERMS OF BENEFITING.
THOSE WITHIN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE DISADVANTAGES.
NOT EVERYONE HAS A VOICE OR CAN
COME OUT OF THE SHADOWS.
BUT OUR COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE
HEARD AS WELL AND I HOPE WHEN
YOU'RE MAKING THESE DECISIONS
THAT YOU TRULY DO. CONSIDER ALL
OF CALIFORNIANS INSTEAD OF.
.
AND.
SIMPLY.
BUT BEFORE US RIGHT NOW SOME.
WITH THAT I. LOOK FORWARD TO THE
END OF THIS COURSE.
BUT WE AS THE LEGISLATURE.
PROBABLY SERVE IN THE CAPACITY
OF DETERMINING IF WE RENEW YOUR
COURSE FOREST FUTURE ONES. AND
WOOD.
ENCOURAGE YOU TO.
.
FOLLOWED THE PROCESS AND ALLOW
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THE. END GOAL
MEETS WHAT IS A BEST USE FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WE HAVE.
.
SO MEMBERSHIP. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING UP KNOWN.
AND LEARN A LOT FROM YOUR
PRESENTATION AND AND THINK TO
COMMISSIONER FOR YOUR. OF HARD
WORK AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO TO
MAKE IT RIGHT.
I HAVE TO AGREE WITH THE.
TELL OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
AND WHEN WHEN I HEAR THAT YOU
WERE SMALL NINE THOUSAND
INCLUDING USE A PILE. OF HOW TO
FILL UP THAT APPLICATION I
FILLED I WAS.
BUT THE.
THAT DEFINITELY SOMETHING DAD.
.
DID THE DEPARTMENT CAN.
THEN I MAKE SOME IMPROVEMENT ON.
SHE SHOULDN'T BE DOT COM
COMPUTING I KNOW IT IS A VERY
COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT. ISSUE BUT
AGAIN YOU KNOW AGES REFILE BALL
WHEN I LEARNED THERE WITH THAT
DAMN MANY OF QUESTIONS.
IT AND I'M A.
QUESTION IT IT JUST SCHEDULE
HERE.
IT'S A PRETTY FIRM OR WOULD JUST
A MATTER.
CONTAGION.
.
NO I SCHEDULE.
THE BASIC IT WAS BASICALLY
OUTLINED IN THE STATUTE
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN
FOLLOWING IS THAT THE VARIOUS
STEPS THAT WE HAD TO TAKE AND WE
WERE TRYING TO BE.
BUT YOU KNOW AS EFFICIENT WITH
THAT TIME IS POSSIBLE OR YOU
KNOW AN EMPTY BY EFFICIENCY I
MEAN DO A GOOD JOB.
WITH THE CHAT WITH THE CHARGE
IN IN FACT IT WAS LAID OUT THAT.
WE COULDN'T BE.
.
THAT WE WERE GONNA HAVE A TWO
YEAR PROCESS TO DEVELOP THE
RAKES IT SAW IT WAS ALL LAID OUT
AND STUFF YOU KNOW I'M JUST
UNDER. NO ME REPHRASE THE
QUESTION OF THE PIG PIECE OF
PAPER I GOT HERE.
IN THE END OF THE HOUSE ON DATE
ON THAT.
ARE WE GOING TO HOLD FIRM ON
THOSE STATE.
THAT'S OUR INTENTION.
INCREMENTED IS OUR INTENTION AND
WE AND.
SO WHERE DO.
WERE NOT SURE DAD CHO WOO WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO REALLY HOLD
FIRM ON THIS DATE.
AND I BELIEVE WE ARE GOING.
OKAY YEAH I'M TAKING A LOOK AT
WHICH.
YEAH THAT'S BEEN THE PUBLIC
SCHEDULE OF THE COMMISSION.
FOR THE DECISION MAKING STEPS
AS WE'VE BEEN GOING FORWARD ON
THIS OKAY HAVE WE EVER MOVE TO
THE DATE BEFORE.
DURING THE DAILY NEWS CHECKED IT
TWO YEARS PROCESS.
WELL WE DID.
.
WE DID OPEN IT UP FOR THE A AT
FOR THE APPEALS FROM APPLICANTS.
AND SO THAT WAS A CHANGE THAT
WE MADE AND AGAIN AS A
COMMISSION AND AS A BODY WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE.
YOU KNOW THE PHASES THAT WE'RE
GOING THROUGH AND SPEAKING ABOUT
IT IN THE PUBLIC FORUM IN TERMS
OF WHAT OUR NEXT STEPS AND
SOLUTIONS ARE TO.
THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WE
ENCOUNTER MAHOGANY AGAINST MY
OF.
A MESSAGES SO I'M HOPING THAT WE
CAN NO ONE WOULD HAVE A SCHEDULE
KNOWING HOW CHALLENGE.
THE DIFFICULT HOW DIFFICULT IT
THE TASK MAY BE. I'M HOPING THAT
WE CAN STICK WITH THE GOOD GOOD
GOOD. A APRENDER SCHEDULE.
AND A AND YOU KNOW THAT'S THEM
REFLECTION OVER WHEN YOU. MAKE
THE SCHEDULE YOU HAVE ALSO TAKEN
INTO THE CONSIDERATION OF HOW
DIFFICULT A TASK
IS HOW CHALLENGED THE TASK IS.
CLOSE SO AND GOOD BUT I THINK
THAT THAT'S REALLY MY ASK WHY WE
DO THE TRYING YOU KNOW WE WOULD
PUT OUR. A BASKET.
ALL OF THE ASSN WENT AND AND
IMPALA SCHEDULE LESS HOME WANT
TO AND I THINK THAT'S IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT. WILL HELP US TO
GAIN SOME PUBLIC TRUSTEES SO
KEEP MOVING THE SCHEDULE.
AT AND TALK I.
QUICK QUESTION DO YOU KNOW FROM
MICE THE STAFF. WHO OF FOR A A
MISS TALK
IN THE TO OF PRECISE TO MEET HIM
BEFORE APRIL TWENTIETH?
WHAT AUDIT MEETINGS HAVE YOU
REQUESTED?
TO ACQUIT USE HAS BEEN TALKING
WITH THE COMMISSION STAFF ABOUT
OF BASICALLY THREE MEETINGS.
AND ON ONE OF THEM WOULD BE A
MEETING IN EARLY APRIL.
TO.
TALK ABOUT THE.
APPEALS THAT HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED
CLARIFICATIONS ON THOSE APPEALS
WITH ALL THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED.
AND THEN WERE SUGGESTING ANOTHER
MEETING IN EARLY MAY.
IN THIS WULD BE ON THE OTHER
COMPONENT SCORE ISSUES THERE'S
INTO THE PUBLIC BENEFIT RATIO IS
A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF THIS
BUT THERE ARE OTHER COMPONENTS
SCORES. AND THIS WOULD BE. YOU
KNOW THE APPLICANTS HAVE
PROVIDED THEIR APPLICATIONS THE
REVIEWERS ARE REVIEWING THAT
RELATIVE TO THE OTHER COMPONENTS
BUT BEING ABLE TO FOR A REVIEWER
AT STATE WATER BOARD FOR EXAMPLE
TO ASK A QUESTION. RELATIVE TO
THOSE OTHER COMPONENT SCORES WE
THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT.
SO THAT WOULD BE.
A SECOND MEETING WERE
SUGGESTING. ON.
YOU KNOW PRIOR TO MAY TWENTY
FIFTH FOR THAT.
AND THEN OF THE THIRD MEETING
WERE SUGGESTING IS DURING THE
WEEK OF ON JUNE FOURTH TO EIGHTH
HAVE A MEETING TO. ON THE JOB
DEBRIEF ON THE RETURN ON
INVESTMENT SCORES.
AND ON TO INFORM.
A PROCESS BECAUSE THE COMMISSION
BE HAVING A MEETING JUNE TWENTY
SEVENTH TWO TWENTY NINTH SO
THERE'S THREE PARTS WE HAVE
SHARED THIS WITH THE COMMISSION
STAFF.
WE. DEFINITELY RECOGNIZE IS A
COMPETITIVE PROCESS
IN THE PROCESS NEEDS TO BE FAIR
BUT WE THINK THESE MEETINGS CAN
BE HELD IN A TRANSPARENT WAY AS
THE COMMISSION DID IN FEBRUARY
WHICH WE REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
AND THAT CAN HELP THESE KINDS
OF.
INTERACTIONS CAN REALLY HELP
THE PROCESS.
WHERE DOES MEETING OF REQUIRE
SKINNER GRANTED BY THE
COMMISSIONER ARE WAS TO?
HE TALKS.
SO WE WE SUBMITTED THEM TO THE
STAFF AND I BELIEVE THERE'S
GOING TO BE A DISCUSSION AT THE
MEETING TOMORROW. ABOUT THESE
AND THE PUBLIC MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WILL BE ABLE TO COMMENT
ON THAT AS WELL MITCHELL LIKE A
REASONABLE REQUEST AND HOPING
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO.
BY HELP THOSE MEETING.
INCOME PLACE AND WE THINK A
GOOD PROCESS ON THIS HELPS
EVERYONE INVOLVED IN THE EARLY.
DEFINITE INDUCES SOUNDED BY
POVERTY ON A DIFFERENT.
AS. A HEARING YOU KNOW I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO KNOW. HOW WE CALL
IT A OUR THE PROGRESS OF HOW WE
SPENT THE OF THE REST OF THE
SEVEN POINT FIVE? BILLION
DOLLARS IN OH ON THIS CHART YOU
HAVE THE BOND THAT A FULL POINT
A BILLION DOLLARS IS ON THE
WEBSITE OR SOME INFORMATION THAT
I CAN.
I CAN THAT I RECEIVED IT THE
ONLY THING THAT WE'RE. FOCUSED
ON IS THE COMMISSION IS THE TWO
POINT SEVEN THAT VOTED TO HAVE
EVEN TOUCH YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
THE BILL AS ARE OTHER AGENCIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE MANAGING
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THOSE FUNDS
OKAY. SO. WE CAN FOLLOW UP AND
ARE IGNORED DISCOURAGE ABAJO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK THANK YOU SOME MEMBER THE.
NO OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
HERE.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO BACK TO THE
PANELISTS AND MAY BE.
IT KIND OF CLOSING COMMENTS
PERHAPS THE MINUTE CLOSING
COMMENTS EACH ONE OF YOU. AS IT
RELATES TO SOME OF THINGS A
BEAVER TODAY IN.
HOPEFULLY SOME OF THE TAKE AWAYS
DATA YOU KNOW WE WILL FOCUS ON.
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WE WILL
BE DRAFTING A LETTER. THAT THAT
MAY I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF
THE COMMISSION.
LET ALL THREE OF THOSE MEETINGS
HAVE BEEN SUGGESTED AND OPEN
THAT THE COMMISSION WILL.
SERIOUSLY CONSIDER. ADDING TO
THAT LEVEL OF. A TRANSPARENCY
INCLUSIVENESS THAT THAT ALREADY
HAS TAKEN PLACE BUT. IN THE
INTERESTS OF MAKING SURE
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS.
I WHAT WAS DRIVING.
TO ACCOMPLISH HERE.
JUST ONCE MORE.
RIGHT SO WHAT MR GIVE THAT ALL
START WITH YOU AND WE'LL GO
AROUND TO ALL OF THE PANELISTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH ALL OF
YOU AND I THINK I CAN SAY THAT
THE COMMISSION IS ABSOLUTELY HAS
BEEN AND IS ABSOLUTELY FOCUSED.
ON THE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS PROGRAM.
AS I'VE SAID EVERYTHING THAT
WE'VE DONE IS TRANSPARENT. I
IT'S BEEN A TRANSPARENT PROCESS
WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN EX PARTE
POLICY WHERE COMMISSIONERS ARE
NOT TALKING WITH ANYONE OUTSIDE
OF PUBLIC MEETINGS BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT. ANY CONFUSION THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME HAND SHAKE
DEAL OR ANYTHING SO WERE ALL.
VERY FOCUSED ON THAT AND.
AND I DO THINK THAT.
THIS LEGISLATION REPRESENTS ONE
OF THE MANY STEPS THAT WE HAVE
TO TAKE GOING FORWARD IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO. AROUND WATER THE
COMMISSION RECOGNIZES THAT AND
AGAIN I THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS BE TRUE TO THE
LANGUAGE IN THE LEGISLATION OUR
GUIDANCE AND DO REALLY. TO DO
THE BEST JOB POSSIBLE AND I
ACTUALLY WANT TO COMMEND THE
STAFF. OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
COMMISSION WHO HAS JUST WORKED
INCREDIBLY HARD ON PULLING
TOGETHER.
THE SUPPORT IN THE INFORMATION
TO MAKE.
OUR EFFORTS SUCCESSFUL AND I
REALLY DO LOOK FORWARD TO.
ACCESS COME JULY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH INDEED TO.
BUT I THOUGHT IT I DON'T HAVE
MUCH TO ADD I JUST WANNA. THANK
THANK THINK Q. THIS IS OBVIOUSLY
ON
THE PROP ONE STORAGE MONEY TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION HUGE.
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY FUTURE AND FOR HOME
IMPROVING ECOSYSTEMS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT THE
COMMISSION STONE ALL THE PROCESS
TO DATE.
STAFF WORKING ON THE WORK OF THE
OTHER AGENCIES THIS IS A HUGE
AMOUNT OF WORK. ON FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
AND THEN FINALLY WE AS YOU'VE
HEARD WERE RECOMMENDING THREE
FUTURE INTERACTIONS WE THINK
THAT CAN BE TRANSPARENT AND IT
CAN HELP THIS PROCESS BE
SUCCESSFUL. THINKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN FOR
YOUR ATTENTION OF THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF SOME REALLY INTERESTING
AND HELPFUL ARE QUESTIONS I
THINK TODAY.
I JUST OUR I THINK TO ITERATE
REITERATE SOME OF THE POINTS I
MADE EARLIER AND RESPONDING SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE SOME REAL
CONTENT CHALLENGES THAT.
THE WATER COMMISSION STAFF OF
HAD TO DEAL WITH THINGS LIKE HOW
DO YOU COMPARE WHICH IS BETTER
TO HAVE SOME FLOW. IN THE SPRING
FOR THIS SPECIES VERSES WATER IN
THE GROUND FOR THIS RIPARIAN
HABITAT.
REAL CHALLENGING THINGS THAT.
TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO'S
COMMENTS UP.
IT IS CHALLENGING TO DEFINE A
REAL CLEAR RUBRIC ON THAT AND SO
IDEA I THINK IT'S NECESSARILY
ARE UNABLE TO PROCESS.
AND.
THAT SAID I VERY MUCH.
ENCOURAGE THE.
THE COMMISSION TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE A.
OF A TRANSPARENT PROCESS I
THINK.
HOPE THEY WILL CONSIDER YOUR
POINTS TODAY AS AS THEY MOVE FOR
AND MAKE THESE DECISIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
WOULD BLOW OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENTS AT THIS TIME
AND.
THOSE OF YOU WHO.
WILL BE SPEAKING IF YOU COULD
USE A STATE YOUR NAME.
YOUR AFFILIATION AND DUCK PLEASE
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO.
A MINUTE OR SO THANK YOU.
AT GOOD AFTERNOON HOW JONES THE
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA WE'VE
BEEN WATCHING THIS PROCESS AND I
THINK I'VE BEEN ATTENDING
MEETINGS AT THE WATER COMMISSION
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS NOW
WORKING THROUGH THE REGULATIONS
AND NOW WORKING UP THROUGH THE
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR
APPLICANTS.
I'M AND IT IS VERY DIFFICULT BOB
CALIFORNIA'S WATER IS
NOTORIOUSLY VOLATILE FROM YEAR
TO YEAR AND ON TOP OF THAT WE
HAVE TO PLAN. FOR THE FUTURE
LOOKING AT HYDROLOGY AS IT
CHANGES AND AS WE'VE SEEN IT
CHANGE WITH CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
HOW DO WE DO WITH THE MELTING
SNOWPACK. HAD WE DON'T PROJECTS
THAT MAYBE CAN MEET PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS IF WE WERE TO LOOK AT
THEM THIS YEAR BUT. MAYBE NOT IN
TWENTY THIRTY YEARS.
SO IT IS VERY NEW PROGRAM THAT
THE COMMISSION HAS BEEN
UNDERTAKING AND THEY ARE.
BEING REALLY INNOVATIVE AYE IN
ITS APPROACH AND I THINK THAT
DOES EXPLAIN A LOT OF SOME OF
THE HIT UPSET ABOUT HAPPENING.
ITS ENTIRELY NEW.
AND IT'S IT'S FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE HADN'T SEEN IT BEFORE OB
I THINK.
AYE AYE I AGREE THAT.
AFTER LISTENING INTO THOSE OF
THOSE MEETINGS THAT WERE
HAPPENING IN FEBRUARY THAT THE
PROCESS WILL NOT IMPROVE OVER
THE INITIAL PUBLIC BENEFIT. ROB
RATIOS ARE AND SO WE ARE YOU
KNOW CONCERNED ABOUT. ADDING
EXTRA MEETINGS IF
YOU KNOW WHAT.
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA BE CONCERNED
ABOUT AT HOWARD THERE'S GOING TO
HELP IN THE PROCESS MAKING SURE
THAT THEY ARE DOING.
APPROPRIATE THINGS.
AND NOT JUST BY HAVING STATE
AGENCIES PROVIDING.
UNNECESSARY.
ATTENTION TO PROJECTS OR GIVING
THEM EXTRA HELP THAT THAT
OTHERWISE WOULDN'T BE FAIR I'M
WE THINK THE STATE AGENCIES DO
HAVE A JOB TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE BENEFITS MATERIALIZE THAT
TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE SPENT
EFFECTIVELY.
AND AND AND FOR BENEFITS THAT
BUT A CREW AND ACTUALLY HAPPENED
AND ARE JUST ON PAPER.
.
THAT BEING SAID I DID MONEY.
JUST MENTION THAT. I AND SECOND
THE ASK OF MR HALL THAT. WHEN
THE REVIEWERS COME OUT WITH
THEIR SCORES ON APRIL TWENTIETH
THERE'S ABOUT TEN DAYS BETWEEN
THAT AND THE FIRST MEETING FROM
THE COMMISSION. ARE THAT
INCLUDES A WEEKEND SO FROM
NUMBERS THE PUBLIC IT'S GOING TO
BE KIND OF HARD FOR US TO BE
ABLE TO GET OUR COMMENTS AND ON
TIME ON HOW THOSE. SCORES HAVE
CHANGED OVER TIME AND I THINK IF
IF THAT IS POSSIBLE TO MOVE THEM
THAT THE COMMISSION COME OF THE
MEETING BACK IN MAY. IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL FOR THE PUBLIC TO HAVE
BETTER OPPORTUNITIES TO COMMENT
MORE EFFECTIVELY DURING THAT
MEETING. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO.
SPEAK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
GARY BOB OF THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR
AT THE BANDS TO TO.
.
NO I THINK THAT ONE THING THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER IS THAT
THERE'S A HISTORY OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
UP CONSTRUCTING WATER PROJECTS
THAT WERE JUSTIFIED ON THE BASIS
OF OF VERY GREAT BENEFITS THAT.
THAT WERE SUPPOSED TO CREW WHICH
DID NOT OCCUR.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY ARE BIG
WATER PROJECTS WERE IN LARGE
PART JUSTIFIED A BY THE INTENT
TO REDUCE A GROUNDWATER
OVERDRAFT. HOW THAT WORKED OUT?
?
A PREVIOUS BONTA MONEY HAS BEEN
DIRECTED IN LIKE IN PROP
THIRTEEN PROP FIFTY TOWARD
PUBLIC PROJECTS OVERSEAS BUT
TOWARD PROJECTS WERE SUPPOSED TO
RECEIVE PUBLIC ABOUT MONEY FOR
FOR BENEFITS BUT WE NEVER REALLY
DEFINE WHAT THOSE BENEFITS
WHERE.
THERE'S SOME QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER WE REALLY GOT ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS WERE TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING DIFFERENT HERE A AND
THAT MEANS IT'S A IT'S A BIGGER
LEFT AND THE COMMISSION TO ITS
CREDIT IS ACTUALLY DEFINED. WHAT
PUBLIC BENEFIT MEANS IT'S A IT'S
A IT'S A TOUGH JOB AND WORKING
THROUGH THE DETAILS OF IS
CHALLENGING BUT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING THAT'S NEVER BEEN
DONE BEFORE? AND PREVENT OF THE.
WASTE OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
PROJECTS THAT A LOVE FOR PUBLIC
BENEFITS THAT MIGHT BE JUST
ICING ON THE CAKE FOR SOMETHING
THAT SOMEBODY SHOULD PAY FOR
THEMSELVES SO.
YOU KNOW IT'S EXCITING
GUT SINGS GO THROUGH THIS IT'S
CHALLENGING BUT WE HAVE TO DO
THIS AND WE HAVE TO STICK A YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO STICK WITH THE
PROCESS THAT WE'VE DONE.
DESIGNED.
THE OTHER POINT I'D MAKE A AND
THIS IS A TWO TO REINFORCE WHAT
POINTS OF MISTER JONES JUST
MADE.
IS THAT.
I I DON'T THINK ANY OF US HAVE
AN OBJECTION TO IMPROVING THE
DIALOGUE BETWEEN APPLICANTS IN
THE COMMISSION BUT REMEMBER THIS
IS A COMPETITIVE PUBLIC PROCESS.
LET ME REPEAT THAT A COMPETITIVE
PUBLIC PROCESS AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PUBLIC TO
BE ABLE TO REVIEW THE
APPLICATIONS TO REVIEW THE
RATINGS TO REVIEW THE APPEALS TO
UNDERSTAND THE DIALOGUE BETWEEN
THE APPLICANTS AND COMMISSION IS
JUST AS IMPORTANT AS AS THE
OTHER PARTS. SO WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE TIME
ADEQUATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENGAGE.
I AND SO AS WE LOOK AT ON.
SCHEDULE MORE MEETINGS YOU KNOW
FIDDLING WITH PROCESS DON'T
FORGET THAT PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT.
PART BECAUSE IF YOU TINKER WITH
THE PROCESS THAT YOU HAVE TO
ALSO TINKER WITH THE PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT ELEMENT OF IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
SINGER NO ONE ELSE OPIATES
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OUT JUST WHAT TO SAY A
COUPLE THINGS VERY QUICKLY FIRST
AND FOREMOST.
.
ONE DAY YOU'RE GONNA BE A PATH
LEGISLATOR LIKE ME.
AND WATCH BILLS THAT YOU MOVE
THROUGH ITS ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINE WE WROTE THIS.
.
THE LANGUAGE IS PRETTY MUCH THE
SAME IF NOT EXACTLY THE SAME AND
BACK IT IS THE SAME IN THIS
PARTICULAR SECTION.
WHEN THEY'RE STEINBERG IN THE
LEGISLATURE CAME BACK AND
REWROTE IT. AND THE ISSUE WAS A
HAIRCUT. AND A HAIRCUT OCCURRED
FROM ELEVEN BILLION DOWN TO
SEEN POINT BLANK.
I'VE IT'S INTERESTING TO NOTE
THAT THIS SECTION I WAS THE
LEAST IMPACTED.
SO EDUARDO EVERYTHING WAS CUT A
AT THE END THE DAY IT CAME DOWN
TO.
HAVING THE REQUISITE REPUBLICAN
VOTES.
TO BALANCE THE PACKAGE THAT
WOULD GET THE SIGNED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN THAT WAS DONE.
BUT I THINK WHAT IS CONCERNING
TO ME AND I JUST WANT THE NEWER
MEMBERS PARTICULARLY AT THINK
MISS RUBIO HIT IT RIGHT ON THE
HEAD IS THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
SOMETHING ISN'T WORKING YOU JUST
CAN SEE IT.
YOU CAN SMELL IT IT'S THE REASON
YOU'RE ELECTED OFFICIALS YOU
HAVE INSTINCTS.
AND YOUR INSTINCTS ARE SUPPOSE
TO BE USE FOR THE PUBLIC THE
PUBLIC ONLY OPPORTUNITY FOR
OVERSIGHT STE
STANDS RIGHT HERE.
SO I WILL SAY THAT.
LEGISLATORS PASS BILLS OF THERE
ARE WONDERFUL BUT IT DOESN'T
MEAN MUCH IF THERE'S NO
OVERSIGHT TO SEE IF THOSE BILLS
YEARS LATER. ARE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT IT
SO I WANT TO CONGRATULATE THE
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS FOR ASKING
THE REAL TOUGH QUESTIONS.
THE KEY TO THIS IS TO STAY ON
IT.
I TELL YOU TO HAVE OVERSIGHT
CONTINUE TO ASK QUESTIONS TILL
THAT MONEY IS ALLOCATED.
AND IN FACT IF YOU LOOK OF THIS
BOND IT'S FUNNY THAT SOME OF THE
MONEY NOW IS NOT ONLY GONE BUT
IT'S OVERSUBSCRIBED SO HE LOOKED
RECYCLED WATER LOOK AT THE OTHER
PIECES OF THIS.
YOU SEE THAT MONEY HAS GONE OUT
THE DOOR VERY QUICKLY.
I WILL TELL YOU THAT WHEN WE DID
THIS WEEK GAVE THIS AUTHORITY TO
THE CALIFORNIA WATER COMMISSION
AND NO SLIGHT TO RECRUIT MEMBERS
ARE WONDERFUL BUT IT WAS A VERY
SLEEPY LITTLE COMMISSION.
AND WAS SLEEPY BECAUSE WE KNEW
THAT WE GAVE IT TO STATE WATER
RESOURCES.
THAT STAFF WAS GOING TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT OCCURRED HERE.
AND WE KNEW THE SENATE TO THE W.
OUR STAFF IS GOING TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT IT DID HERE.
AND THE GOAL OF THAT WATER
COMMISSION WAS TO GET NINE
STRONG MEMBERS THAT WOULD GET
STAFF TO GET THIS MONEY
OUT THE DOOR.
PERIOD.
WHAT OUT IN SOME SENSE GOING SO
DEEP?
THAT WE HAVE FORGOTTEN.
THE ORIGINAL PURPOSE.
AT THIS PARTICULAR BOND WAS
STORAGE.
THE ONLY THINGS YOU DO YOUR
OVERSIGHT AND THE STAFF
CONTINUES TO MOVE THROUGH THEIR
PROCESS THAT I APPRECIATE IT
LEAVE AFTER THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD I KNOW
REGULATION IT WILL MAKE.
BUT AT THIS POINT.
S. RUBIO SAID WITH FOUR YEARS
DOWN THE LINE AND A BIG STORM
COMING AND TODAY.
WITH VERY LITTLE PLACES TO STORE
IT.
WITH ANTIOCH REFERS ALL OVER THE
STATE BELOW GROUND.
SOME SENSE TO ME THIS IS A VERY
TIMELY HEARING.
AS IS VERY BIG STORM OCCURS AND
I WOULD JUST SAY PUT THE
LEGISLATORS.
TEN YEAR OVERSIGHT IT TRULY IS.
THAT STRONGEST POWERS YOU HAVE.
PERIOD
BECAUSE IF YOU'LL PASS BILLS AND
LEAVE AND YOU MIGHT BE SITTING
HERE LIKE I AM.
SHAKING YOUR HEAD WONDERING AT
SOME POINT IN TIME.
WHEN THAT BILL IS ACTUALLY GOING
TO BE.
SUCH WANT THANK YOU CONTINUE
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR YOUR GOOD
WORK AND AND
FRANK AND OTHERS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
TO MEMBER RUBIO I JUST HOPE YOU
STAY ON THIS BECAUSE THIS IS NOT
OVER.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND AGAIN
THANK ALL THE PANELISTS ALONG
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES AT THAT.
TENDED TODAY'S HEARING AYE WE
WILL ADJOURN AT THIS MEETING
THANK YOU